only on c-span 2
created by the cable television industry
next on encore book notes charles
fetcher discusses his work editing the
diary of h.l menken he describes the
unsealing of menkin's personal papers in
1985 which led to the publishing of the
diary mr fetcher talks about menkin's
work at the baltimore sun as well as his
views on contemporaries including f
scott fitzgerald and franklin delano
roosevelt it's just under an hour
charles fetcher editor of the diary of
h.l mencken what's been the most
surprising thing
that's happened since the publication
uh the the uproar
surrounding the publication i was
totally unprepared for anything like
this
i expected that the book would generate
some controversy because h l mankind
never wrote a book that didn't but i did
not expect
what happened
who uproared the most
uh reviewers and critics
all critical
uh no no not all by any means the the
initial reaction was highly critical
of mankind
but then some calmer voices began to be
heard
and i would say that at the present time
the reaction
is about 50 pro and 50 khan
is there anything to criticize
him for as a result of this information
uh the diary reveals a strain of
anti-semitism
of racism
of what the media has called bigotry
uh
it reveals a pro-german
sympathy
that sort of thing uh you know none of
this was entirely new anyone who was
familiar with mankind's work
would have known that those things were
in there it's simply that in the diary
they are stated
more strongly and starkly
than they ever were and what he
published during his own lifetime
let's start at the beginning who is h.l
mencken h l menken was a newspaper man
magazine editor author
philologist
and
critic of
the national mores
from about the turn of the century 1900
uh up until the time of his death in
1956
he reached the peak of his reputation
in the 1920s and 30s
when walter lippmann called him the most
powerful personal influence
on this whole generation of educated
people
and the new york times called him the
most powerful private citizen in america
what's a philologist a philologist is a
person who studies the origins and
meanings of words
mankind wrote a book called the american
language
which is a study of the way that the
english language developed in the united
states
he published the first edition in 1919
there were second and third editions in
1921 and 23.
in 1936 he totally rewrote the entire
book to bring out a fourth edition and
then subsequently he brought out two
supplements to that edition
so what you have are four thick volumes
run uh six thick volumes
running to about 3 800 pages
of study of the american language of the
english language in the united states
where did he live
in baltimore his life long he was born
there lived there and died there and he
lived in one of the city's typical brick
front row houses
for all but about eight of his 75 years
and where do you live
i live uh in a similar
community uh called govens in north
baltimore which again is row houses
where did these diaries come from
when mankind died he left the diary
along with a mass of other papers to the
enoch pratt free library in baltimore
enoch
pratt and what's that it is baltimore's
public library
and mankind had used it from the time he
was nine years old
uh all of his papers were deposited with
the pratt library
the diary and some other papers were
given to them with a stipulation that
they could not be opened until 25 years
after his death
and the 25th anniversary of his death
was in january of 1981
but it wasn't until a number of years
after that
that the library uh
decided to publish the diary
how did you get involved
well uh in 1978 i published a book on
mankind called mankind to study this
thought
which was also published by alfred a
knopf the publisher of all of mankind's
books
and the publisher of the diary
when it was decided to publish the diary
i of course
applied
you submitted my application for the job
that there were any number of other
applications i know
of the various applicants the library
selected me what were you doing before
that
are you a writer by training uh
well i
would like to say that i am a writer
i've never made a living at it uh
i worked for a good many years for the
archdiocese of baltimore
in various capacities and retired from
there in 1982.
i've been retired since
uh i suppose some of the considerations
that led them to give me the job of
editing the diary
uh or the fact that i had written the
other book about him
uh the fact that i was a native
baltimorean and knew the whole
background many of the people he talks
about in the diary
and was retired said i could give it my
full time
when did you first get interested in h.l
menken
uh so far back that i can hardly tell
you when it first happened
uh mankind wrote a series of articles
for the evening sun the baltimore
evening sun
they were known as the monday articles
they appeared on the editorial page of
the evening sun
uh every monday from 1920 until 1938
and i first became acquainted with him
in
those monday articles
uh
i i don't go back to 1920 but i can't
remember
uh the the later years you know the
middle 30s
uh i fell in love with his style his
manner of expression
and with his ideas and this began a love
affair that has gone on ever since
i bought his various books as they came
out
and uh
read everything by and about him that i
could get ahold of
if you go to the national press club
here in washington there's a h l mencken
library and
as we're talking a major controversy is
whether or not to continue calling it
the h.l menken library yes i know
uh because of the anti-semitism and
racism expressed in the diary
the national press club felt that they
did not want their library to be named
after a person with
with these ideas
and the proposal has been made to
take his name off of the library
uh i would hope that
calmer minds will prevail
and that the proposal will not go thrill
why
because mankind was above all else a
newspaper man he was probably the
greatest journalist
this country has ever seen
uh and the national press club and
naming its library after him
recognized that fact
and the fact is not changed
because the diary reveals some
disagreeable
aspects of his personality
reveals his weaknesses as well as his
strengths
are there people that are genuinely
shocked by what they read here and
surprised yes yes there's no question
about that
should they be
i suppose they have every right to be
i said earlier that anyone who knows
mankind's work would have been prepared
for this
if you did not know mankind very well
then the anti-semitism and the racism
revealed in the diary would come as a
shock
from your perspective what what was it
about his writing that made him so good
primarily i would say the style no other
man in american literature has ever
written like him his style is utterly
unique
he's one of the great humorists in
american literature
uh there are passages by him that you
can't read without bursting into guffaws
now you know style is only one aspect of
writer's equipment uh he must also have
ideas
to express
and and mankind did uh the the range of
his uh interests and activities was
enormous he wrote about politics
literature
uh civic affairs
uh politicians
uh
mostly i would say politicians
what do you think of politicians uh he
didn't like any of them he said that a
good politician is as unthinkable as an
honest burglar
no politician at all that he liked uh in
in theory yes in actual practice there
were of course men whom he knew
personally and liked and respected
let me read from your introduction okay
roosevelt this is uh franklin roosevelt
was a quote world saver
his political and economic premises were
quote so false as to be absurd the
conclusions he drew from these those
premises were quote always dubious and
sometimes completely idiotic
is that strong for mankind no that for
mankind that's rather mild
he wrote about all presidents of the
united states like this
you describe
an appearance by the president uh
roosevelt fdr in front of the gridiron
club and uh that mr macon was sitting
there in the audience can you tell us
about that
uh mankin had been invited to be the
speaker at this dinner of the gridiron
club in 1934 i think it was
uh he gone up and delivered what was uh
a critical
but essentially
good-natured and humorous
uh
talk about roosevelt's new deal and of
course he found plenty of fault with it
he claimed that the only provision of
the constitution that had not been
violated by the new deal
was the uh prohibition of quartering
soldiers in people's private homes
a little later it was the president's
turn to speak
he got up and began
a vicious attack
on newspapermen and journalism
an attack that had cold chills running
up and down the spines of the people
listening to him
finally they realized that what he was
doing was reading a piece called
journalism in america which had been
written by mankind himself
and published in his magazine the
american mercury
so uh you know the president was
attacking
journalists and and mankind in menkin's
own words
menken felt publicly humiliated by this
and swore that he would get even
although of course there was really no
way that he could ever get even except
to write more and more bitter attacks
upon roosevelt and the great iron club
the room was full of journalists yes of
course
you also write in your introduction
he had castigated and ridiculed presence
before almost as a matter of policy
harding the num skull
coolidge a cheap and trashy fellow a
dreadful little cat
hoover
where his car where his character ought
to be there is almost a blank
did uh did this have any impact on the
public oh yes i think so how
uh because of his enormous reputation as
a political commentator
and journalist
these monday articles in the baltimore
evening song that i spoke of
uh were
known and uh
quoted all over the country but you
could only read them in the baltimore
evening center i i think they were
syndicated in some papers
go back to uh 1956 that was the year of
his death yes had you ever have you ever
met him no no he never did
have you talked to people who have met
him yes a number of them yes what was he
like to know
according to everybody who ever knew him
he was one of the kindest most courteous
most gentle and most considerate persons
you can imagine
how did he write i mean when did he
write what was his style uh he wrote
with a bludgeon
he he hurled thunderbolts at everybody
was he a morning writer an afternoon
writer did he uh uh did he write with a
typewriter longhand
all his work was done as a typewriter
uh my impression is
that most of his work was done in the
afternoon and evening
was he a drinker
uh
yes he was if you mean by that was he an
alcoholic
uh no by no means he was a very careful
and cagey drinker
uh among his friends were authors like
sinclair lewis and scott fitzgerald
uh and he blamed them for the fact that
what he considered their excessive
drinking
had destroyed their their literary gifts
and he himself had very careful rules
about what
when
and where he drank
and uh that you know there is no record
that he was ever at any time
uh
under the influence of
you say um
let it be said at once clearly and
unequivocably uh equivocally that menken
was an anti-semite and then you go on to
uh
the difficulty in reading all this it
just fuels the whole
discussion and and that's why i hesitate
um he you go on to write that uh
lawrence spivak who was to become
publisher of the mercury is a young
harvard jew the young harvard jew is
quote unquote from lincoln uh is that
the same large pivac that went on to do
meat yes yes it is the wife of a
distinguished johns hopkins professor is
characterized in two words french jewess
charles angov enghof
no
hangoff
quote like most of the other young
jewish intellectuals unquote inclines
toward communism samuel elliott morrison
the great historian is quoted as telling
him that the students in his class at
johns hopkins are quote mainly jews why
was this such a bother to him
i i don't know uh you know i i can't
pretend to explain it
uh
there there was unquestionably
uh an overt or i should say a covert
uh anti-semitism in the air and culture
of that time
uh it wasn't the kind of
psychotic and murderous anti-semitism
that occurred in germany with the rise
of the nazis it was a more quiet thing i
i know that in my own baltimore and i
suppose this is true of other cities too
uh there were neighborhoods that were
restricted in quotes
but this meant the jews could not move
into them
there were clubs the jews could not be
long till
uh there were swimming pools the jews
could not go in
and there were lots of other
restrictions
placed upon them
uh what was his religion
lincoln did not believe in anything did
he go to the church ever no he was a
strict diagnostic
um
one of the ironies uh
this book is published this the diary
here hold up to the arts you can see is
published by
kanawha publishers
and mr kanoff was jewish yes and one of
mankind's closest friends when did is he
still alive no no he died uh five or six
years ago i think was there ever any
consideration by the canal publishing
company
that by publishing these diaries they're
fueling the whole anti-semitism again
i i'm not aware of any such
consideration
uh i mean in the course of your
conversations with them that never came
up and i never worried about uh
at the beginning of my work on the diary
when i was just getting started on it
uh i wrote to the senior vice president
and editor
at
pointing out to him that these things
were in there and that to do an honest
editing job
uh it would be necessary to
to use them
and he wrote back and said uh he agreed
completely and that
there was no point in trying to cover
them up
start with the diaries um
how did he keep these diaries
uh
he began them in 1930 when he was
already 50 years old
and for a while he kept at it fairly
regularly not not daily by any means
there might be long stretches of several
weeks where he wouldn't touch it and
then there might be a period where he
would
you know make an entry almost every day
in 1935 his wife died
and after that for a long time he gave
it up almost entirely it wasn't until
like 1937 or 38
uh that he resumed it on anything like a
regular basis
uh
and then in the 1940s he really took it
seriously the the entries for those
years
uh are lengthy
uh he did it as a typewriter
as i said he never wrote anything in
longhand
the the result i suppose is starting out
in life as a newspaper reporter
uh
about half the diaries in his own typing
about half of it is in the typing of the
secretary mrs larfink
and did he only keep these diaries for
18 years
yes
that's it
that's it
now when you started with this when did
you physically start with this project
about
1987 i suppose 1986 or 87. and once you
showed up to work one day where did you
go and what did somebody hand you
well
the frat library handed me the total
diary
uh it was it was boxed in in five
volumes it was sealed in five boxes let
us say
each one with a label on it initially by
him
saying that it was not to be opened
until 25 years after his death
uh
i was given a xerox
copy all the way through from beginning
to end of the diary
and the first thing i had to do was make
a selection this this by the way is by
no means the total diary
the diary runs to something like 2100
pages of double-spaced typing which
would make three books the size of that
one how many words is that i would
estimate it somewhere between five
hundred thousand and six hundred
thousand
uh so the first thing i had to do was
make a selection
and get it down to a volume of
manageable size
uh what you see here in this book was
what i selected and it is about
one-third
of the total diary are you going to do
another
no there are no plans to bring out uh
the unused two-thirds
now when you had a glance at this first
in 1987
there had been a period between 1981 and
1987 that these diaries were allowed to
be seen by someone
the library made them available to
those who had already established
themselves as mankind scholars
people who had written books or articles
about him who were engaged upon research
about him and they made them available
to scholars in some related fields for
example there was a man
at that time doing a history of the
baltimore sun papers for
the occasion of its 150th anniversary
uh and you know this book is loaded with
material about the sun papers so you
know the diary was made available to him
but it was not generally available
and even those who were allowed to see
it
had to swear solemnly in writing that
they would not quote from it or
paraphrase it or use it in any way in
their writings
there was a problem
getting a decision
to actually publish why
i spoke of the fact that there were was
a label on each one of the boxes
initialed by him
that label said that it was not to be
opened until 25 years after his death
and that even after that it was to be
made available only to scholars engaged
in serious research
uh this created the problem or uh
brought up the question
did menken ever intend the diary to be
published at all
the board of trustees of the pratt
library debated this question for a long
time
and they sought a legal ruling from
stephen h sachs who was at that time
attorney general of the state of
maryland
as to whether in view of what was said
on the labels
the library
could publish them
mr sachs ruled that the labels did not
have the legal formality
uh required for wills
and that therefore the library was
within its rights in publishing them
do you think that h.l menken would be
pleased that these diaries were
published
i don't think menken ever wrote a single
word
that he didn't envisage being published
sometime
so i think yes he would be pleased and
doubtless highly amused by all the
reaction to it put the actual diaries
into context with everything else he was
doing i mean this wasn't the only
writing he was doing during these 18
years
and what was the style of writing the
diaries compared to other things well
the diaries are much rougher
they don't have the finished polish
style of the published books
they don't have the high humor of the
published books
and this is not to say that they're
serious or somber in tone they're not
uh it was impossible for him to write
anything somber
even when he's complaining about his
health which he says constantly through
here
you say it was a hypochondriac oh god
yes yes one of the worst in the world
was he really was he sick very often
uh you know there's no doubt that in
later years his health declined
uh he was really a candidate for high
blood pressure and a stroke
and of course this was a stroke that
eventually finished his career
uh
i i don't know how much of the
complaining about his health in the
diary was genuine and how much was just
hypochondria
at uh at what time did he would he write
the diary compared to everything else he
was writing during a day was at the end
of the day i i would imagine so there's
no indication
uh as i said about half of it is his own
typing and half of it is in the typing
of the secretary
and it's very easy to distinguish
between them
apparently on days when he had the time
and i would imagine this was late in the
you know sometime after dinner
uh he would
sit down at his own typewriter
and type a diary entry
uh when time did not permit he would
dictate it to his secretary along with
the mail he had for her
and she would type it
you've got a lot of photographs in here
and i want to hold a couple of them up
and and take a look at them and have you
explain what they are
uh on the screen right now is a
photo of
mr menken and who
george gene nathan
who was a close friend of menkins and
incidentally also jewish
uh they worked on the smart set magazine
for
from 1908 to 1923.
mankind was the book editor nathan was
the drama critic
in 1914 they became the co-editors of
the magazine
and it was during those years that they
both became famous for their
their irreverence
their pungent style and for the
influence they had on
in menken's case
literature in nathan's case the drama
what's this picture below
that is a picture taken on boston common
at the time of the famous hat rack case
which occurred in 1926.
is making in this picture uh yes he's
the one holding up that sheet of paper
in the center
uh he was editor of the american mercury
magazine by then uh he and nathan gave
up the smart set at the end of 1923 and
started a new magazine called the
american mercury at the beginning of
1924
uh which immediately became one of the
most influential
magazines
of of that period
uh
in 1926 in april i believe it was the
magazine was banned in boston by an
organization called the watch and ward
society
uh because of an article in it called
half rack
the story of a prostitute in a little
midwestern town
uh a man named chase who had at the
watching ward society
uh thought that the article was obscene
and uh ordered
all boston newsstands and book dealers
not to sell it
now chase's society had no legal
standing whatever
but it had such enormous influence that
book dealers
and newsstands were afraid to buck him
so they took it off of their stands
uh mankind heard about this and went up
to boston
and sold a copy of the magazine on
boston common and was promptly arrested
for
selling obscene
literature
uh the next morning when the case came
up in court the judge who had read
hackrack the night before threw the case
out of court he said that there was no
evidence of uh
obscenity in it at all
so you know there mankind won although
in the long haul he lost
because chase succeeded in having the
issue
barred from the males
now this was a moot point since it's
already been mailed out anyway
but it was necessary to go through a
long hearing before the postmaster
general
and
there menken lost
he and his publisher cannot consider
taking the case to the supreme court but
it would have been too long and
too expensive and they never did
i have a photo here in just a moment of
uh
h.l menken and
second wife
no he was only married only married once
yes
he married at the age of 50 in 1930. um
i know what confused me you say he she
died in 1935 that's right and they were
only married for how long five years
what impact did she have on his life a
tremendous one
uh he had met her seven years before
they got married
and there's no doubt that he was deeply
and romantically smitten by her from the
very beginning
there was an 18-year age difference
between them
uh
when they married he was 50 and she was
thirty still
uh
she
was in poor health
she had a number of serious
operations over the time that he knew
her
when he married her the doctors told
him that she did not have more than
three years to live
actually she lived five
uh and
he says in the diary you know they were
the five
happiest and most fulfilling years of
his life
and there's no doubt that her death left
a tremendous void
in his life and not all of his
activities ever suffice to fill that up
why did she have so much impact on him
why did she have someone what was it
about the relationship that
what does he say about the relationship
that was so important to him she was a
beautiful charming intelligent woman
and he never married before that or
after that's right yes what did her
death do to him and what what what can
you read through the diaries that
give you an impression of uh the fact
that he writes so often uh of how much
he misses her
the hardly a day goes by that he doesn't
think of her didn't he say even
somewhere in one of these
uh one of the entries that an hour
doesn't go by without him thinking yeah
yes it's probably yes probably so and
every day he thinks of something he
wants to tell her or see something that
he wants to buy for her
another photograph of um
h.l making by the way what does hl stand
for henry lewis
who is he named after
anybody
uh
henry was the name of his uncle
uh who lived next door to them by the
way
and louis uh
was the name of a long since
dead
uh child of his
grandfathers by another marriage this
child died in infancy was named lewis
and for some reason uh which nobody
could possibly figure out today
uh little henry was named was given the
middle name lewis
did he always part his hair down the
middle yes
did he ever say why
no nothing i'm aware of when was this
picture taken the little one the little
one about
i think about 1942
and the one below it the one below it is
i believe dated 1939
uh
it's the backyard garden of their row
house of 1524 holland street in west
baltimore and he and his brother spent a
tremendous amount of time in the garden
uh
planting flowers in the spring and
pulling them up in the fall and enjoying
them in between
what were his politics
uh he was an incurable conservative and
tory
any reason that he gives why
no uh
there are i suppose a number of reasons
that would have contributed to it
uh his solid germanic background
uh
the
the flavor and atmosphere and culture of
baltimore
uh in that period
uh the fact that his father owned a
business
uh which he wanted henry to succeed him
in
uh so that his father was in at least a
modest sense of the word a capitalist
and you know mankind believed in in the
virtues of uh
capitalism
and uh
bourgeois values
very much did he make any money in his
life
uh
yes he did
uh you know he was
he was uh one of those very rare
creatures a financially successful
author
now obviously he did not get the kind of
advances on his books that are given on
some books today
in fact he didn't believe in advances he
never took one
he took his royalties when the book had
been published and was selling but he
never took an advance in his life
that and uh what he earned from the sun
papers
for being a columnist and an editorial
advisor
uh plus the fact that uh
you know his father had left the family
pretty well uh
taken care of at his death
so omega never had any real really
serious money worries
the american mercury
was a publication that lasted how long
uh well if you're asking how long it
lasted it came down to relatively modern
uh recent times
uh the great mankind period
began in 1924
and he resigned the editorship of it in
1933. what did it look like it was a
magazine with an arsenic green cover
this cover was uniform from beginning to
end as far as color was concerned
uh and general design although the
design was changed a little bit
over the years
and who wrote for it
oh an enormous number of people
it was primarily devoted to political
and social commentary
some literary criticism some fiction and
poetry but not much
uh
you know it dealt with the
social political
economic problems of that era
and
many people
many writers contributed to it
it has been said that
it was a one-man magazine which it was
really it reflected menken's personality
and anybody whose ideas differed from
menkins
wouldn't have much chance of getting
published in it
uh it was even said that mankind rewrote
the articles that were contributed to it
uh so that they would reflect his views
he himself denied this and and i believe
that his denial you know was sincere uh
i i don't think he would have changed
other people's writings
but but the articles that appeared had
to be in agreement with his own
philosophy
let's go back to your work on this uh
this book first of all let's see it
sells for thirty dollars yes expensive
yes it is
any trouble selling it you know
uh i think it has been selling pretty
well i i don't have any figures on it
but uh in baltimore and washington when
it came out the early part of last month
book sellers could not keep it in stock
did uh the publisher tell you why they
put such a high
premium on it uh no
but you know i think that's fairly
standard for books in today's market
you started on this in 1987
when did you finish it
uh the completed manuscript was probably
turned in about september of 1989.
[Music]
how did you go about no september of
1988 i'm sorry
how did i go about how did you go about
doing this well as i said first of all i
had to make a selection right from the
total how did you do that did you read
every word oh yes yes i had to how long
did that take you
not long
uh a matter of a few weeks
uh
and the the job of making this selection
was not all that difficult
uh you you may wonder what's in the
other two thirds it's part that i didn't
use
but but really what's in it uh you know
is more complaints about his health
uh he was a member of the board of
directors of the a.s able company the
publishers of the baltimore sun papers
and the director of alfred a knopf
incorporated his publisher
and many of the entries are a little
more than minutes of board meetings of
these companies
and a very little interest to anybody
today
so you point out that actually his
his writing about the board meetings
were better than the minutes themselves
they probably were
i'm sure they were
but anyhow you know those things i
pulled out well i tried to give as
representative
a glimpse as i could of all his
activities
you know as an author as a newspaper man
as a family man
uh
as a friend of authors and musicians and
so on
and you know this is what you have
in in this volume
then of course i have to settle down to
the job of annotating
because many of the people he mentions
the most i suppose
many of the events he talks about
would have meant little or nothing to
today's readers
so i had to provide an enormous amount
of well a relatively enormous amount of
annotation
at the bottom of every page explaining
who so and so was
or what this refers to that sort of
thing
where did you do that everything was
done at the pratt library in baltimore i
never had to go anyplace else for any
information i needed and as you were
doing this who helped you
make sure that i mean who edited you
well no one really until i submitted the
manuscript to the publisher
you the reason i ask you that as you
mentioned uh in the introduction
um
i owe do vincent fitzpatrick
assistant curator of pratt's mink and
rome
who knows more about its contents than
any other person on earth
with him i could discuss any problem
arose any doubt in my mind this is what
i want to ask you about he read the
first draft of this introduction
disagreed vigorously with some of the
things in it what did he disagree with
well
you know i i don't remember all of them
because this was more than a year ago
but what kind of things
i assume is he a real expert on h.l yes
yes indeed he is uh he disagreed with my
flat statement to mention with anthony
semi
among other things that's just one
example
and why would he based on what you read
here that it's rather clear how he feels
about i can't say
you know are there people that are
worried that this will do great damage
to h.l menken oh there are yes no
question about it and will it
that's pretty hard to say
uh my own fear when when the book
hit the stands
and all the hullabaloo started was that
it might permanently
damage his reputation
uh now i'm not so sure i i really
believe
that he he will survive
in spite of
the new i the new material has come out
about him
uh
i say that because
the american language for example is
still one of the greatest works of
scholarship of our time
his three volume autobiography today's
books still makes the most delightful
reading you can imagine
uh he still remains one of the most
important and influential critics in the
first half of this century
uh all that
is there and you know the things in the
diary don't change that
so i i don't think
uh
that it's going to permanently damage
his reputation obviously
uh scholars who write about him from now
on future biographers and critics are
going to have to take what is in there
into consideration and deal with it
as they see fit
uh
but you know i still think his
reputation will survive now if somebody
wants to go see the rest of these
diaries for any reason is it available
are they available
uh they're in the private library you
know you would have to be engaged in
some kind of scholarly research
involving them to get permission to see
them so you just can't walk in and say i
want to see the rest now them
why are they so cautious with that why
don't they bind them
put them in a on the shelf and let
anybody come in and look at them
uh
because well first of all the re the
reason they didn't let anybody see them
originally
was because you know there was always
the thought in mind that eventually they
might be published
and the library wished to hold their
contents
in the reserve until such time as it was
published
now that a portion of it has been
uh
the restrictions so far as i am aware
still apply
on the agreement the unused portion of
it
because there's always the possibility
that someday
the diary may be published in its
entirety uh there are no plans for this
at the moment
but somewhere down the road a university
press
may want to publish the total diary
in a relatively limited edition for the
use of scholars
and
for that reason
you know the library is holding on to
them
who gets the profits for that library
and what do they do with that is it go
does it go right into the menken section
of the library or does it or do you know
i i really can't answer that question is
if you go to the pratt library what kind
of a
area is set aside from minkin alone
there is a mankind room on the third
floor what's in it
uh
mankin kept every sheet of paper i think
that he ever
typed on in that room are
the volumes bound in blue morocco
bindings which must have been extremely
expensive even then
of all his books
all his magazine articles and newspaper
columns
i i spoke of the monday articles which
ran from 1920 to 1938 there are 18 big
volumes
each one containing a year's monday
articles his original manuscripts and
the
cutouts
of the article from the paper
uh
there's an enormous amount of
correspondence
and then his personal library
of quite a few thousand volumes was also
bequeathed by him and is in the banking
room
here's a photograph of him um with a
cigar in his mouth is that
one of his trademarks oh yes yes he
always had a cigar in his mouth where is
this picture taken that is in his second
floor study is a house on holland street
looking out the the front window across
to union square
across the street what have they done
with this house his house is now a uh
baltimore city museum
it has been restored
uh so far as possible to the what it was
when he and his brother august live
there
uh it is open to the public
right now an effort is being there was a
picture you showed earlier in the
backyard garden right now they're trying
to restore that garden to what it was in
his time
when he was a reporter
um and what were the years that he
actually did reporting for the baltimore
paper well he went to work about 1900
for the baltimore morning herald which
is long since extinct
uh the herald folded up i think about
1906
and he went to work for the sun papers
and was with them
until
his stroke in 1948 would he actually
physically go out i mean like for
instance would he come to washington and
talk to presidents and senators and
congressmen or did he just write his
opinion
uh he interviewed many of the important
politicians and statesmen at this time
uh but
very early
he shot up so fast in the newspaper
business
uh you know that he in a relatively
short time he was uh in a managerial and
supervisory capacity
so he
he did relatively little
newspaper reporting in the course of his
life he wouldn't he would undertake
certain assignments for example he
always covered the national
political conventions the democratic and
republican conventions
matter of fact uh we have a photographer
from the national republican convention
in this how many entries are there in
the the diary here that you've done
how many entries different days that he
writes about oh i really have no idea
what the number of entries are
what about your favorites
oh i i have some favorites of course
uh one is the long and very beautiful
entry
on may the 31st 1940 the 50th the fifth
anniversary of his wife's death
uh
between the time that she died and that
entry there is no mention
of the fact in the diary at all you
wouldn't even know that uh
she had died in fact you wouldn't know
you've been married and then on may 31st
1940 he writes this beautiful and very
long entry about our life together
about uh how much she meant to him about
our travels together and so on
uh that would certainly be one of my
favorites
uh there's one about a trip that he and
a friend of his joseph hergersheim are a
novelist of the period
uh made through the pennsylvania dutch
country which is very interesting
uh
and of course you know he
in new york he met for lunch or dinner
novelists like theodore dreiser
poets like edgar lee masters
his accounts of uh you know having a
meal with them and what they talked
about
are fascinating who did he like the most
in people
who yeah what kind of people did he like
he writes a lot about people he didn't
like yeah
uh
you know i i don't know if you can
generalize and say you know what kind of
person he liked
uh
he was obviously
drawn to writers or who's or who were
his closest friends
writers
uh
journalists and musicians and doctors
his attitude toward black people was a
curious mingling of total
of total egalitarianism on the one hand
and patronizing superiority on the other
you say that uh
things just didn't make sense that he
had people that work for him that he was
tremendously kind to that's right
what did you conclude tell us more about
that though
uh menken
published black writers in the american
mercury at a time when there were very
few markets
for the work of black writers
he encouraged his publisher alfred knuff
to bring out their books
uh he played a very important part
an inspirational part
in the harlem renaissance of the 1920s
uh he knew and was on friendly terms
with and corresponded with many
important black people of that period
uh and you know he he and his brother
had two black women who uh cooked and
cleaned for them and
obviously he was very fond of them took
the most complete care of them
he paid their medical bills if they got
sick
uh you know uh
here you have what i call the
egalitarianism
but at the same time
uh
there's no question but he thought that
black people
uh were inferior to white
uh you know and speaking of these two
black women who worked for him uh he
speaks of their belonging to the
afro-american race and bearing many of
its psychological stigmata
and you quote him as saying here in the
introduction it is impossible he held to
talk about this is quoting to talk about
anything resembling discretion or
judgment in a colored woman they are all
essentially childlike and even hard
experience does not teach them anything
now are you going to ask me to explain
the paradox here
not necessarily i mean you want to go
right ahead uh no i can't yeah uh he was
a complex and contradictory person
guess what i really wanted to ask you
was um
do you expect
journalists now in the world we live in
today to be able to sort through all
this and in the end accept him
and still revere him as one of the great
journalists of all time
uh
you know i i myself
in spite of the fact that i have been a
man can buff all my life
uh and admire him and enjoy him
tremendously
you know i i would not say that i revere
him
and i wouldn't expect anybody else to
revere him
uh but you know i i would expect
somebody else and especially journalists
uh to respect him
for his tremendous abilities as a
journalist and writer
do you think that a lot of journalists
who would use his name all the time as
being one of their idols as a writer
really knew
the story here that you
tell in this book
no they did not
what's that say about journalists
and their ability to investigate
anything
well perhaps so but you have to remember
that they had no access to this anyway
but you said when we started this that
it should come as no surprise if you'd
ever read menken over the years
yes that's right there are
indications of anti-semitism
and of his feelings about black people
scattered here and there
in his published writings but you know i
i think that most of us you know i was
one of them
uh i just skimmed over this and ignored
it
and did not let it get in the way of our
admiration for him
have you done much
talking about this book have you
traveled much with it or is this thing
just taken off on its own it's pretty
much taken off on its own i've had quite
a few interviews
uh
and news with newspaper people and uh
radio talk shows and on television
what are the questions you're asked the
most often
uh how do i account for the
anti-semitism and the racism
is
if somebody gets this book and looks in
it are there going to be some surprises
based on you know lots i mean i've got
here a stack of
paper
all the reviews and everything's been
done but are people going to be
surprised by things that have not even
been touched
i mean are there major stories in here
from your perspective that that no one's
written about that
no no i wouldn't say so no no major
stories
you know uh
this is not going to make previous
biographies and studies of mankind
obsolete you know uh as i said in my
introduction
uh it tells us things about him that we
had not hitherto known but it doesn't
tell us anything basically different
uh
you know what it adds it it adds in
in detail not not in any major
revelations
there's another thing that caught my eye
you say has um
that
the story goes that he once read his own
obituary in the sun files meaning the
baltimore sun files approved it
and directed that a single sentence be
added at the end quote as he got older
he got worse
and then you say this was undoubtedly
true what did you mean by that oh
there's no question that he became
very crotchety
and stubborn and set in his ways
uh
he must not have been an easy person to
get along with
uh you know he
he was one of the great humorists of the
time and i think he was this
in person as well as in print
for the most part i don't think he ever
lost his his good humor
or
his
ability to relate to people in his
uh generosity and politeness too
uh but he did become said in his ways
that there were certain things that you
know he believed
and uh
the rest of the world believed otherwise
which meant that the rest of the world
was wrong and he was right
uh and uh
you know
he just became a
crotchety as i said and said in his ways
you said he was a conservative yes
is there conservative dogma that he
writes about that becomes
mankind generate or is he just is it he
just comments from a conservative point
of view or do you find they just
he just comments from a conservative
point of view
uh yeah if you could reduce his
political philosophy to a sentence or
two
he was in total agreement with thomas
jefferson
that's the best form of government is
that which governs least
uh mankind thought that uh
a government had no business whatever
uh intruding into the lives of its
people the government existed for two
things to repel foreign invaders and to
maintain domestic order and tranquility
and this was the source of his hatred of
franklin d roosevelt
who came along and created yeah uh the
ccc the nra the nlrb
uh and you know all these other
government agencies uh the social
security act
uh welfare
and so on and you know uh all of this to
mankind was anathema
because he didn't believe the government
had any business
in such areas you said when we started
this that he was very german i'm not
sure he said it that way but that that
meant a lot to him what did that what
does that mean to you how do you
translate that so we can understand what
that means uh menken's whole background
and culture was german
uh
three of his four
grandparents were german
his father and mother were
german uh he he grew up
and incidentally in those days a great
deal
of the baltimore population was german
he grew up absorbing german ideas in
german culture
uh the germany that he loved i think you
know an important distinction has to be
made here
was the germany of bach beethoven
schubert brahms
german beer
this sort of thing
uh so it was hard for him
to feel both in world war one and again
in world war ii
to feel any strong anti-german
sentiments
uh at the same time you know i think it
would be wrong to say that he was
pro-nazi
nothing in his writings gives the
slightest indication that he
approved of what hitler was doing in
germany
it has to be admitted he never wrote
anything against it and he should have
of course
why he didn't
is a mystery that you know no no writer
about him no one who knew him has ever
been able to explain
you point out and and as i look through
the
your book to find it uh there is no
entry around december the 7th 1941
that's right there is no entry around ve
or vj day that's right how come
uh
[Music]
again i don't know
there is an entry where he talks about
the the end of the war
i don't know whether it's ve day or the
vga day my impression it was a ve uh but
the the only uh
the matter with which the entry deals is
the the noise that all the people are
making around the neighborhood
while he was working
uh celebrating the end of the war did he
ever talk about war
well he talks about it here and there in
the diary yes
but but mainly uh
to the extent that it has had very
little effect on him it hasn't changed
his way of life very much or conversely
that it's inconveniencing him in this
way or that
last question what impact
has baltimore had both on you and on him
can you tell us
something about baltimore that's
different from other places that you
know
uh
let me try to quote diary of h.l menken
looks like and it's edited by charles
fetcher
we thank you for joining us thank you
for inviting me
charles fetcher is editor of the diary
of h l menken you can visit the
publisher's website at randomhouse.com
the book is currently out of print if
you're interested in purchasing a used
copy they're available from several
online booksellers
h.l menken was scheduled to be the focus
of this week's american writers
but due to current events american
writers will not be broadcast this
monday
henry louis menken 1880 to 1956 is the
most famous writer
here in baltimore and he had a long and
friendly relationship with the enoch
pratt free library he began to use the
pratt library when he was a child in his
eighth year over on
holland street
and he used the nypratri library as a
scholarly resource for the rest of his
life and he's been very generous to the
library he began to give us material
during his life
and this has continued
and after his death he died january 29
1956
after his death this room the menkin
room was opened in the spring of 1956
and it's a wonderful repository of a
variety of of things related to lincoln
well we have a variety of things we have
and i'm looking around the room here
uh
wall to my right which is the north wall
we have menken's personal library and we
have the presentation copies
given to him by a number of writers who
are very important for example we have
the inscribed copies from theodore
dreiser and menken's relationship with
theodore dreiser was the most important
literary relationship in each man's
career we have the inscribed copies
given to him by f scott fitzgerald and
menken menken's relationship with
fitzgerald was a significant one too
because fitzgerald wrote for menkin on
the smart set and then menken later
reviewed his novels so we have the
inscribed copies and these books are
invaluable
on the wall behind me we have what we
call the a collection here and this is
the manuscript collection that making
gave us and it's a variety of things we
have
type scripts we have proofs we have
clippings we have various drafts of
books so this material is invaluable for
scholars for example uh
menken wrote the monday article for the
baltimore evening sun from 1920 to 1938
and he saved all of the clippings and if
a scholar wants to come in here it's
much easier for him to read it in hard
copy than it is to look at the material
on microfilm it's much easier on the
eyes and the other thing that we have is
he not only has the clippings but all of
the typescripts so what you can do is
you can go back and look at a piece in
terms of the revisions that he did and
in looking at these typescripts it's
very humbling because menkin was able to
do a newspaper column in those days he
would write 1500 words and he could
almost do a clean with no revisions
what kinds of topics did he cover in his
monday articles for the sun well the
monday articles ran from 1920 to 1938
and that was the most significant
probably the best known column that he
did for the sun
he talked about everything he had a wide
range he talked about food politics
religion
beer
just about everything he ranged widely
and he was given a great deal freedom by
the sun to pretty much write about what
he pleased and this was the time in the
latter part of the monday articles uh he
commented frequently upon fdr and the
new deal and roosevelt had been elected
in 1932.
curiously mankind voted for roosevelt in
1932 because roosevelt was a whet and
menke was looking forward to the end of
prohibition and menkin had no idea what
roosevelt planned with a hundred days
and as soon as mankind began to
understand what the president had in
mind menken hammered away at him pretty
regularly up until the united states
entered the war
were those columns syndicated were they
available elsewhere in the country some
of those columns appeared elsewhere
and mankind at times was syndicated and
appeared regionally but for the most
part uh he
he wrote for a number of papers but for
the most part in terms of the writing
for the sun
uh he it was not syndicated and he felt
very comfortable with what the son would
allow him to say and he wasn't certain
if he got into other markets how much
he'd be
allowed to write he wasn't certain if he
had if he would have the freedom that he
did when he was writing for the son
because the paper gave him a great deal
of space and he talked about
controversial topics and he was not
certain
if the writing was syndicated how much
of this would be a layout how much of it
would be cut how much of it would be
killed
why then did he have a national
reputation
well he had a national reputation
because people knew about him through
the sun and some of the some of the
newspaper writing appeared elsewhere as
i've said
um the journalism was just one part of
mankind's career essentially he played
three different parts he he was a
journalist with the most important
writing being done for the son but also
for other places like the new york
evening mail for example and some of the
writing appeared in the chicago tribune
now the second part of megan's career
which was terribly important was the
magazine work
now he did a great deal of writing for
magazines and he was also the editor
of two magazines and this the the
editing of the magazines really enhanced
his reputation he began to write for the
smart set in 1908 as a book reviewer
and in november of 1914 he and george g
nathan became co-editors of the smart
set magazine
and they remain co-editors from november
of 1914 until december of 1923. now this
was a period of menkin's life where he
was
uh
primarily interested in literature and
he did a lot of literary criticism and
book reviewing of fiction at that time
so
the market in the smart set was terribly
important for the growth of mankind's
reputation
and then in january 1924
he and nathan
became co-editors of the american
mercury that's the magazine which was
established at that time it's published
by alfred kanav menkin's book publisher
and nathan
did not remain his co-editor he dropped
out i believe it was the following year
in 1925 and menken edited the magazine
by himself
from 1925 until 1933 when he left and it
was at this time that menken gained his
greatest popularity
the 20s saw the zenith of his reputation
he was called the most powerful private
citizen in the united states why
well one of the reasons why we can talk
about this in a minute because some of
the national events that happened at the
time for example
it was while he was editing the mercury
that you had the uproar in dayton
tennessee with the scopes trial and this
gave mancon a great deal of notoriety
he was either deified or or vilified
nobody uh
nobody could possibly read the copy that
he produced at dayton and being
different one way or another so in 1925
you had the the uproar of the scopes
trial and then in 1926
you had the hat rack censorship case in
boston which was a landmark case for
menken as the civil libertarian and that
gained him a great deal of of notoriety
what were the details of that case the
hand rack dealt with the american
mercury and hatred was a was an essay by
a man named herbert asbury
and it dealt with a
a small town prostitute in missouri
and the
essay is with the story as we read it
today seems very innocuous and and tame
but you had a situation there where
menkin got into a conflict with the
magazine with the boston watching word
society and he went to boston and sold a
copy of the mercury on the square
and
the censorship case freedom of speech
case ensued and mencken took a
considerable personal risk because if he
had been found guilty he could have gone
to jail for two years so menkin took a a
very dangerous and costly as it turned
out stand for freedom of speech so to
get back to your original question in
terms of the 20s
you had the writing for the smart set
and you had the writing for the mercury
and then you had the national events
like the scopes trial and the hadrag
censorship case which kept menkin
constantly in the news
now the third part of his professional
career was
the author of books so you had the
journalist and you had the magazine
author and editor and then you had the
editor of books and menkin the author of
books and menkin's first volume uh
written under his name was called
ventures into verse it was a book of
poetry which was published in 1903
and it was modeled on kipling and the
poems are
alternately
hideous and respectable
and the poetry that he wrote as
a youth was something that he got beyond
he recognized that this was not his
forte so beginning in 1903 when he was
23 years old he began to publish a
variety of books and the early mankind
went to wright went on to write about
george bernard shaw and he went on to
write about frederick nietzsche
and then as the career went along uh he
became very prolific as an author of
books now you get to the end of the
decade of the teens
and you see for example in 1917
this is the period just prior to
the 20s when his reputation reached its
zenith and you can see when you look at
what he did at the end of the teens that
he was doing things which would prepare
him for his fame in the next decade
which contributed to his fame and in
1917 he wrote a book of prefaces which
is his most important volume of literary
criticism
and then in 1918 he wrote
one of his most controversial volumes
called in defense of women and it's a
book which continues to outrage some and
delight others today
women as as menken well knew were
superior to men and they did not need
any defense at all so the title is
itself ironic and it's one of the
funniest and most outrageous volumes
that mankind ever wrote
in 1919 he published the first
volume of the american language which
was the philological study now menkin
believed as he assessed his career that
he would be remembered most for the
philology
i don't think that's true i think he'll
be remembered for other things
but the philology is very important and
it ran to four volumes and two
supplements uh and then 1919 seoul as
well the first book of uh of the
prejudices series which was uh
a series that contained a variety of
opinions about a variety of matters and
a lot of this
material for a lot of this material was
taken for what he had written written in
magazines so you see at the end of this
period of the teens
him being very
productive as a writer of books and this
is something this great productivity at
the end of the teens was something that
uh led to the rise of the reputation in
the in the twenties
did he ever live anywhere besides
baltimore
um
menken would travel to new york
periodically to take care of the
editorial duties for both the smart set
and the mercury and he would go up there
and and stay he always stayed at the
algonquin hotel which he loved and he
wrote about it with affection
and he would stay up there periodically
but he never wanted to live outside
baltimore he had a love affair with
baltimore he called it a perfect lady
and he said he could work very well here
without being bothered and he had some
very deep friendships with people here
in baltimore and then the family ties
were very significant so he could have
if he had wanted to
lived in
a number of other places and made a
great deal more money than he made but
he he didn't need the money and he
didn't really care about it he had what
he needed and
he loved the city and never really
considered living elsewhere one of the
prints you have here in the menkin room
is of union square just outside his home
on holland street
tell us about where you got that print
and what it shows well that print is
along this north wall here
as i'm glancing up and this print was
given to us by the mankind society and
it's a beautiful print of union square
and the menken society was very generous
to us here at the pratt with that print
and they've been very generous to the
library and to making causes for a long
time the menken society was founded in
1976 and the first president was
dr carl beauty who wrote a biography of
mankind and then mr arthur guptman
became president and he was president
from if i'm recalling correctly 1979 to
1999 and the mankind society really
flourished at that time and has
contributed a great deal to many worthy
mankinian causes and dr ray stevens is
the current president of the menken
society so that print is a beautiful
depiction of union square and we're
grateful to the society for its
courtesies and generosity to the library
what does the society do
uh the science the society
helps to perpetuate the memory of menkin
in a variety of ways the society
meets regularly throughout the year
and
their mailings and so on and their
variety of banking activities which are
sponsored and perpetuated by the society
what is menkeniana
menkeniana is the library quarterly
uh which was founded in 1962
by betty adler and if i may let me take
a minute to say something about betty
adler betty adler was the first editor
of menkeniana and she was also a
librarian here at the pratt library and
she is responsible
for the beautiful collection in this
room because she catalogued the entire
thing
and
she did a tremendous job with the
magazine and she did a tremendous job in
organizing this room and her scholarship
was not only limited to the magazine she
did a variety of other things
for example census of menken's
correspondence and she's published a
list of menken uh
collections in the united states and
everyone who has written about banking
is very much in her debt
what's your favorite item in this room
oh there's so many it would be uh
it would be hard to choose i i've done a
lot of work on menkin and dreiser and
i've i'm very interested in in the
dreiser inscription copy so in terms of
the books i guess that's my uh major
interests there because it's something
that i've happened to work on personally
over my left shoulder there's a very
interesting item that the sunpapers was
kind enough to donate to the pratt and
that's the copy of the front page of the
final issue of the baltimore evening sun
and that was a paper that was very
important in menkin's career because it
was founded april 18 1910 that's a date
which is well known to every sun person
and the paper continued until if i'm
recalling correctly september 15 1995.
so that was the paper with which menkin
was most associated he wrote for the son
but uh he's best known for his
association with the evening sun and
this of course is where the mundy
articles appeared so that's a very
baltimore touch the headline on that uh
and that's something i have a great deal
of fondness for
the portrait behind me
is something that's very striking and uh
you notice that when you come into the
room
and that's a portrait of mankind by
nicole shottenstein
now that portrait was done in 1927 and
if you look at the portrait
menken
almost jumps off the canvas
he's very vibrant
uh he's not your typical thin aesthetic
writer if you look at the body type he
was very vibrant
and this time was very important for
mankind because as we said before the
20s
uh marked the zenith of his career so
this portrait done in 1927 was mankind
47
toward the end of his great decade now
there's an interesting story behind the
suspenders
if i may tell that
legend has it that those suspenders were
given to him by rudolph valentino
and valentino had been
attacked in the press and he came to
mencken for advice and menken gave
valentino some advice which prevented
valentino from embarrassing himself and
valentino was grateful and the way the
story goes is one of the ways he showed
the gratitude was to give the red
suspenders to menken
and the story also goes that after
valentino died menken predicted that he
menken would become the sheik's
successor but things never worked out
that way
finally there's one volume in this room
that you edited
on menkin's newspaper days and there's
one page in there that mentions your
grandfather vincent de paul fitzpatrick
in baltimore
who knew h.l menken what's that story
and what did your grandfather ever tell
you about menken well my my paternal
grandfather vincent de paul fitzpatrick
senior i'm vincent de paul fitzpatrick
iii
was born five years after macon my
paternal grandfather lived from 1885
until 1953. and he's a very
distinguished writer he was a journalist
and he became editor of the ballmer
catholic review and he also wrote
several books he wrote the biography of
archbishop curley and he co-authored the
biography of cardinal gibbons so he's
quite a distinguished writer
and he worked with menkin on the sun
and as best as i can tell my grandfather
went to the sun about 1907 and i know he
left in 1920 to become editor of the
review and the following decade it was
it was in 1934 in june and july of 1934
there was a conflict because the sun
ran an article in which the writer
stan ignacious loyola to adolf hitler
and it never should have been written
and it never should have gotten through
a copy desk but those things happen and
there was an uproar among the catholic
community and
the catholic
and the catholic review which was edited
by my grandfather and what happened is
the sun was attacked in in the catholic
review and the
uh review and the church called for a
boycott of the sun so it was a
it was a lively time menkin has a long
account of this in 35 years of newspaper
work and the matter was finally resolved
but he and my grandfather were on
opposite sides of the issue and that was
one of the interesting things in editing
the volume when you
come across something like that that
relates to your family
unfortunately my grandfather died in
1953 i was only three years old at the
time and i never had the opportunity to
talk to him about meccan but the
reference to my grandfather there and
and the dispute was certainly something
where the personal and the professional
came together for me what did the people
of baltimore think of menkin
uh some line eisen
uh
some detested him
four more people lionized him then
detested him but he was very famous
there's a story that's often told is
that
on mondays when the
sun came out the people would open to
the
editorial page first they didn't have uh
today's op-ed page menkin's column uh
his money articles ran on the editorial
page so people would open the way the
story goes in any event as people would
open the paper to the editorial page
every monday and say well what is making
up to now
so he was somebody who's very well known
in the town
the
attitude was far more positive than
negative but he was somebody who was so
controversial
and he said exactly what he thought so
he
at times over this long and productive
and turbulent career he wrote some
things that not everybody agreed with
but that didn't bother him
and should he be read today
well yes i i definitely think that
making uh making somebody whose
career
up to this time has has lasted very
strongly i mean we're now what he died
in 56 were
45 years is my math right 45 years past
his death
and like the mankind industry is still
very productive now i mean you have a
situation where books new books are
published by menkin he let me let me
explain this matter the time lock is
when he died in 1956 he left material
under timelock which would be released
at various
intervals and for example the diary of
h.l menken and 35 years of newspaper
work which i edited along with fred
hopson and brad jacobs bradford jacobs
under the very able editorship of robert
bruger at hopkins and then jonathan
yardley's 35 years of newspaper work
these have all been published since
mankin's death so there's a lot of
primary material still coming out and
for example he was a wonderful
correspondent
now coral booty estimated in his uh
collection of menkin's correspondence
the new menkin letters that menkin had
written about a hundred thousand letters
now uh that's probably a low figure
and we would say now that he probably
wrote at least two hundred thousand
so these uh these letters like his
published writing are very interesting
and eminently quotable and the style
that you see in the letters is the style
of banking the
uh public writer so we've had if i'm
remembering correctly about ten
collections of mankind's correspondence
come out which is really staggering so
uh
the banking industry in terms of the
primary sources has remained very busy
since megan's death and i think it will
continue to do so and menken has written
about with great frequency today now the
question is why and that's a question i
frequently get asked why
has mankind's writing
lasted
why why is it so much of it keeping
published and
new material being published now and
that material be reprinted and why is it
that people continue to write about him
uh
fred hobson wrote a menkin biography in
1994 a very distinguished book making a
life and we have two other biographies
which are currently being written now by
marion rodgers and terry teachout so as
i said he he's written about with great
frequency why
well i would point to two things i think
the most obvious answer is the style
and menkin was one of the great pro
stylists in
american literature he ranks up there in
my opinion with rowe and with franklin
and
one of the true greats
and the writing remains
as vibrant and as readable today
as it did
uh when it was written i mean for
example with with a with the mercury
many times when you look at a magazine
that was uh published 60 or 70 years ago
it it seems archaic well menken's
writing for that magazine seems as
relevant now as it did then so the first
thing was the was the style and the fact
that the style was so vibrant and and
that it lives on and it's as relevant
for
our reader today as it was at the time
the other thing i would point out is
that i think he's a man of tremendous
courage
and i think that's something that
influenced all of his writing
menkin wore so many hats and and i've
often been asked well was there anything
consistent was there any one role
consistent in any and everything that he
wrote and the thing that i've said is
mankind had this tremendous belief in
civil liberty and in freedom of speech
so i think stylistically he he was
very gifted nobody has ever been uh able
to copy him some some have tried but it
can't be done really not very well
and then the other thing is his great
courage as a
civil libertarian
i think i think those are reasons that i
would point to as to why he uh
he's so much in the news today
dr vince fitzpatrick thanks very much
thank you
american writers continues live on
sunday afternoon with their look at the
life and works of f scott fitzgerald
this week in 1925
[Music]
this week c-span's american writers
series continues to look at our
country's history through the lives and
works of authors who've chronicled or
influenced the course of our nation
this week our selected writer is
literary critic journalist and author
h.l mankin
last fall baltimore sun reporter fred
rasmussen spoke with us about the life
and legacy of h.l mankin this interview
is about 20 minutes
fred rasmussen a reporter for the
baltimore sun
what was h l menken's relationship with
the sun
well mankind's relationship with this
newspaper was a very profitable one and
a joyful one
he came here after
the baltimore fire he worked for the
baltimore herald which had been burned
out in the 1904 fire
and
mankind
once said of his losses at the baltimore
herald he lost the collected works of
richard harding davis and the gross of
condoms but anyway he uh the baltimore
herald did not uh
succeed in the revival of baltimore and
the paper failed and then he came here
in 1906 on the sun as a reporter
he
cut his editorial teeth on the herald as
a young reporter
and his first uh byline our first story
actually was covering uh
the
theft of some
saddles on the horses in kingsville
but mankind clearly was out front
developed a very
wonderful galloping style
riotous style rollicking style and as of
churchill they said the churchill
sent the american percent english into
battle mankind did the same thing i mean
you can read a menkin news story from
1904 and or five or whatever and still
has a certain defeat to it and and
menken
was not afraid
to state his opinions clearly
and he would end his column sometimes
with little
buzz words like
uh boil your water
or whatever back in the days when
baltimore city had trouble with its
water supply purity and so forth menkin
would say swap the fly
he would roast the methodists
he did not hold back
and at a time when people probably
journalists were a little more careful
about what they said about not menkin uh
what someone once said the mankind was
like an ice wagon going down hill full
speed hitting all the cobblestones
and so around here he developed he
blossomed
um in 1910 he was one of the founders of
the evening sun
and megan's career really is mostly with
the evening sun
he'd been reporter columnist editor of
the editorial page
he
wrote a monday column for years in the
evening sun
and that association continued
until
the beginning of world war ii when once
again as he done the first world war
because he was out of step
his own philosophy with this paper's
support of england
withdrew from writing for the paper
he did that world war one and world war
ii
he was um
he was not fond of the french or the
english
um and uh he was not fond of our getting
in war to save england so mankind just
stepped aside and was
self-censored
and
but he retained his directorship with
the asabu company
was still a great presence here
uh he covered the conventions
for the for the sun
and of course he had done that since the
year of teddy roosevelt and include in
the three conventions in 1948 the nat
the republican uh the democratic and the
socialist convention so we had a long
span um
as a political pronunciator mankind was
very amusing but very often wrong he
once said that
roosevelt could be beaten by a [ __ ]
on a laundry ticket um and of course men
can totally misperceive roosevelt whom
he loathed
he referred to as dr roosevelt and there
are great many uh jobs at ned roosevelt
made by mencken he just he just couldn't
stand a man
uh mankind probably was well
while we're on politics mankind didn't
like any politician actually he thought
they were all on the take he had a very
very dour and dim view of them and uh
you know his bull detector was way up
when he saw politicians talking so on
and so forth but he uh
in the era before television
you can go back to those wonderful uh
dispatchers from conventions and
mankind's talking to the guy who does
who is the band director to the lighting
director and they're very colorful
richly you know with all the implicature
of a menkin story they're there you put
you there uh you use your eyes and your
ears and uh
he had the the gift for the offbeat
the strange person the wacky person
um give us some examples of some of the
things he wrote well some of the some of
the people like dr townes and the
townsend program which was very popular
in those years you know which was become
basically a giveaway of money and a
savings plan mankind was very physically
very conservative
and uh baltimore german um probably more
the republican persuasion and the
democratic persuasion
but
you know he he would write these
wonderful things about politicians and
you go back and you read them they still
make you laugh no one quite
wrote like that
and that made him really the genius he
was did he have a national reach based
here absolutely
menken was uh mankin was known from
coast to coast he was a huge presence in
journalism in newspapers at that time
because of the things he said and how he
said them the issues he took took on
uh for instance in the 1930s he went to
washington testify
against the lynching bill
um that was that we had some very
serious lynchings in maryland in the
early 30s why was he against it and he
was he was for the lynching bill
and and went to washington testify so
megan had a national persona
it was known by everyone
uh a great libertarian
he fought battles against sensors
the famous case in boston the hat rack
case when he was arrested
for a story he had in his
magazine the american mercury about a
woman named hat rack hat rack was a a
prostitute a little village in the
midwest who entertained her customers in
the local cemetery and and uh jay frank
chase head of the boston watching ward
said if mankind sold that dirty magazine
in boston he would be arrested and
mankind was was a test case
and
menken won that case
the scopes case um
as menken himself said no one gave a
darn about that sap scopes
it was it was trying to to break the
laws the teaching of evolution in
tennessee so
the aclu then in its infancy came to
mankind and menkin had persuaded the son
to get involved in the scopes case hire
the lawyers you know clarence darrow and
dudley phil malone
and menken went down to cover the case
and menken again that copy from dayton
tennessee you read it
uh you now know why there were death
threats against mankind menkin would say
things about these you know the
the fundamentalists
you know they were ignoramuses and they
believe stuff that children wouldn't
believe and he laid into william
jennings brian
and
there were death threats
actually if you watch that movie
about the scopes trial
menkin was not there for the great
moment when
when clarence daryl was put on the stand
not clarence darrow uh brian was put on
the stand and cross-examined he missed
that he'd love to come back to baltimore
but mankind retained great interest in
that case
and uh you know brian died a few days
later and probably the only time in
menken's career the only pointedly
vicious
thing that he wrote was
the piece on brian which was entitled
death of a flycatcher
because brian would sit there in the
courtroom catching flies during the
testimony
uh that that that is a very vindictive
piece did the baltimore sun publish that
yes oh yes what was the reaction
i think i think probably amongst the
fundamentalists they were very annoyed
at menkin megan always engendered
thousands of letters to the editor you
can imagine uh with his opinions uh
against prohibition against women's
rights i mean against all these things
that were very popular at that time
but megan always said when he was
editing the evening editorial page the
legends of the editor column also
he would always include letters
denouncing him
he loved that he said people like
reading abuse and you know so he would
he would publish a letter to announcing
him where did he get his ideas why was
he so different from the rest of the
people maybe in baltimore megan kane was
to send him a long line of academic
germans and
they were had been professors in germany
and so forth and mankind read widely he
came from a family that believed in
reading books and education he was an
outstanding scholar polytechnic
just a very bright person who read
widely in all areas could could read
very quickly
um
it was a great intelligence um
i mean what was it
what was it at the sun
who was at the sun who allowed him to
have such freedom to publish mankind
came here at a time when baltimore was
changing the night the 1904 fire
actually had dragged baltimore into the
20th century it was probably a good
thing there was no loss of life 23 acres
of downtown was destroyed the city
rebuilt
it enjoyed its great success in those
years it was the
center for the south of that point
banking and manufacturing center before
the rise of atlanta and richmond and
those towns were still probably
suffering the effects of the civil war
and
mankind the sun also was flourishing at
that time and mankind came here that
golden age
paul patterson was publisher
came to this newspaper from the midwest
he was a great supporter of menkins
menken gathered great people brought
great people to the sun
um
was a magnet for young reporters they
wanted to work where men can work they
want to work with mankind and so it was
a great period between 1910
and really into the ninth
some of those men were still here when i
got here in the early 70s some of those
menken era people
so he was a magnet and uh the son had a
national reputation there's a story
behind h and l his why he used his
initials well man like the great byline
h.l menkin was
created purely by accident uh mankin's
father
august a wonderful man bumbling
owned a cigar manufacturing company the
old man
was just was probably one of those
people was always hitting his hand with
a
hammer or whatever and menken was given
a toy printing press on christmas
morning in the 1880s
and in the rush to try to help menken
get this thing working the old man
smashed the fun of type so menkin wasn't
able to speak or to spell out h-e-n-r-y
lewis menken
he just had the h and the l left so that
was
how he would print his little business
cards
h.l menken card printer h.l mentioned
and he just spent with him so all of his
life he always used that byline by h.l
menkin
tell us a little bit about how he
covered the conventions for the
baltimore sun the political conventions
well mankind menken's a great mankind's
great uh method was to get there early
and break away from the pack men come to
wander around the convention hall
interviewing the florist the caterer the
lighting man
whatever the ushers
and i
in the pratt library you can examine
menken's in his copy books
the copy he filed from the conventions
well he would you type on yellow paper
western union paper and that was carried
by a runner to a western union
telegrapher who would telegive it back
to the sun
and menken's copy is so clean
it's amazing this man's mind
was incredible most of us who write for
a living you sit there you take it out
you put it back in you fiddle with it
not making it's one shot out of the
cannon and then on subsequent takes he
would change to change that
make a pencil mark and then type in
something over it or write something in
and he was always worried that he said
that he hoped the idiots back in
baltimore to understand this
but this is all that's how he worked and
you look at those books they're simply
amazing he's a very clean facile writer
quick
um and not not labor at all mankind
was a human type foundry actually that's
what he was if he disliked politicians
then why did he cover the conventions
well because he thought it was the
greatest show in the earth you know uh
people once
critics once said well if you find
someone that's unpleasant in america why
don't you leave and menken said i love
this country like a small boy loves the
circus
he loved all the buffoons and characters
and yo-yos and snake girls salesmen he
loved it this was great fodder for
mankind who could level his broadsides
against this against that against birth
control against prohibition against
women's rights again he loved all of it
it was it's wonderful stuff it really
holds up i mean in this business where
it's very it comes and goes it's just
temporal i mean you can go back and read
mankind and it's still very amusing and
that that kind of elevates him to not
only a social critic but also an
american humorist there's a great deal
of humor there
almost on the level of mark twain i mean
it's it's very very good stuff i think
most people today probably look at
making more more as a humorist than they
do a journalist i think people in the
business still think of as one of the
great godfathers great figures
but uh mankind um
oddly enough menkin's last piece for the
paper before the stroke was about
the tennis courts in druid hill park
here in baltimore the tennis courts in
baltimore in those years were
and
blacks could not play with whites
and if
the park police saw a mixed tennis match
going on
people were arrested
and menken felt this was outrageous and
his last piece for the paper was
saying what he said in that piece was
that it's high time
that all signs of ku kluxery be wiped
out of maryland that the black taxpayers
as well as the white taxpayers pay for
the parks and the tennis courts they
ought to be allowed to play together
that there should be equality there and
not separation so for when you think of
a man at his age and given the time he
was raised again you see
the kind of civil libertarian he was
he took the wide view at a time when
there's still lots of segregation in
maryland
i want you to talk about his stroke in
just a second but before that you
mentioned that he really disliked fdr
and i just wanted to ask you what his
opinion was of the men who ran against
fdr and if you had any stories about
that the uh
menkin you know because megan's hatred
for
roosevelt was so intense
um
it was natural that he would support the
person running against
fdr
and one of his great friends was
governor landon the great victim of the
great landslide um
uh there was no the the next great
landslide in american history was of
course carter and reagan
but governor landon came to maryland
and menken
was on the land and campaign train and
was touting land and left and right
and promised land a winner lose when you
come back to maryland and give you a
maryland dinner and he did that london
came back after the election
menken had a huge dinner party at the
southern hotel where they ate nothing
but maryland cuisine
pikesville rye whiskey
maryland hams oysters crabs the whole
thing
but uh really
no one mankind would love to go against
the winds but no one really thought
landon had a chance in 36 and of course
he didn't
but menken would call him dr roosevelt
and you know
and he he he called roosevelt a great
radio crooner with that voice of his
mankind just found him totally
objectionable you know and then of
course you take that into mexican's
hatreds were very intense
it could be and uh of course the war was
coming on and menken really in many ways
was an isolationist he felt that we had
no business participating in a european
war and why should we have to spend
american money and lives to save england
and france
two places he found to be very corrupt
you know the english empire and so forth
so
so he stepped aside and did not write
anything during those years
in the newspaper he kept on writing his
books
american language and he wrote his
reminiscences happy days he in days
newspaper days the the autobiography uh
in that period still wrote book reviews
and so forth but steered clear of the
politics
and you mentioned a stroke what happened
when did he have it and what happened
afterwards menken um
menken had the stroke in 1948 which left
him with a severe case of aphasia he
the cruel irony of that stroke was he
was a man who made his living writing
and reading
and could no longer do either one i
could not write could not read
he did regain the ability to speak
and i knew people
who knew menken and his brother august
who lived with him bachelor brother
lived with him in holland street
when menkin was talking
he would if he couldn't think of a word
august had
learned the delicate ability to slip in
the right word and then make him
continue on
robin harris r.p harris who had been an
editorial writer here brought to the
paper by menkin and later with the news
american the hearst paper robin was a
very
attentive and loyal friend to menkin
and robin told me near the end of
menken's life he did learn to do a
little writing again he could write he
could he could edit if someone read
something to him he could do the editing
uh help with that
he still dictated to his secretary to
the first correspondence
but being able to write books or read
books that was lost to him so
um
he once told the
the author of the studs lonnigan stories
um
i can't think of his name right off the
hand
the author of the studio stories came to
baltimore visit mankind in that period
and
menken
and he were talking
and
the author asked about some mutual
author
and when did he die and menken said the
same year i did 1948.
the last few years was life he hated
television he was forced to watch tv
they thought that might bring him out
and he said tv was just filled with
clown clownish shows and
fit for imbeciles and
he'd go to movies he hated he wasn't
fond of movies
but he would he would entertain friends
and listen to music he listened to the
to the metropolitan opera on sunday
after saturday afternoons
he busied himself with visits from
people but those were kind of lonely
years for him bleak years you know his
association here
outside of people visiting him ended i
mean he wasn't writing for the paper
they brought him down here in 1948 when
they dedicated this building
and there are pictures of mankind kind
of you know very thin
and wayne out front here by that
cornerstone
um but those were lonely years he lost
his wife in 1935 and
had no children
but it was a great life
the baltimore sun though continues his
legacy with a quote in your lobby talk
about that and how the baltimore sun
remembers him well
menken once said this is a paraphrase
here mecca once said when i was a young
man
and my friends were listening to idiot
lectures by pedagogues i was a young
reporter on this
and it was so interesting people and he
felt that this was like the life of
kings being a reporter this is being
abroad in the world doing this kind of
work
is just a privilege and he and he never
lost that love for it um
i think when i came here
mankind still was very much a presence
in this building i think
younger reporters menken is kind of an
antique figure
um
you know they they know the name
from jay school or they've read some of
the stuff but uh he he doesn't have i
don't think quite the impact
amongst the younger reporters that he
once did uh
when i came here i was so excited oh you
knew how many you were they tell mankind
and of course that's 28 years ago and
there are people here that had started
their 20s who at that point in their 50s
or 60s or 70s who knew henry menken and
could talk about him and it was just
great for me to listen to those stories
but um
but he's still here i mean
we have that great quote on that out
there in the lobby which is that says it
all you know
fred rasmussen thank you very much thank
you
tonight starting at eight eastern from
baltimore maryland c-span's american
writers 2 the 20th century continues its
examination of the progressive era with
the life and times of newspaper man and
literary critic h.l menken
marion elizabeth rogers editor of the
impossible h.l menken a selection of his
best newspaper stories and vince
fitzpatrick
[Music]
we'll continue our look at h.l menken
with a portrayal sharing his views on
life politics and literature he's
portrayed by american history professor
john chalberg it's just over an hour
i first
became aware of the cosmos we all infest
i was sitting on my mother's lap
blinking at great bursts of light
some of them read and
some of them green
but mostly only the bright yellow of
flaring gas
a time
the evening of september 13 1883
which was the day after my third
birthday
the place
was a ledge outside the second story
window of my father's cigar factory
368 baltimore street baltimore maryland
usa
fenced off from space and disaster
by a sign bearing the majestic legend
august menken and brothers
the occasion
was the third and last annual festival
of the order of orioles
a society that adjourns cynodia the very
next morning with a thumping deficit
and has since been forgotten by the
whole human race
but i do remember that flaring gas
no matter what all of the psychologists
working in shifts like coal miners will
tell you
and here i am tonight i'm supposed to
remember my own past
and worse than that i'm supposed to talk
about it
i'm a writer all of my life i have
disgusted people who make their living
by talking
whether they be actors or politicians or
pedagogues or
clergymen
trust we haven't got a
single clergyman in
the audience tonight do it
i have a definition of a clergyman for
you
someone employed by the wicked
to prove to them by his example
that virtue
doesn't pay
clergy
then i'm supposed to not only talk i i'm
supposed to be an historian
what is history anyway
but a lot of encrusted misinformation
facts poorly understood at the time that
they happened and then mixed up with
dandruff by the historian who comes
later
well hell you can't get an accurate
account of what happened a year ago
so how in god's name are you going to
know what happened 100 years ago or 500
years ago besides
if we knew the honest-to-god truth about
the american revolution or
or or the renaissance or or the
reformation or or jesus christ himself
we'd probably all commit suicide
suicide
by the way i
i once wrote it
nothing more than a belated acquiescence
in the opinion of one's wife's relatives
you know during
the 1920s there was a
wave of suicides across college campuses
in this country
by an enterprising young journalist and
went around to investigate this to
get a an understanding of why this was
happening
he went around the college campus they
talked to presidents even
and i remember in particular he talked
to the president of rutgers university
asked him why there why this was
happening
and you know what the president of
rutgers said
he said the reason for all the suicides
was too
much
menken
but they were reading my american
mercury
well
of course that young fellow had to come
and see me
ask me what i thought of that
opinion
well i i told him that
at times the desire to do ourselves in
is
pretty strong in all of us
especially the intelligent young
but if a college freshman
were to leap uninvited into the arms of
his savior he'd please only himself
now if a college president were to do
the same thing he would bring keen and
permanent joy to great multitudes of
people
college presidents
half quack
half visionary holy the go-getter no
other society it could produce such a
fella
no other society could tolerate them
for a man of real intelligence to become
president of a university
is to me as is as improbable as a buck
festival in mississippi
now i i don't want to criticize the
south
too much i'm from the south i'm from uh
baltimore and that is part of the south
i i might add
but i'm here to tell you that in my
years of traveling through the south
that it is the only part of the country
when you check into a hotel
and go up to your room
you'll find one towel and two gideon
bibles
and yet i am convinced
that this would be a better world
if the confederacy had won
the civil war
you may have read an essay of mine
having to do with that but in case you
haven't let me let me fill you in
i've often wondered if grant rather than
lee would have been in the hot box
around richmond
if grant had been the one to surrender
the south you see was filled before the
civil war with gentlemen
neither died or fled to the north once
it was over and they'd lost
and babits took over worse than that
populist i don't know if the south had
they won the civil war would have
produced any more madisons or jeffersons
or
calhouns but i do know this that the
south wouldn't fall into the hands as it
did of the heflins and the and the
pitchfork ben tillmans and the tom
watsons and the james vardamans
and and and and the university of
virginia if the south had one
would have turned out to be the
university that thomas jefferson
intended it to be
and richmond
richmond
would have been a beautiful consoling
second-rate capital on the order of
on the order of budapest or stockholm
and not the dull suburb that it has
become
if there had been two countries they may
have come together
in 1898 to fight spain
but the south
the south you people would never
never have gone off to save democracy
in the great war
you would never have gone off
with woodrow wilson the south you see
inoculated as it was from wall street
and the liberal whim wham
would never have done something like
that
and certainly the slaves would have been
freed at least by the 1880s
i'm convinced of that and for economic
reasons not moral reasons
and victory a moral victory that the
north won in the civil war is always a
dangerous thing it debauches and
degrades both the victors and the
vanquished alike
the world would have been a much more
civilized place if sin had triumphed in
1865.
and i digress i i need to get back to
college presidents and
college professors and
college students
if i might for just a few minutes and
you're listening to someone of course
who
who never graduated from college
i started out at
johns hopkins university
in the fall of 1898 and i was through
with it by november
and i began to lay in real knowledge
real knowledge courtesy of shyster
lawyers and crooked policemen and
friendly bartenders and prostitutes
i was at large in a wicked seaport city
of a half a million people
while
freshmen of my age were being assaulted
daily and hourly with balderdash by
chalky professors and sadistic
sophomores i was acquiring
real knowledge
uh real truth
so i put very little stock
in a college education
at all in fact i have a prayer
to be saved
from college professors
it goes something like this
from all those who know the difference
between will and shall
but don't know the difference between a
martini and a manhattan god deliverous
actually
when i think about it i pray to be saved
from all sorts of people
from barbers with pale freckled hands
from fat women who loud grotesquely in
automobiles
from argumentative christian scientists
from adult males who wear diamonds
from neighbors who refuse to drug their
children at night
from german waiters who wear detachable
shirt fronts
from streetcar conductors who are new to
their lines and don't know their roots
and from everyone who thinks that all
right
is an english word
college presidents college and
professors and
college students
you know during the 20s again
there was great concern among people of
my generation that
colleges were being filled up with
rebellious types
the campuses were falling victim to the
jazz age and
college students were entirely too full
of themselves and full of rebellious
attitudes against the country
i told them not to worry
and i think i have been proven right
i told them the average campus rebel
by the age of about 30
begins to feel the absolute suction
of rotary
by 40
he's a sound currency man
and by 50
he's ready for a seat
in congress
you know
i have befriended
many of the writers of my generation
and i have encouraged my great friend
minnesota red
i call him
the minnesota tornado
do you know whom i'm speaking about
you don't ma'am
sinclair lewis
sinclair lewis
the fellow with that pockmarked face
his classmates at yale said it was
you
you can almost fart out of his face
so awful
he wrote though
wonderful character studies
and i wanted him to write a study of a
university president or university
professor and he didn't do it
but but have you read babbitt
have you read babbitt
george f babbitt
truly drips with human juices
there are real sweat beads on his
forehead and real freckles on the back
of his hand
and if at the end of that novel he's
abandoned his carnalities
it's not because
the trouble is conscious
but it's because they're bad for
business
this gives him pause
and in the end the pause saves him
as the curtain falls on george f babbitt
he's back on the track of rectitude
an assiduous elk
a loving husband a good father a loyal
presbyterian a sound businessman
in some
a successful and unchallenged
fraud
well i wish he'd have done that book
but he didn't
and i've tried my hand myself at writing
novels and
i haven't been able to do it
i write essays
that's what i'm best at
i wish i could write novels
when i was about seven years old
i began to inherit a world that was
about two-thirds letterpress
and about one-third trees and
people i began to acquire spindly shanks
and rounded shoulders and a despondent
view of human nature
and yet i'm here to tell you that i
believe that a fellow of of
a 50 who has read many books is more a
credit to his race than anybody else
if you learn a trade
and you're not afraid of ghosts and
you've read at least 50 good books
and you practice common decency
while you're a credit to the race as far
as i'm concerned
when i was about eight years old
i discovered huckleberry finn
it was the most stupendous discovery of
my life
and i read it once a year
not
for any kind of solemn duty but for the
honest joy of it
it's a wonderful book it's a masterpiece
absolutely
where where are you going to find a more
real boy than huck himself
no more real boy ever existed who stole
a ginger cater cake or tortured a cat
not a freckle is missing not a star
not a trick of boyish fancy not a habit
of boyish mind
and mark twain was the founder of our
national literature what what an eye he
head out for the bogus whether in
religion or politics or
education you name it or patriotism
especially patriotism
but he always treated his fellow man
kindly
whatever indignation he was capable of
he leveled it life itself
and never at its victims
but you know
he didn't really make his mark in this
country as a writer
a fellow made it as a speaker pandering
to his audiences
something that i refuse to do he would
never never
speak what he believed
there are times that i doubted he ever
believed what he believed
well
when i was eight or nine right after
huckleberry thin
i picked up a dime novel
you probably have read those sir
you were told i'm sure all kinds of
terrible things were going to happen to
you if you read one of those books
weren't you that
awful things would grow on your hands or
you
you'd be sent west to fight the indians
or something or off to the gallows
well i picked one up one day
trembling like a virgin boarding an
airship for hollywood
and you know what
i was bored absolutely bored
it's the great literature
that deserves to be ready
the great literature never
forget that
my antonia
the greatest book ever written by a
woman
in the history of this country
my antonia
and the second best
book
mark twain's huckleberry finn stands
above everybody else and everything else
theodore risers jenny gerhart
a book about a woman
and the real tragedy of that book is not
that she falls into the gutter
but that she escapes from the gutter
not her dealings with the ordinary
misery of economic problems but the
truly awful miseries of trying to
achieve happiness
that's what made that novel great he's
written all kinds of terrible things
since then
but jenny gerhart is a
marvelous book
and read books don't go to movies
don't waste your time
with films at all
actors are empty-headed people they have
no ideas they're full of bombast but
they're ignorant completely ignorant
they have the manners of a fashionable
gynecologist
but the women soon for them
does that happen to you
are you swooning for actors i think the
reason is
that the average woman in this country
is married to a businessman
and she knows what oaths they are
and so she's trying to escape the
commercial world all of the time
and actors come along and they have the
advantage you see
of getting up at about two in the
afternoon
and so then they take a bath and shave
and go out and face the world and
they've got a tremendous advantage over
the businessman who got up at a normal
hour and eight or nine hours later is
rather scruffy and and and ill-kept
the actor then is
[ __ ] and span is a hard-boiled egg
and that's i think what the woman is
truly looking for for someone who just
came out of a barber shop
well
there are numerable subjects that i'd
like to expound upon
tonight
and it's good to see that you're
enjoying
uh good wine
i am amvivulus
it's my own word i love the word
unvivulus
it means that i drink every known
alcoholic drink
what was that sir what was that word
ambiguous
ambiguous it's a marvelous english word
and i have the the worst era in this
country
was the era of prohibition puritanism
run wild
and puritanism of course is nothing more
than the haunting fear that someone
somewhere might be happy
karen is that fellow
who either because of religious
superstition or
physical cowardice or lack of
imagination
is incapable of getting any satisfaction
out of his normal bodily appetites
but you know
the average puritan in this country
was much more the sadist
than the masochist
and going all the way back to that bleak
new england coastline
the typical puritan of the 17th century
wasn't happy flailing away at his own
wayward carcass
no he wasn't truly happy until he jailed
a quaker
so during the 1920s
prohibition reigned
i came awfully close to getting out of
this country
it did terrible things it uh
it uh drove up the marriage right
because the life of a bachelor became
nigh on to impossible during prohibition
they scared off the better sort of
immigrants at the same time
it even led me to vote for franklin
roosevelt in
1932. as i said at the time i'd to
explain it i'd i'd have voted for a
methodist bishop or a [ __ ] to get
rid of prohibition
and it made me
or convinced if i needed any final
convincing
that i am a libertarian
a libertarian up to and including the
neck
i have for you menkin's law
you might want to write this one down
whenever a annoys or injures b
on the pretext of saving or improving x
a
is a scoundrel
i have little time
for reformers
of any variety or for utopian visions of
any kind
i don't believe there is such a thing
as utopia there's no such thing as a
perfect world just as there is no such
thing as a perfect wife
present company accepted i'm certain sir
but
government
government is is not going to change or
improve our lives at all
the average man gets no more use from
government than he gets from the money
that he lends to his wife's brother
i'd like to talk if i might about
politics for just a little bit
i have learned in covering
elective politics in maryland and
nationally and i have covered every
national convention
from 1900 on
everything i have learned can be reduced
to propositions and two propositions
only
the first is this
in politics one must learn to rise above
principle
and secondly
when the water reaches the upper decks
follow the rats
[Laughter]
now there's a certain cast of mind
that's incapable of understanding this
this notion of perfectability
these are the chronic hopers of this
world as i call them the believers in
men and ideas and things
the advocates of wars
to make the world safe for democracy or
leagues of nations or sex hygiene or
clean up campaigns or education
generally
now for most things in life we're better
off going back to the original disease
and burying it with dignity just as we
put up with the noises of the city and
bad cooking and marriage and the
certainty of death
we're all vile creatures
but we're never so vile
as when we're trying to deny and
disguise our vileness
but i must tell you i actually do like
practical politicians
reformers especially the socialists
i have trouble with
a socialist as far as i can tell is
someone with an overwhelming compulsion
to believe in that which is not true
he earns for it as the cow yearns for
the milkman
or as a dry congressman pines for a
drink
he always believes in something idiotic
and usually two such things at the same
time
if he doesn't believe in osteopathy then
he believes in international peace
and we don't need to worry about them
anymore after the great war against the
kaiser they all went down the sewers
some of them became chiropractors
others became prohibitionists
and the rest of them went in for harding
idealism or
free love or mental telepathy or texas
oil stock
socialist has this mesmerizing
fascination with money
they have no sense of the romantic at
all
and i can tell you that the sense of the
romantic is crucial to a happy life
and let me put it to you this week
one daffodil one perfect daffodil
is better for the human race than ten
shares of bethlehem stock
but the socialist
doesn't understand that
at
all now i have been accused of being
someone without any kind of reform
proposal
for humankind at all it isn't true
back to the subject of alcohol for just
a minute
during the 1920s there was great danger
that the youth of this country
were beginning to admire
crooked members of harding's cabinet or
lecturers on sex hygiene or ymca
secretaries
well i thought the youth needed a new
hero
and into the breach i nominated the
bootlegger
or as i called him the boutician
that sir is also my own word
the beautician
not not the abject scoundrel who peddled
scotch in clubs mind you
no the brave the dashing the romantic
the defiant fellow
who would bring the stuff up from the
spanish maine
after all
we must remember that the people who
fought our revolution were smugglers
and in their fragile craft they brought
in not only rum but liberty
and remember that the war was not
against
george the third alone it was against
abhorrent legislation
the worst of them the intolerable stamp
act
but was the stamp act worth the
revolution
if it was then prohibition was worth a
massacre and an earthquake
let me see
other reform proposals speaking of
saloons
i have noticed
that we have a great need in this
country
for a suave and soothing burial service
for the admittedly damned
and i have noticed during my years with
poets
that uh
robert frost and
carl sandberg and edward arlington
robinson have always kept suspiciously
mum about their religious beliefs
so i would suggest that they all gather
in the back of their favorite saloon
and draw up the service that i advocate
and while we're on the subject i
am absolutely amazed that no reformer
has ever proposed solving all the
problems of this country by getting the
whole country gently stewed
not not drunk mind you
just gently stewed
just as the fellow over here is
engaged in at the very moment
drunks
art
robbers are the drunks aren't makers of
wars they don't oppress sure a man who
was taken aboard a cocktail or two
is less competent than he was before
to
saw off a leg or draw up a deed of trust
or
conduct
box b minor mass or or steer a
battleship
but he is eminently more competent than
he was before
to put on a dinner party
admire a pretty girl
or listen to box b minor mass
and while we're on the subject of music
for just a minute
i would like to tell you that i am a
charter member
of the saturday night club of baltimore
maryland
where every saturday night
for better than 25 years
i have gathered with my friends in the
basement of the hotel renard where we
devote two hours to music making
and two hours to the twin an inseparable
art of beer drinking
i'm the piano player
i'm an amateur i'm not very good and i
don't believe in amateur i don't get
very good at anything
but i love to play the piano
and i would like to tell you that music
is the sole art that can be made
absolutely pure
and thus totally satisfying
i like the technique for it and i'm too
old to acquire it
it's really the great tragedy of my life
here i am i someone who was written
upwards of what 10 million words
and yet i am convinced that i'll die an
inarticulate man
because my best ideas beset me in a
language i know only vaguely
and speak only
as a child
where did my interest in music begin
i think it was a that's the most
damnable invention in the history of
humankind
i have on numerous occasions
tried to get rid of the telephone from
my own home
and
just as i
have called the fella to come why some
good comes of it and then i have to give
him a drink and send him on his way and
keep the darn thing and i suppose
someday i'll end up with a telephone in
every room in the house just like the
hotel
but it's a
terrible invention it's ruined more than
one evening diminished my profits in the
process i'm absolutely convinced of that
the only invention
the only invention that is worthwhile
is the thermostat
i don't know who invented it but the
fella who invented the thermostat is
worth any number of marconis or edisons
for that matter i'll rank him with
michelangelo and beethoven himself
well now can i get back to music without
further interruption
music
i think my interest in music began
when i was a young fellow
student at the friedrich canap institute
young fellow about the age of this one
right here
the friedrich knapp institute
private school
in baltimore
and every morning here knapp himself
began the day
by accompanying our singing
on the violin
and to this day the sound of horse hair
on cat gut moves me deeply
i think that's because
the world presents itself to me really
as a complex of
oral sensations and not
visual ones
and to satisfy
the need for that i go
every may to bethlehem pennsylvania
to listen to the bach festival there
now this is a town founded on steel
a town appropriately hard and risk
town one guesses at once in which
rotarians are not without honor
you're looking very much like a rotarian
yourself sir
so i trust i've insulted you at least
twice tonight and i've met my quota
three times and what was the third
i don't want to tell you you don't want
to tell me
well he doesn't look much like a
socialist i'll say i'll say that like
that
bethlehem pennsylvania
i think i go there to hear that music
because the people there agree with me
about my understanding of music
which is to say that they're really two
kinds of music
german music
and bad music
i think the reason
that that's true has something to do
with brains
why when brahms wrote his piano concerto
in d
he was the complete master of his
materials
and i would rather have been present for
the first performance of that on
november 6
1876 then at the initiation of general
pershing into the elks
and for that matter i would rather have
been present
at the debut of beethoven's heroica
on april 7 18 5 than at the landing of
columbus himself
the first movement
of beethoven's eroica
is absolutely perfect
you you can imagine improvements in the
human eye
and even in the constitution of the
united states of america
but you cannot imagine improvements in
the first movement of the iraq
and the last movement the last movement
is voluptuous
it's bolshevistic
try this
try playing it while looking at a
portrait of calvin coolidge
[Laughter]
it's as impossible ladies and gentlemen
as eating ice cream on roast beef
and beethoven
beethoven was one of those lucky few
whose stature has only risen in
retrospect
oh
he lived a life of unmitigated misery i
i know that he never could remember to
change his shirt
he could never remember to wash his
windows
a nephew found the place so foreboding
that he preferred suicide to living
there
short he lived a life of unmitigated
misery and to that misery we must lay
his sterile years when he could get
nothing on paper
but to it we must also lay the splendor
of what he actually did right
because no healthy or happy man could
possibly have matched it
for you see the gods are jealous of
happiness and they punish it
with dullness
now let me move on
strauss
no one has written happier music
sad music has been written in vienna by
chiefly by foreigners beethoven's pap
was a sour wine rhine
bombs came from that bleak baltic coast
but strauss was a hundred percent
viennese and he could no more be sad
than he could be indignant
why are strauss waltz try it on the
fattest or the thinnest or the most
deciduous of women
and they'll be ready in 10 minutes for a
stealthy smack behind the barn door
may they will forthwith impart the
embarrassing news that her husband
misunderstands her that he drinks too
much
and that he's leaving for cleveland ohio
on business in the morning
strauss will never be forgotten not as
long as there's malt liquor in the world
as long as people can leap to
three-fourths time
jazz
may someday do him in unfortunately
i know it's thought that jazz is an
aphrodisiac it's not that at all
if if jazz is an aphrodisiac then so is
the sound of riveting as far as i can
tell
well we got away from politics and uh
and and perhaps it would be
appropriate to
field a few questions if you if you have
a mind ask me any questions about uh
politics or other subjects and
we have a few minutes for that sort of
thing uh are there a few questions
you're still not going to tell me the
third
insult
with no fair whispering
you're discussing your marriage i do
husbands and wives should never discuss
their marriages
if they do so they're doing nothing more
than giving evidence at a coroner's
inquest
let me let me ask you about uh william
jennings brian who you wrote you wrote
his obituary and it was one of the most
vicious things i think i've ever read
about a person did you have any ever
have any uh feeling that maybe you were
too harsh on him
vicious he says i
i didn't think i was being vicious
enough
a man of palpable imbecilities
i was with him
at the scopes trial in dayton tennessee
when he said that man is not a mammal he
lost me entirely at that point sir
lost me entirely do i believe in
evolution of course i do
skin a chimp and it would take an
autopsy to prove he's not a theologian
[Laughter]
i did write
i will admit
a very tough tough-minded obituary
something about it being fitting that he
died
near
in tennessee among
fellow believers
beating off flies and gnats
he was at home in such christian scenes
such simple christian scenes and
entirely at home in places like that
with people who were not debauched by
the refinements of the toilet
i believe that liking was sincere about
him and i will give him that
probably it was the only sincere thing
about him
and if
look at the democratic party of today
the democratic party of william jennings
brian the democratic party of jimmy
walker and al smith and dr wilson
and dr roosevelt ii
it's got about as much connection to
thomas jefferson
as the methodist board of christian
morals and public temperance has to do
with jesus christ himself
you're going to force me to
plow on
all by i hate to use metaphors like that
uh uh plow on
very mindful of
an essay i once wrote on the husband man
and
farmers and
how they're perfectly willing to bilk us
all when things go bad for them
i say let them go bad for them as far as
i can tell and brian's speech sir at the
1896 convention slightly before my time
lording it over us and the virtues of
rural life and the evils of the city a
terrible terrible misguided fellow
we've lost your wife
momentarily momentarily
yes sir who were your
favorite and least favorite presidents
my least favorite
woodrow wilson
did you know that god
causes wars
it's been believed by every president of
the united states
since thomas jefferson
by during the late great war against the
kaiser
the then president of the united states
woodrow wilson set aside a day to pray
to god
to stop what he had started
as soon as possible
and on terms favorable to american
investments
now this was not done mind you
by a voodoo man of the congo forest
but by a sound presbyterian
a phd of johns hopkins university
and the best dressed professor ever seen
at princeton
but i have no respect for him at all
he's like every other politician you
know they're always running for the next
office
wilson himself even had his eye on a
third term
in 1920 and if that wasn't going to do
it he was going to run for the
presidency of the league of nations and
i have it on good authority and if that
would be denied to him he was looking at
the first opening in the trinity
[Laughter]
now you asked me about my favorite
this is a little weak sir a little weak
i trust you'll do better afterwards
grover cleveland
is by far my favorite president
he was a good man in a bad trade
i think that's the best way to summarize
it we've had presidents
uh more intelligent
we've even had one or two that have been
on occasion profound
but we've never had a president whose
basic character was more solid and more
admirable
than grover cleveland himself
he didn't get by by by knuckling under
or glad-handing with politicians
he got along by scorning them by
absolutely defying them
but he was simply impervious
to criticism or to being swayed by
anything at all
but there was far more to him
than beam and tonnage
he had the shape of a of a natural
object something on the order of cape
horn if you've ever seen pictures of it
but when his enemies head at him
they quickly learned that his weight was
the least of their difficulties
what really sent them sprawling was that
there was no give day no no bounce no
softness at all
he simply sailed through american
history like a steel ship loaded with
granite
he had
he had good family behind him
they were not readers
and there was none of the the sleek
graces of woodrow wilson about him and
certainly none of the wide reading of
roosevelt the first
but there was something about that
upbringing that made him solid even
though he never became a reader at all
whatever he learned about human nature
came from sitting in buffalo saloons
with pleasant fellows
drinking away the afternoon
otherwise
what was it admiral about him beyond
anything else was his sense of duty
god he liked to say never failed to make
known to me his sense of duty
it's a sad thing to contemplate but
we'll probably never elect someone like
him again
it's one of the things that the map
that's the matter with this country
that he's fallen behind and is looked on
as subordinate to the likes of lincoln
and
roosevelt one and wilson roosevelt two
most politicians are entirely too pliant
but not cleveland and you know something
else besides that sir remember that
charge against him about fathering an
illegitimate child
well
he was man enough to admit that there
was some truth to it well well at least
he he was
admitting to to having little the woman
and he was willing to pay for the little
bastard and i'll give him that entirely
my least favorite i suppose would have
to be
beyond wilson it would be the second
roosevelt
he had
an ingratiating grin on his face
like that of a snake pill vendor at a
village carnival
and with precisely the same sense of
responsibility
you know what his conception of
government was don't
you that of a milk cow with
125 million teats
the new deal
the new deal began like the salvation
army promising to save humanity
and it'll end like the salvation army i
suppose running flop houses and
disturbing the peace
[Laughter]
in 1935 i wrote a
constitution for this country taking
into consideration the new deal
and i won't bother you with the whole
thing but the preamble might be of
interest
we the people of the united states in
order to form a more perfect union
establish social justice
draw the fangs of privilege remove the
burden of liberty from ourselves and our
prosperity and affect the redistribution
of property to ordain and establish this
constitution of the united states of
america
but you know something i'll give him
this
prior to the arrival of fdr on the scene
the democrats would leave their
quadrennial suicide pact
otherwise known as their national
convention
in a low and tortured frame of mind
with their seat of their pantaloons
shiny
their pocket books empty
and a candidate on their hands whose
chances of election were a good deal
worse than bad
so i'll give him that
are there any other questions
oh
yes but
would you talk a little more about some
of the writers that you have known
well i i
be happy to any in particular that you
strike your fancy
trouble with so many of the writers is
that they
they've fallen victim of
of alcohol
sinclair lewis
was a victim of alcohol
f scott fitzgerald he moved to baltimore
with zelda
because of me
hounded me wanted to befriend me and i
had no time for that kind of nonsense i
have rules about drinking
and and you're subscribing to them
never drink while the sun is up
never drink while there's work to be
done and never drink alone
and you're i don't know about your
workload sir but uh two of the three
you're at least uh you're at least
abiding by them
and and drizer dreiser wrote sentences
that went on and on and faulkner did the
same thing
and then dryser's private life was an
absolute wreck an absolute wreck
i i ring lardner
ring lardner is worth have you got books
by ring lardner here
he wrote about ordinary people
and i think that that's to his credit
entirely and willa cather much better
than edith wharton
willa cather did the same thing
and a good novel i used to read two or
three novels a day
i was i was the brigham young the metro
maniac of the uh of the literary world
on rainy weeks i would go through a
couple of dozen of them
and i was always looking for novels that
that dealt with one man's fight or one
woman's fight with the ordinary
the ordinary stuff of life
and i didn't care if they found freedom
at the end for most of us most of us
have no more freedom than a bird in a
cage
we may flap our wings and sing we may
bathe and and eat our food but at the
end we're still in the cage
and that's fine
one man's fight with the environment is
all i'm asking for
but since about 1930 not too many novels
have hit me is worth worth my time at
all
i mean was it
oh
trying to divert you from the rotarians
i thought so i i i i was absolutely
correct on that wasn't i
could you give us your views on
the least favorite and most favorite
presidential wives
no
the least favorite might have been
harding's wife
given all of her ambitions for this poor
fellow
or taft's wife given all of her
ambitions
or grant's wife
those wives are are bothersome for me
i almost feel sorry for
for harding or did at the time
difficult to feel sorry for hardingham
his prose reminded me of stale bean soup
of
dogs barking idiotically through endless
nights of
college
yells warren gamaliel harding
the gamaliolize i once wrote was to
reduce a proposition to terms of such
imbecility
that it would be immediately
comprehensible to morons
coolidge's wife was decent
and so was coolidge for that matter
she put on no heirs at all and
and kept in the background entirely
she wouldn't go around hooping for
coolidge at all but then again to hoop
for coolidge would be akin to hooping
for parallel longitude
one could be a coolidge fanatic one
could be a fanatic for double entry
bookkeeping
[Laughter]
and the professional cooler gisters went
all out their business
with the air of a grocery clerk wrapping
up packages of ginger snaps
were you going to ask a question um
yes i thought no i'm sorry i
i will well all right
are you married
well i was
i married at 50
10 years ago i married in 1930
sarah hard and
we were married for five years and
she preceded me
in death she she had tuberculosis i knew
that at the time
she was 32
and a writer of some note
and i i i think we had a decent marriage
a decent marriage is mostly talk
a good marriage i think is about 90
percent talk
and a good marriage is
is entirely possible i used to think uh
i used to think that it wasn't
i used to say my my saying was no man is
happily married if he has to drink worse
gin than he used to drink when he was
single
but i have my idea for a marriage if
they're if you can if you have a
marriage you have to have a contract
and my marriage contract
went something like this
i promise to do my damnedest and you are
hereby notified that i expect you to be
polite
[Laughter]
actually when i think about it it's not
really a contract at all it's a way of
life
its essence when it is sound is a
complete surrender of many of the
natural rights of the individual it's
not comparable to buying an automobile
or joining the elks
it is comparable to entering a monastery
or enlisting for a war
well
yes sir in your autobiography you talk
about happy days and newspaper days what
about the heathen days
those are everydays sir every day i am
completely agnostic i have never been
religious not for a single woman in my
life
and i can't imagine changing now
i'm devoid of what are called spiritual
gifts
religious ceremonials often interest me
aesthetically
and not infrequently do they amuse me
but i get no sense of exaltation
no sense of uplift from them at all
it's not it's not prevented me from
being interested in the history of
religion
and religion does have a history it was
invented
just as the ordinary wheel was invented
its simple function was to give man
access to the powers that seem to
control his destiny
and its simple purpose was to induce
those powers to be friendly to him
average man
didn't want much out of religion he
wanted more blackberries or fewer
mosquitoes
he wanted his living wife to
to die or
or his dead wife to come back to life or
something like this
so i i now i must tell you that
if the day comes when i am confronted
with my unbelief
by saint peter and the angels
if they all gather around me and
and confront me with my agnosticism i
i'll simply look them in the eye and say
to them
gentlemen
i was wrong
i've changed my mind
but i what else could i do at that point
but but until then now i i i have
favorites
among religions
i should tell you
we might get you a fourth time here
before we're done
and some unfavorites while we're at it
i much prefer people who actually do
believe in something
even if it may be idiotic if they
believe in something and hold to it
not the unitarians
or as i call them the urinarians
one of my favorite religions is
is the catholic religion
because it's one of the oldest
and one of the least democratic
and religions like sunsets and castles
and women
never reach their maximum of beauty
until touched by decay
you know the roman church
the roman church despite its frequent
and astounding imbecilities
has always kept before it the fact that
religion isn't a syllogism but a poem
it's always been accused by the
protestant dervishes of withholding the
bible from the people
now to some extent that's true
to a greater extent the church is wise
and to an even greater extent the church
is prosperous
the roman church however has not only
preserved the original poetry of
christianity
it's made capital additions to it
why a solemn high mast must be as
impressive to a man of any real
religious sense about him as the most
powerful sermon ever roared under the
big top by a protestant auctioneer of
god
but look what's happening
the catholics are copying the
protestants
what do the protestants do they strut
into church sidle into a pew settle back
and cross their legs and proceed to
listen to some ignoramus try to prove
he's a better theologian than the pope
instead of approaching god in fear and
wonder that's what they do
and the catholics are now copying it
why a bishop
playing his part in the mass is a
dignified spectacle
even if he may sweat freely
but that same bishop
in the pulpit half an hour later bawling
against darwin is seen to be nothing
more than an elderly irishman with a
bald head
the son of a saloon keeper from south
bend indiana
so i say let the reverent clergy go back
to block
if they keep on spoiling poetry the day
will come i predict when some extra
bombastic deacon proposes to insult god
and astound humanity by proposing to
translate the liturgy into american
now i i have referred mistakenly i might
add
this is a fairly long answer i apologize
i have mistakenly been referring to god
in the singular
and really it should be in the plural
i'm absolutely convinced that there are
plural gods in heaven
now you're supposed to ask me why i
believe that sir why do you believe that
why thank you
i
i believe that
or a male god well i haven't got that
refinement down yet i'm just going to go
with plural god at this point
my answer very simply is this
if there is a single god in heaven
how is it that he could make such a
perfectly efficient and durable machine
as the human hand
and yet make such utter botches of the
tonsils and the uterus and the
gallbladder in the prostate gland
the answer you see is that the universe
is really run by a board of gods
as any single one of them could have
done it all correctly
and now we are left reproducing
ourselves in the familiar
embarrassing
arduous almost pathological manner by
which we do so because the single god
who had devised the excellent system
prevailing among the protest noah
had to be put in his place when he
proposed to extend it to the primates
and just as there are plural gods
in heaven there are plural gods here on
earth
there is for example the god of the
episcopalians
who's kind of an elderly british peer
very courtly in manner
somewhat beefy
and in new york
vaguely jewish
and then there is the god of the
mormons who shaves his upper lip and
believes in large families in the
protective tariff
and then there is the god of the
methodists
who's kind of an agent provocateur
forever fingering his pad of blank
warrants
was that the fourth one sir
no pardon you're right on oh
then i can take away one of the other
ones
people try oh
well lastly there's the god of the
baptists
he's amphibious
well i'm just trying we have
a minute
yes sir
would you say a little bit about your
book the american language
well that's the book that i'm most proud
of
i for any number of reasons i have
contributed
i think
i hate to say this actually
something scholarly
and i i don't consider myself a scholar
but i do think i have made a
contribution there and i know i have
coined a number of words a few of you a
few of which you have heard tonight but
getting this all down and working on
this in my odd hours has been a a
pleasure to me
some of my books have been
well to be honest a little slap dash but
not that one
at all my notes on democracy
i must say a little slap dash but
um
i'll take more pride in that than any
other book sir
well let me conclude if if i might
simply saying this
as i approach the gates
of senility
i have wondered again and again the
secret contentment
seems to me the ability to put off
suicide for one more day
why have i worked so hard all of these
days
is it money
bosh it isn't money at all
is it the notoriety
now if anything to me the attention of
strangers is unpleasant
is it the desire to do good
not at all if i'm convinced of anything
i'm convinced that doing good is in bad
taste
now i think i have worked so hard to
escape the tragic comedy of life itself
to just to escape the depressing agony
of pondering life itself so so man works
and plays
he strives for the koi i wink called
fame
he founds a family and spreads his curse
onto others
and all the while what he's trying to do
is to lose himself to escape the tragic
comedy
of himself
imagine it is
something else imagine it is most of the
people of religion imagine it
all of us trooping up the celestial gang
plank in lockstep
all the time whipped into line by
ecclesiastics on mule back forbidden to
laugh to swear and eat peanuts all sweet
symbols of dissolute irresponsibility
what manner of man would care to live
but i do care to live right here in
america
i know this is a country filled with
third-grade failures from other lands
a land where the average american is a
prude and a methodist under the skin
a land where women rule and men are
slaves where our chief business is
setting up bogus heroes especially war
heroes
where we've never got half enough ward
healers and bond salesmen and circus
clowns and songwriters and farmers and
agents provocateur
our national bird is the boobies
americanus
and if it won't come down to texas oil
stock or overnight cancer cures it'll
always come down to patriotism or
religion or education
yet i stay here
people ask me why i do stay here
my answer is simple
why do people go to zoos
[Laughter]
only a man born with a petrified
diaphragm can avoid laughing himself to
sleep at night
as for me i awaken every morning
with the eager expectation of a sunday
school superintendent about to tour the
paris peep shows
[Laughter]
so i love it here
and when it's all over
you ever have
fondness or occasion to ponder my ghost
i would simply ask you to forgive some
sinner
and wink your eye
at a homely girl
thank you very much
[Applause]
the correspondent with the atlantic
monthly when you hear the name h.l
mencken what comes to mind baltimore i
went to graduate school in baltimore he
is the
essence of baltimore and all of its
charm
or whatever
what most attracted to the writings of
h.l making it's his language i mean the
man is
was
is
the master of the american language i
mean it's not for nothing that he wrote
a book by that name
he it was just the luminous language his
amazing range of vocabulary he it all
the way from the from from the most
modest slang
to the most william f buckley of words
his his mastery of that this guy never
went to college you know
why does that set him apart i mean how
how does he compare to other writers
that also mastered language only what
makes him different
um
there are a number of american writers
who had a a mastery of language
hemingway in his way did mark twain
would be the person that i would compare
menken to
um what set menken apart i think was his
baroque
use of that language it immediately
appealed uh to something in me
and it's something that i've borrowed
from and used
in my own writing and the interesting
thing to me about this is that it's not
a style that i usually like i don't like
writerly writing i don't like big brush
strokes in writing i like elmore leonard
personally
but that's not how i write i'm i i'm a
big brush stroke writer and menken is
one of the few people who do that
whom i can bear
let me give you a couple of categories
and have you give your critique on
menken's take on these things and just
give us an example of
what comes to mind when you hear menken
megan's take on organized religion
well i disagree with it completely i i
happen to be a believing christian and i
i think that it was uh
it's always been a puzzle to me um how
absolutely unspiritual uh a menken was
uh he lived and wrote at a time of
enormous bunkum in religion
we've seen some of it over the past say
20 years with the christian right i
think
that was
rampant during his day after i remember
menken was born in 1880 he's not a man
of our time
and uh
uh and he was an old man when he died in
the 50s
the uh organized religion the kind of
things that we object to in the
christian right
those things were practiced by ordinary
established mainstream protestant
churches i mean the episcopalian church
in the united states was not having
kumbaya knights and marrying pets uh in
in 1880 muscular christianity was the
phrase of the day and the kind of bible
belt fundamentalism uh that
uh that that peripherally annoys us was
central to the existence of most
americans and
megan was was quite justified in in in
lighting into it
it's if he had any um
personal religious beliefs and it
doesn't seem that he did
he was darn quiet about them and i
regard that as a good thing it's not
something that
i think that i think it's a very private
thing and i
would just assume that people quit
writing about that just as i think
unless they're c.s lewis
then they can get a pass but uh for the
most part i wish people would quit
writing about their beliefs just as i
wish they'd quit writing about their sex
lives
menkin's take on american government
his take on american government was
exactly correct then and it's exactly
correct now why he
had an eye for word we can't say on
television but it involves bulls and it
involves you know cleaning up after the
dog and we know what we're talking about
here
and and how central that is to he was
not much of a believer in democracy um
he he didn't even go so far as to say
that there's no worse system in the
world than democracy except for all the
other systems which would be basically
what i would say
we have to also again we have to put him
in the context of the time his opinions
were formed before
the russian revolution of
1918
before the fascist
a period of the 20s and through the 40s
his opinion was was formed
during the
early 20th century during the
progressive era when the amount of
baloney being flung around in american
politics was probably
this
as voluminous as it has ever been um
so that his criticism of democracy now
in in in the light of all that has
happened
uh and in the light of uh of of the
alternatives to democracy in the
ex-colonial countries former colonial
countries we now know what a blessing
democracy is uh
even though we can look at it with a
clear eye and see how disgusting it can
be it's not unless it is back to the
bull stuff it's very valuable as uh out
in the field and helps the alfalfa grow
you know we don't want to do without the
ball
menkin's take on business
megan was also very skeptical
about business it wasn't as much of a
focus for him
as politics religion and
this cultural fads of the middle class
so i really don't know what i would say
about making a business he worked all
his life basically for the sun
newspapers in baltimore and
never uh
seems to he did he did get
cross-threaded with them but not about
business matters
uh he he writes in his memoirs he writes
very little about that
his father ran a cigar factory a rather
successful cigar factory menkin cannot
be said to be pro businesses nothing of
the uh of the upton sinclair or the
sinclair lewis
to um but but again this skepticism of
buncombe
of things like advertising and promotion
but as for capitalism itself
i would say that he was a friendly
critic of that as far as it goes but
it's not central to his writing
menkin's take on the middle class
now the interesting thing about menken
in the middle class is that that menken
sees the middle class created
he is born into a poor agrarian country
and by the time that he is at the height
of his powers when he writes his memoirs
in the in the 1930s and 40s
he has seen america turn into an
essentially middle-class country to our
very prosperous eyes it might look like
it was still a rather poor country but
to menkin's eyes having come from the
late 19th century through the middle of
the 20th century
the wealth of ordinary americans has
grown enormously now tom wolf has
brilliantly pointed out that the great
dislocations of american society the the
oddities of american society he's
speaking specifically about the 60s and
70s
are result of tremendous change in
social class by americans
lower middle class americans became
upper middle class americans didn't know
what to do with their time and their
money and and went nuts in the 60s and
70s
menken witnessed a really much more
radical change when lower class
americans became albeit lower middle
class but but became bourgeois
during the 1920s and it's not for
nothing that the 1920s was as strange
and crazy a period as it was
you were the cato institute's first
menken fellow
here in washington still am nermenkin
fellow what is the cato institute and
what do you have to do to be a mencken
fellow there well the cato institute is
a libertarian think tank uh in fact it's
it's now one of the the more important
think tanks in in washington i think
it's the second most cited
think tank after after brookings um
being an h.l mencken fellow um you don't
have to do anything it was a joke ed
crane
is an old friend of mine who runs the
cato institute
and uh
i've
always been involved with with cato i
get a lot of research material from them
i try and do some fundraising for them
and he made me menkenfellow one menken's
letters when megan's diaries were
published not not his letters when his
diaries were published
this must have been the late 80s i don't
remember the exact date but when
menken's diaries were published was a
huge outcry about his terrible
prejudicial language you know he'd use
the n word he'd use the j word he'd use
the chick word or it's a then equivalent
and
there was there was a
a large if brief stink about what what a
what a bad man menken turned out to be
because he didn't adhere
to modern standards of propriety and
language in his in his private documents
do you think he was bad of course now i
think it says this thing's absolutely
ridiculous 100 years hence
somebody is going to be teaching up dyke
in an english class if there is such a
thing in a comparative literature class
probably saying now
it's going to be sort of hard to get
some of these students past the fact i
want you to understand that updyke was a
brilliant writer despite the fact that
he ate meat
believed in god and was a heterosexual
now you're going to just have to get
past that you know and
the uh uh the measure of a person is
what they do
and there is nothing on record to show
that menken ever did an unkind thing or
said none kind thing
about anybody because of what group they
belong to in fact he got in a little bit
of trouble by trying to integrate the
tennis courts the public tennis courts
in in baltimore but i'm not going to
make him out to be a crusader
he says he simply used the words that
were current then was he prejudiced of
course he was prejudiced everybody as
prejudice prejudice means to be to make
prejudgments it would be impossible to
go through life without uh without
making prejudgments uh was he a bigot
well that's not an entirely different
question there's no evidence of in fact
he was a very tolerant man
was he a libertarian
was making a libertarian um
it's very hard to put a finger on what
menken was politically no i think the
political conservatives such as the old
american spectator crowd who laid claim
to menken
made themselves out to be sort of the
modern heirs to to banking sensibility
would have been quite wrong
he was conservative in one sense that he
disliked change and was suspicious of
change and he was suspicious of a bogus
populism
but you have to remember that he came
out of an era of bogus populism it was
very much the rage from the time that he
was a young man
through
really through the uh through roosevelt
whom he detested uh uh uh uh
uh uh
franklin uh i don't think he was a big
he wasn't a big fan of teddy either but
i mean he really detested uh franklin
there was this strain of bogus populism
in
american politics that
everything from a desire to inflate the
money to
trying to fix railroad rates to all the
new deal programs
and even the relatively conservative
republican uh era
after world war one was marked with
maybe the exception of the coolidge
administration and megan didn't like
coolidge either making never like
didn't like politics was suspicious of
politics
conservatives can't
conservatives do like politics uh they
just wish they won more often you know
they
but was mencken a libertarian in a small
l sense he certainly was for letting
anybody do whatever they wanted as long
as it didn't harm others i i think but
but to call him a libertarian would um
would mean that menken
had a
strong belief in the sanctity of the
individual the the primacy of the
individual the idea that society and
political uh organization should be
based on the individual
and i don't think menken's opinion of
the individual was quite that high a
mankind was a believer as many people in
his era were
in the forces of culture uh he believed
he may not have believed in in in in
politics he may not even have been much
of a nationalist but he did believe in
culture and it it was
one of the ways that that shows up and
it's interesting is
and it shows menken in both his best and
his worst lights
is his attitude towards his german
heritage
he was deeply shocked by the anti-german
feeling
in the united states during world war
one he was not uh in favor of world war
one he believed the united states should
have stayed out of world war one and he
had some pretty good arguments to that
effect tested wilson
for getting us into that war
um he was infuriated by the anti-german
feeling in america and i think he was
equally infuriated by the fact that
german americans
quickly dropped their german identity
all sorts of muellers became millers
overnight uh
in 1918.
menken had enormous respect for german
culture for german music german poetry
german literature
uh uh he felt himself to be
culturally in many ways a german
this
quite reasonable outrage on his part i'm
not at all sure he was wrong about
america's
uh uh sting uh getting into world war
one not staying out of it
um led him to be blind to what was going
on in germany in the 30s and he quit
writing for i you know i hope i'm right
about this it's been a while since i
read uh
newspaper days
and and the biography of menken that i'm
thinking of here
um
he he quit writing during world war ii
for the uh
for the baltimore sun
uh essentially in protest uh i mean this
started before world war ii and
protested what he felt was their
anti-german attitude he was not
a fan of hitler's i mean in hitler he
saw
very kind of bunkum that he detested
anywhere else but he was he disliked the
anti-german
feeling that was growing in america and
it probably led him to be
less alert to the menace of nazism than
than he might have otherwise
talk about mankind and prohibition
well mengan regarded prohibition as
as ridiculous as you know it was i mean
he saw it quite clearly uh as uh
you know
lincoln was very good on the two poles
of american society
american society loves to get large get
sideways get high get crazy and it loves
to forbid other people to do the same he
would have been wonderful and i may say
much needed on such solemn people as
mothers against drunk drivers
or drunk driving or whatever they are
there's is it kinky friedman someone in
texas has a drunks against mother's
organization
i
always kind of wanted to join um
that that that strange streak of
american
um
it isn't puritism it isn't puritanism
exactly there's a strange streak of of
of uh
self-solemn
[Music]
sensoriousness
combined with very little self-control
and if you think it's changed to which
since the day of prohibition i invite
you to watch jerry springer or jenny
jones or murray povich or
there it is
censorious and completely without
self-control
you've written several satirical columns
and books like
eat the rich and parliament of [ __ ]
compare your writing style and politics
with h.l menkins
is there any comparison well no i mean
first place he's he's too good uh uh uh
for comparison
and the second place i'm probably uh uh
um
well let's see i i i really don't know
how to um
to um
to figure this exactly um menken
although he was a lifelong newspaper man
i was less of a reporter than i am in
certain ways i mean i'm very interested
in the nuts and bolts of issues and how
things actually work
menken was much more interested in
public attitudes towards how things work
uh he uh was brilliant at reporting the
carnival
but not necessarily very interested in
how the ferris wheel worked
i wouldn't be very good at reporting
that carnival but um i i i would make it
my business to figure out whether that
you know what gear drove which gear to
make the uh
the thing turn around
can you give us any um
idea of the impact he's had though on
american writers or on american
literary style
menken is one of those geniuses
like
jackson pollock
whose influence is almost all bad
and this is terrible a terrible terrible
thing to say
well his very flashy style is one that
um when imitated the result is usually
disastrous i'll give you other examples
jack kerouac
had a brilliant style which when
imitated by a million beatniks and and
and five million hippies was just
absolutely dreadful
um a number uh of the of the of the
early beat poets uh for legetti comes to
mind uh it can their their style is is
terrible influence
pollux drips and splashes how we wish
they would go away when done by anybody
except pollock hemingway's minimalism
how awful it is in the undergraduate you
know
where menken has been a good influence
it was in his study of the american
language but i think that influence has
been largely academic and of course
nowadays it isn't the fashion to analyze
uh uh
language descriptively people are too
busy being prescriptive about it uh uh
uh making sure nobody says uh she when
they should say it or
um
or he when they said should say he and
she um uh he and or she uh whatever what
would make him say about all that
probably not printable uh yes or what he
would say that would be credible he
would say at length the um uh and i i i
won't
i won't attempt to imitate him the uh
other thing that influenced there's
influence he should have had and didn't
his memoirs are an absolute model of
what a memoir should be his three volume
autobiography is brilliant entertaining
fascinating
because it's not about him
what's it about it's about the world he
grew up in the world that was then by
the 40s already being forgotten the uh
the the world of late 19th century big
city america especially the first volume
if you if you study the autobiography at
all you will find among other things
like he left out a sister
and and was this because of his feelings
for his sister was this some sort of
oprah thing no she just there was didn't
happen to be any funny stories about her
you know i mean it was
he he writes a memoir the way thurber
wrote
a memoir and all of menkin's writing was
directed towards the reader it's there
for the reader it's not therapeutic it's
not about him and it's not about
hierarchy it's about communication and
it communicates to the reader would you
recommend people read menkin to learn
about american history
oh absolutely i mean nobody covered the
scopes trial for instance if you really
want to understand what small town
america was like don't read main street
by sinclair so sinclair lewis was a very
good reporter in his way
uh but the but but but menken's coverage
of the scopes trial is it really gives a
much it's funnier
what's menken's relevance today
why should we continue to read him and
why should people who have never heard
of him pick up a book by h.l menken and
dive in
well people should read menken because
they'll enjoy it or maybe they won't i'm
not sure anybody reads anymore at all so
maybe they shouldn't pick it up you know
because they won't enjoy it
menken is
among his many virtues shows
what can be done in the context of
popular journalism and and if you hold
it up to the gray pages
of today's new york times or the
washington post
you will see that what
can be done is not being done
although there are a couple of people in
the washington post i'll give the style
section it's due there's some people in
the washington post who who do some very
enjoyable things with popular journalism
but menken shows what you can do in in
just in ordinary communication to
ordinary people
it is a tremendous of course peek back
at america all of this stuff is is
interesting but mostly it's the beauty
of the language the extraordinary and
the volume of it the man wrote every day
and then he wrote letters and then at
night he wrote his diary and he drank
too and
although he was discreet about it had a
love life
i don't know how he
had the time to do any of this
and finally your favorite menkin story
or favorite mankind quote menken said
whenever a annoys b
in order to improve c
a is a scoundrel
a is a scoundrel whenever a annoys b
for the betterment of c
a is a scoundrel why do you like that
quote so much because all you have to do
is spend an hour in the house of
representatives visitors gallery to
watch a
propose to annoy b
for the improvement of c
thereby proving that a is a scoundrel
it's almost all legislation is
we are going to crack down on the
accounting code for the benefit of you
the taxpayer
we're lying
we're just lying
we're going to make
drunk drivers
stop drinking by lowering the minimum
alcohol
you know level 2.0003
which is something i wake up with in the
morning
we're going to eliminate drunk drivers
so that your kids can live
you know we're lying we're lying you
know
minkin saw that dynamic
in democracy immediately and
put it into words
pda work thank you very much you're very
welcome
the c-span recently visited the
huntington library in san marino
california their curator sue hudson
shared with us some letters of h.l
menken from the library's collection
this program is just under 15 minutes
what was h.l menken's contribution to
american life in the first half of the
20th century
h.l mencken was an equal opportunity
critic and insulter
he went after
causes that he felt
needed attention he was he made a career
out of being outrageous and
writing outrageous things that would
offend and insult people but would bring
up issues that he thought needed to be
considered and
dealt with and read about by the
american public
where was he based for most of his
writings mostly in baltimore
where would people have read his
writings
he was an editor of the american mercury
and the smart set
among others he appeared in newspapers
and periodicals
what was the mood of the country when he
was at the height of his popularity
i think the country was fairly
conservative and he was
wanting to fight a different agenda he
had different different points of view
than a good good part of the american
public was he a maverick or was this a
new concept for someone to be a
critic and insulter of american society
no i think he followed in the footsteps
of people like mark twain and ambrose
beers
people who would criticize the american
way of life or what what we were growing
comfortable with
at a particular time
how popular was he at what he did
i think he was popular among a certain
group of people he would have been
vilified and reviled by a large segment
of the american population
he would have been appreciated by people
who were of his same points of view
who were iconoclasts who were critics of
the sort of status quo he's the
gentleman who point who coined the word
the bouboisi
meaning the great kind of unwashed
public the great unread untutored
unlettered public that didn't think for
themselves did macon himself belong to a
certain class of society
not that i know of
what are some of the holdings that the
library has concerning h.l lincoln we
have several groups of letters addressed
to other authors critics editors
including george sterling and the
southwestern writer mary austin
can you talk about his letter to
sterling yes
there's a pair of letters to george
sterling written in the summer in autumn
of 1919
at this time
in the united states there were race
riots going on in more than a dozen
cities this was following the close of
world war one
and there were many contributing factors
to the race riots among them
were the fact that
african-american soldiers who had given
a lot as white american soldiers had for
the war effort came home and found that
conditions were no better than they had
been before the war they were hoping for
progress and for more justice and humane
treatment and they found nothing had
changed they were simply back with jim
crow laws which were in fact increasing
there were also
rumors that in the black neighborhoods
uh communists were being harbored and
that african-americans were were holding
you know controversial points of view
that they were reds
so
that and the fact that white men who
were striking were sometimes replaced
by black workers at their jobs
meant that the blacks were not popular
with those white workers who were out of
work
so there were many contributing factors
to the race riots
and by july
of 1919 menken writes from baltimore
about the beginning of the the race
riots in washington dc
and
now minkin being
the outrageous fellow he was and being
as i said before an equal opportunity
insulter
uses words that are exceedingly
uncomfortable for us now in the 21st
century and throughout the 20th century
they're pejorative words they're
offensive they're insulting
they're they're just highly offensive
and they're very uncomfortable for us to
use them now but i will read exactly
what h.l menken wrote
as i write news comes in that the whites
and [ __ ] in washington are fighting
in the streets at last my dream comes
true
no matter what the result the
extermination of the coons or the murder
of all the southern whites i shall give
thanks
and then um sarcastically ironically he
signs the letter yours in christ
what does it say about menken
some
talk of his mastery of the language that
he uses terms like this in the letter
it's simply to be outrageous to be
insulting also there were words that
were used at the time
more much more freely than we would ever
hope to do now and um
people use these words thoughtlessly and
carelessly
not really understanding how hurtful and
how insulting these words were the
letter you just read was intended for
what purpose
just a personal letter it's just a
personal letter would he use
terms such as that in any of his public
writings
i don't think he would quibble at doing
that i think he would have done it
and how often did menken write about
political subjects such as this in his
commentaries quite often quite often he
always had an agenda and he was setting
out to comment on the politics and the
social settings of the day what
influence did he have on the social
setting of the day
he was certainly read and listened to
and i think he tried to change people's
opinions and i'm sure he had some
success at that
you have one additional letter related
to this same subject correct yes the
letter i previously read is from july of
1919 just a couple of months later in
september
minkin writes again about the race riots
still in washington
and he writes this
so far the race riots have been very
feeble but i have hope
once they are on in earnest i believe
the coons will kill man for man this
will make the thing doubly stimulating
i'd be glad to go to work in the [ __ ]
munitions factory if they promise to
massacre every adult male south of
richmond
between the two letters is it surprising
to you that he seems to
be uncertain as to which side to pull
for
i don't think he's pulling for either
side in one sense i think he's enjoying
it as a spectacle to be watched it's the
american public acting out
their prejudices their beliefs their
fears
their unhappiness
their anguish
at the same time though he did have an
agenda he detested southerners and the
south
um
you have another letter related to world
war
one yes
menken is writing to george sterling in
may of 1916
and this is of course during world war
one
prior to the war menken was a critic of
the united states prospect of entering
the war
in fact he had written some pro-german
articles which could hardly have made
him popular with the american public as
they begin to get into the spirit of
entering the war
he's writing specifically in this letter
in criticism of the impending espionage
act which would be put into law the
following year
he's concerned about this because as an
editor and an author and a critic he
doesn't want to see any risk
to his freedom of speech
he perhaps used that right
to a greater degree than a lot of
authors do because he wrote about such
outrageous points of view elaborate just
for a second about the espionage act
what was the purpose of this the purpose
of the espionage act was to ensure that
there was nothing going through the
males in america that would harm the war
effort nothing that would work against
the recruitment of soldiers nothing that
would give away secrets nothing that
would work to the detriment of the
overall war effort it was to be a major
major initiative
going all out in the war and nothing was
to happen to to work against that
and
menken as i say was was worried about
about the possibility of censorship so
to george sterling he writes the new
espionage
the new espionage act gives the
postmaster general almost absolute power
to censor american magazines he may deny
the mails to anyone that he doesn't like
for any reason or no reason
no crime is defined no hearing is
allowed no notice is necessary there is
no appeal
i venerate these late triumphs of juris
prudence you should read the act the
newspaper accounts of it put a soft
pedal upon it
um in his relationship with this person
who he's written both of these letters
to talk to us a little bit about how he
knows this man and his importance in
menkin's life
george sterling was a california poet
based primarily in the bay area san
francisco
and he wrote for h.l menken
and they so they knew each other as as
writer and editor writer and publisher
and they were also friends
i don't imagine their friendship was
particularly warm and close but they did
know each other
your last piece related to mankind deals
with sterling yes
one of the venues in which menken and
sterling knew each other was the
bohemian club of san francisco
and
by 1926
george sterling who
lived as a fairly depressed person and
had been suicidal for some time and in
fact his wife carrie sterling had
already committed suicide
um
he he was at risk he was a heavy drinker
and he was a depressed person in 1926 in
november he did commit suicide using
cyanide
and a month later the writer mary austin
who also wrote for menken wrote to
menken offering to write a memoir essay
about george sterling
and menken writes back to her in
december of 1926
dear miss austin the article on poor
george would be capital stuff for us but
as you may imagine i'm in a rather
delicate position with regard to it i
was in san francisco when george killed
himself and the town rumor was to the
effect that he had done so following a
quarrel with me
this of course was not true
but if i printed anything that seemed to
put him in a bad light even only
incidentally it might cause unpleasant
gossip i thus leave the matter in your
hands i'd like to have the article
certainly
if what you want to say of him will not
collide with the facts i have recited
i'll be delighted to print it
and menken was in san francisco at the
time that george sterling committed
suicide in fact among the george
sterling papers that we have here at the
library there's a final note that minkin
wrote to sterling upon his arrival in
san francisco
sterling had planned a dinner for menken
and menken was kept a few days extra in
los angeles on his way to san francisco
so he arrived too late for the dinner
and sterling had to reschedule the
dinner so sterling was slightly annoyed
but going beyond that would be too too
much to say
so this letter to george sterling is
written on november 16 1926
and it's on stationary from the bohemian
club in san francisco and it reads dear
george i called twice and found you
asleep both times i surely hope it means
that you're much better i'll drop in
again tomorrow hal is with me tonight
yours and then there's a monogram for
menken
and what makes this an extra poignant
note is that the envelope for it
which is addressed to mr sterling in
menken's hand
has a pencil note written by someone
else
and this note says found under george's
door unopened november 18 1926
and of course the reason the note was
unopened by sterling is that he had
killed himself by then so he never read
the note
how did the library get this letter we
have george sterling's papers we do
collect california authors so we have
the papers of george sterling jack
london and others you had mentioned the
bohemia club in san francisco why would
what's the significance of that place
the bohemian club was a place for
artists
and literary people to gather in which
they would have dinners drink enjoy each
other's companies
do do what was called the bohemian club
hijinks which were plays and comedies
that were put on by the members they
were really pretty out a pretty
outrageous group
you mentioned uh menken's outrageousness
and his extremism where would menken fit
into today's society
oh i think he'd be out on the fringes
again
because he loved to outrage people he
wanted to make people stop and think
and to do that he wanted them to examine
what they were thinking how they were
acting what their way of life was and he
did that by being outrageous and by by
writing things that were offensive and
insulting
to what extent did the people of
menken's time recognize him for what he
was
they recognized him certainly as being
outrageous and offensive and some people
detested him and what he stood for and
the positions that he took
and other people however appreciated
what he had to say thanks very much
thank you
c-span's american writers 2 series
continues tomorrow as we explore the
work of h.l mencken among the most
influential literary critics of the 20th
century his work the american language
published in 1919 compared american
english to british english
our program on h.l mencken will be live
from baltimore starting at 3 p.m eastern
here on c-span
biographies of more than a thousand
authors movements
and now from baltimore maryland american
writers to the 20th century
as we examine the life of one of the
most influential literary critics of the
20th century
h.l menken
[Music]
walmart i knew as a boy was
extraordinarily
hot in summer
and filthy
it was full of flies mosquitoes
all kinds of epidemics were running
simultaneously
but the people liked it food was cheap
houses were comfortable
although we slept under mosquito nets
and uh
i looked back on it with great affection
i realized its limitations
there were no sewers
and uh
water supply was bad typhoid raged all
summer smallpox all winter malaria at
all times a year
i had malaria but i escaped
typhoid in smallpox oh i don't know
those are the words of h.l menken from a
1948 interview he spent most of his life
here in baltimore we're coming to you
from the union square neighborhood
walking along holland street h.l menken
came here at the age of three in 1883 he
died here at 1524 holland street in 1956
at the age of 75.
the next two hours we will take a closer
look at h.l menken author editor critic
newspaper reporter with the baltimore
sun
he wrote 30 books including the american
language and yet he never left far from
holland street spending his entire life
here in baltimore and we're joined by
marion elizabeth rogers who has edited a
number of books on h.l menken and also
coming out with a new biography what is
it
about this man that we need to know to
better understand who he was as a person
and the times that he wrote about well
menken was one of america's foremost
humorous he's ranked second to mark
twain he had a wonderful style of
writing the humorous sj promon said that
he put adrenaline into the gray and
pulpy style of the day but i think what
makes him most relevant right now is
that well we're undergoing a major sea
change in the world where the concept of
freedom is very very important but
mankind stood for that freedom he was
fighting for the civil liberties of all
americans including african-americans
saying things that few people were
saying in those times
one of his contemporaries gerald johnson
said it best he said wit and words are
what made mankind entertaining but
honesty and courage are what made him
great we will be hearing the words of
megan over the next two hours he talks a
lot about life as a reporter his first
job in 1903 worked for the baltimore
morning herald later went to the
baltimore sun what was happening at the
time here in this city and around the
country well baltimore it was it was the
year before the great baltimore fire of
1904 baltimore was one of the major
seaports on the sikh on the east coast
ranked after new york city
theodore roosevelt was president at the
time and those are some of the the key
things that were going on what was the
h.l menken writing style
oh well it was still rather archaic in
those days uh it was it was very lively
he took as his uh as his mentorship the
pages of the new york sun
but it wasn't the style that we
celebrate today
we want to welcome you to uh the second
part of c-span's american writer series
as we look at the life and works of h.l
mencken and we welcome your
participation as well the numbers on
your screen
202-585-3890 for those of you in the
eastern and central time zones and for
those of you in the mountain pacific
time zones 202-585-3891
we're joined by marion elizabeth rogers
who first came across the works of h.l
menkin when well when i was a student at
gaucho college in 1981 i was actually
writing a
an article about sarah hart
menken's wife who went to school at
goucher
and i was writing it for our school
newspaper and i went to the rare book
room and i actually tripped over a box
and it was the box of love letters
between menken and sarah hart and on top
of the box was a label it said do not
open until 1981 signed h.l menken and
the year was 1981 it was two weeks from
my graduation so i guess it's one of
those acts of serendipity that all
biographers speak of you don't
necessarily find your subject your
subject finds you and what did you learn
about his style
his style through those letters well
that he was a wonderful prankster had a
had a delicious sense of teasing and
nonsense that he could actually be quite
courtly to to this particular individual
to sarah hart who was one of many
girlfriends i must say at the time as we
take a walk along holland street is this
pretty typical of baltimore row houses
at the time well yes uh this is uh this
union square is actually quite historic
it was deeded to the city after the
civil war
it was uh primarily a german-american
neighborhood during the uh
during the 1880s up to the 1920s or so
menken loved this home he said it was as
important to him as his own two hands
and this home directly behind us he
lived here all but just a couple of
years when he was married right he lived
he moved here when he was three years
old during those five years of marriage
to sarah from 1930 to 1935 he lived on
cathedral street
but this was his home and this was his
refuge from the rest of the world and
paint a picture of what life was like
during the time that he lived here this
street this neighborhood in particular
well
menken was
grew up here during the era of
cobblestones
this was a very quiet neighborhood in
fact it was considered almost
countryside in the 1880s of course it's
not that way anymore
and during the 20s and 30s
the the neighborhood experienced various
changes especially during the 40s when
you had all the different war workers
coming in to build ships and things for
world war ii right now union square is
experiencing a wonderful wonderful
renovation a lot of new families are
moving into this neighborhood it's it's
very heartening to see it coming back
before we get to the first call just
give our audience a sense of where we're
at here at union square where baltimore
is the neighborhood around here the
library down the street that h.l menken
frequented as a boy yes well the library
was the number two branch of the enoch
pratt free library what many people
don't realize is that menken was
self-educated his education did not go
past a high school so he always liked to
say that the enoch pratt free library
was his university
and
he he just he just loved this
neighborhood and he loved this city in
fact when he would go to new york to
edit his magazines
he he always was relieved when the train
was headed south and then he was coming
back to baltimore our focus today is on
h.l mencken we'll get a call from
decatur georgia good afternoon welcome
to the program good afternoon steve this
is a great series i'm so happy that
you're back on the air after that long
delay
i'd like to ask the guest
what were
menken's religious beliefs
now my reading of menkin indicates that
he was an agnostic or it
worse than atheist and if he and if he
was did his readers
understand that did they know that and
did it matter and also briefly
what were his early
religious
training if any or what
what church was involved with
thank you very much
yes well menken was an agnostic and
everybody knew it uh he was decried
across the pulpits across america
but his uh his devoted readers didn't
mind menken
actually was very well versed in the
subjects of religion he used to have
wonderful theological discussions with
rabbis and priests and in fact
wrote one of his favorite books which
was called treatise on the gods that
came out in 1930
but as for his uh he and he didn't hold
it against anyone who was religious and
in fact he said
when he arrived to the great pearly
gates he would say and if he met the 12
apostles he would say gentlemen i was
wrong but the fact is uh he
his early religious training he did go
to sunday school but uh his his father
sent him there only because he wanted to
sleep late on sundays
and caller there was an interview and
you're going to be hearing some of the
audio from this donald kirkley interview
that was conducted at the library of
congress in 1948 actually just a couple
of months before he suffered his
debilitating stroke uh in 1948 and
during that interview he talked about
being at agnostic and also some of the
superstitions that he had let's listen
in
or the man who believes that friday is
an unlucky day i should add once that i
am one of those who do believe that
friday's an unlucky day
and uh
like like nearly all
agnostics i'm very superstitious
and i would no more undertake any
work of importance on friday the 13th
and i'd jump off a house
you are still an agnostic you feel very
faithful to that
i was born and agnostic my father was
one ahead of me and his father ahead of
him
so agnosticism is nothing new to me
i'll point out a
one of the strange corollaries and that
is this
a man who is an agnostic
by inheritance
so that he doesn't remember any time and
he wasn't
has almost no hatred for
the religious
i i get on very well with all kinds of
ecclesiastics and all kinds of pious
people
because i don't uh
have any uh
evil conscience in the matter
i'm not a renegade no feeling of sin now
feeling the sin whatever i'd assume that
they've got a right to believe anything
they please
h.l menken from that 1948 interview
another call from bethesda maryland good
afternoon
hi
i was privileged to be a student at
baltimore city college which is a high
school public high school in baltimore
we now now call it probably a magnet
school we didn't know what the word
magnet was then
back doing world war ii
and shortly thereafter when menken would
make
his annual visit to mr pence's english
class
and to the carrollton white and bancroft
literary societies that he would address
in the afternoon
and i can tell you the reaction of the
students
when he came to city college was
unbelievable
this man how old are you now i'm now 73.
how old are you
how old were you when he came to your
school uh i was a high school student i
was uh in my teens
and of course
we didn't know who menkin was the first
time
but after he arrived boy did we know who
he was
he did more
to stimulate learning
and to force young men by their own will
to go to the library and to look up the
huge words that he would use
when he came his vocabulary was
unbelievable and of course he wrote the
great american language series
which is still a standard reference work
today in the american language but i i
wanted to comment on what the reaction
students was
after that first visit we looked forward
to every successive year visit
and we would prepare by
studying the topics that mengan
you used to used to really be against
he was against virtually every
politician but particularly
he his favorite subjects were woodrow
wilson archangel woodrow william
jennings bryan
he was against divines
which is his word for religious people
or pastors
he was against what he called
mata banks
quackery
he was he was for anything almost that
was german
uh especially a great admirer of
beethoven and and
brahms of course and wagner what have
you
he did have a good word to say about
governor richie
who had been the democratic governor of
maryland mainly because he was against
prohibition and mankind was just
tremendously against prohibition
but he would uh
he would so stimulate the students at
that ch
at the
baltimore city college
uh that uh i i think he did more to
teach us
about life and about the english
language and
any teacher that we ever had he was
simply a great influence on my life and
on the life of those of us that were
privileged to be students at that high
school and to have him come teach our
english class
thank you caller what do you take away
from that well that's the wonderful
thing because i think that menken can
continue to
inspire students even today his vitality
lives on even in his writings and so
if you're not as fortunate as this
caller was to have met menken and listen
to him i envy you
at least you can read the writings and
get inspired in that way in fact one of
the journalists james farrell said that
he said that
menken inspired journalists like himself
to write with greater clarity and to be
inspired to speak out courageously about
matters on the day and he can do that
for young journalists today as well what
was the american language well the
american language is something that
menken is most remembered for
it was his study of how the american
language differs from the english
language as he argued back in 1919
uh the the american english differs as
much as the portuguese differs from
brazil to portugal and back in 1919
that was a very novel concept and i
think he instilled a wonderful pride in
our american language and it went on for
volumes and volumes throughout the years
next call from new york city here on
c-span's american writers series good
afternoon
good afternoon
uh i i knew h l mankind too
i was a medical are you from baltimore
yeah i was a medical student at johns
hopkins in 1930 and i was an intern
on marburg the private service
and menken was a patient of mine he was
a patient of ben baker's and i was the
intern on the service in 1938
and i got to know menken quite well
and he happened to be
a friend
of
another lady patient who knew him and
she said i often have him to dinner
so next fall when when i have him to
dinner i'll invite you out so i got to
know him that following fall and several
times
for rather lengthy joyful dinners i
almost failed
that in the time i got to know him i
almost know him as a friend
of course i'd read everything he ever
wrote before i met him but i want to
tell you he talked
exactly as he wrote it was just as fast
just as clever he had an amazing
response to most any subject that came
up and an amazing in-depth authority so
yeah
can you compare him in the time that you
knew him
to anyone who is uh either alive today
or past writers is there another person
that compares to h.l menkin well that's
a real good question
in today's world
uh the closest i could come to his real
subtlety
of uh
of intellect was
you know baker who wrote for the new
york times and and he's on public
television and but but baker was so
gentle
he uh
he is just that menkin was they're both
clever but uh but menken was was so full
of
acid and he could sum somebody up
i asked him so many questions i heard so
many stories
oh even about dayton you know and the
monkey trials
that he was so involved in and i heard
him describe those early days in dayton
tennessee with that unbelievable
descriptive power
he he told me
that he went down to dayton uh several
days before the trial opened to kind of
see what that town in tennessee was like
and he found a teenage boy with a little
fuzz on his cheek
crying
and he went up to him he said what's the
matter
and the little boy said my mother's
going to wean me
and make it absolutely claimed that in
this backward area of the country
of kids at 8 and 9 years old while at
play
would go over to the sidelines and pull
up their mother's dress and wean
themselves
his colorful descriptions of america
were just endless
so thank you very much caller
thanks for the comment 46 years after
his death that's right well i just think
it's so amazing we've been on this show
what just a few minutes and all these
calls that are coming through with
people who have had personal contact
with me with menken but i'm interested
that the caller says that he was
working with ben baker because lincoln
was very interested in medicine and in
fact there are those that when they
listened to him they thought he had gone
to medical school lawyers thought he had
gone to law school uh priests and rabbis
thought he had studied theology i mean
this was truly a renaissance man who was
well versed in almost every single
subject it's really quite amazing we'll
take a walk over to the center of this
union square park but we'll continue
with more of the words of h.l menken
back from 1948
well of course you'll notice the
peculiar
thing about the united states where
there is very little
free speech free speech is a very
limited
right in this country
as i have learned to my better
experience more than once
yet it is the country where the right to
press opinions on
reluctant hearers
is carried to a
development that is unheard of on earth
the whole country is full of
propagandists who are bothering
everybody all the time i get
in the mail every morning tremendous
piles of propaganda of one kind or other
and i can easily imagine a man
who would resent that
would think it's a nuisance
and
he ought to have some
there ought to be some way to save him
from annoyance
h.l menken from 1948 marrying elizabeth
rogers where did he do most of his
writing most of his writing was actually
done in the house right behind us
in the upstairs room where some of the
greatest pros of the 19th 20th century
was actually produced
we're going to continue with your calls
bristol virginia you're on c-span
yes uh
sort of have a question for miss rogers
uh when i was in graduate school and
this was about 20 years ago
i did some rather extensive research
on robert ingley carter
who was the second managing editor
of the baltimore morning herald when uh
henry menken was beginning his
journalism career
and i got far enough along with it to
learn that carter had a tremendous
uh
influence
on henry menken's writing and his
approach to criticism
and i'm just curious if anyone
to ms rogers knowledge has pursued any
further research on mr carter
well
i don't know about further biographies
or research on mr carter but i can say
that
menken in his autobiography
autobiography does talk about his debt
to mr carter and mr carter had been uh
looking at menken's uh drama criticism
and he said you have to give the readers
a show
and
that's what menken was in some ways a
showman and uh
that's that was an inspiration for him
in his writing
and we're joined by vince fitzpatrick
who is here at union square who who were
h.l menken's
mentors at the time
um
menken as marian rodgers has said uh
used the new york sun as a model
i think that thomas henry huxley was
very important as a mentor because
menkin always stressed uh foremost
clarity and prose and many people may
well disagree with what menkin says but
very few people have any problem
understanding what he says you're a
teacher an author and you also head up
the menkin collection what is that the
h.l menken collection is housed at the
enoch pratt free library in downtown
baltimore lincoln had a long and very
friendly relationship with the pratt
library and we have it the at the pratt
the most extensive archive banking
archives in the world he began to
contribute material to the pratt during
the 1930s and uh the collection under
the very able guidance of betty adler uh
has continued to grow since that time
this neighborhood this square was it a
source of inspiration for him it was a
source of great inspiration for his
writing and in my opinion the zenith of
menken's career artistically
were the days books happy days newspaper
days and heathen days and not everybody
will agree with that assessment but i
think he writes beautifully and happy
days covers 1880 to 1892 birth to
puberty and this area where we're
standing right now figured very
prominently in some of mankind's finest
writing we talked earlier with marion
rodgers about this neighborhood for
people who have never been to baltimore
and as we hear some of the sirens in the
background there are two hospitals
nearby
how would you explain this area well
this was an area that was a source and
a source and a sustainer for menken it
gave him uh the grounds for some of his
finest writing it's uh urban america
we'll get a call from san francisco good
afternoon
hi um thank you for taking my call i'm a
younger caller i'm 33 years old and my
question is
why is it that h.l menken says so very
little about the second world war
um and and what would be his what was
his opinion of america's transformation
from an isolationist nation to a global
superpower thank you very much
vince with patrick
uh very good question um
the first part uh is probably more
easily answered than the uh than the
second part menkin um
menkins stepped down from the sun he
wrote a mundi article from 1920 to 1938
and in 1938 he took a job as an editor
so he did not have a regular forum with
the sun during the second world war as
he had previously so that's one of the
reasons why you don't see
as much commentary on the war as you did
on the first war because he did not have
a regular newspaper forum
[Applause]
in terms of the second issue
i guess you should start
with the fact that menken
severely distrusted franklin delano
roosevelt and was always distrustful of
his motives
i would start with that thank you san
diego you're next good afternoon hi uh
the prior caller kind of answered the
world war ii questions my other couple
of questions have to do with the menkins
politics would he be described as a
libertarian or where would he fit in on
the political spectrum
and my second question has to do with
after his stroke did he
was his mind still completely functional
or what how was he able to continue
after his stroke thank you
marion rogers well uh if vince would
like to answer the first part i'll take
the second
um
menkin's politics menken was
i guess best described as an old-time
jeffersonian liberal who believed that
the government the best government
governed the least now whether that
makes him a libertarian or not by
today's terms is a matter of debate
uh menken would line up on the liberal
side today in terms of his belief in
first amendment rights
menkin would line up on the conservative
side today
in the fact that he did not believe he
would not believe in the
continued growth of the federal
government he would not believe that the
essential
problems of humankind can be solved
either politically or by spending money
and welcome back to the caller's second
point about atel menken after his stroke
but this is what he had to say about his
views of politicians in general
while in politics i'm a complete neutral
i think they're all scoundrels without
exception there are especially that is
true of the reformers
i've known
politicians by the thousand all my life
and i'm here to tell you that the most
pleasant men
and on the whole the most honest of them
are what are ordinarily looked on as
machine politicians
and aaron rodgers the caller he also
asked about h.l menken when he had a
stroke it was here at 1524 holland
street and then he died what six or
seven years later well he died seven
years later the stroke affected his
brain in that he had aphasia so he had
difficulty speaking at first although as
the years went on it was people found it
easier to understand what he was saying
but the horrible thing the horrible
tragedy of menkin's life is that he was
unable to read or write he was a man who
made his living reading and writing and
he would look at the shelves of his
books and he would say oh if only i
could read again that was his constant
lament and for seven long years he was
unable to do that and we will come back
to this later in the program vince
fitzpatrick but as you look at that
third floor where he passed away
1956 1955 1955. menkin died in the early
morning hours sunday morning january 29
1956 and he passed away in the third
floor bank which was his bedroom
baron rogers we're going to rejoin you
in just a couple of minutes as we
continue to walk down this
inner city park and take a look at
a fountain directly in front of us which
represents what well it's the menken
memorial fountain which was dedicated in
1971
and as we'll be able to see when we get
down there they have a number of plaques
which represent
uh menken's various books and the
fountain
is important because it's a testament to
menken's productivity and great
achievement but it's also very important
because it places mankind in this milieu
which is extremely important lincoln is
associated with baltimore in particular
and 1524 highland street union square
baltimore in general and 1524 holland
street and union square in particular as
much as say
pharrell is associated with walden pond
as much as
mark twain is associated with hannibal
and the mississippi river as much as
faulkner is associated with oxford
mississippi and the fictional yokan of
botolfo county
uh i'd like to point out two additional
things in terms of the
acknowledgement of menkin's reputation
and the keeping of the flame one of
these plaques to my left is dedicated to
betty adler who was the menken
bibliographer and she was my successor
my predecessor at the pratt library is
the curator of the menken collection
and every person who has written about
menkin is very much in her debt she died
in 1973
and three years later in 1976
the menken society was founded and that
has done very much to keep menkin's
flame burning quite brightly i want to
point out this is the date that the
fountain was dedicated september 12th
1971 it was called defender's day
that was the day that he was born what's
the significance of that date in the
life of h l menken besides the fact that
he was born on that date in history
that was uh pertained to the battle of
north point if i'm return if i'm
remembering my local history correctly i
believe here in baltimore and there are
a couple of books that are depicted here
along the fountain again this was
dedicated in 1971 one called damn
a book of calumny what is that all about
damn a book of tommy was one of menken's
relatively early books uh
it was um
originally published by philip goodman
and was later reissued by alfred akanav
and as the title suggests it shows
mankind the iconoclast their series of
brief essays about a variety of topics
he begins with an essay called pater
patria about george washington and how
george washington would not fit in well
with contemporary american society
another book in defense of women
did we move down to the fountain in
defense of women uh was published in
1918 uh again originally by philip
goodman and it was later reissued by
alfred achanov it's one of mencken's
most
most vibrant volumes it continues to
this day to delight some and outrage
others rather than accuse or complain
men can lay us very loudly at the
grotesquely humorous efforts of men and
women to deal with one another and one
of his more famous works the american
language which is the basis in part of
this
american writers series
the american menkin uh first began to
write on philology in 1910 in a
newspaper column and he continued to
write up until his stroke in 1948 and
the american language ran to
four
four uh different editions and two
supplements so six books in all for me
menken's greatest achievement in the
american language is the fact that he
can make this topic accessible to the
common reader and still make it
informative to the scholar
from that 1948 interview donald kirkley
asked h.l menken about the american
language which as we just heard from
vince patrick came out in four volumes
here's what he had to say about it
that wasn't a transition i never never
have been a scholar and never pretended
to be one
my interest in
american speech
began
in my
young repertoire days
i'd listened to the testimony in police
courts
and it was a level of society it was
unfamiliar to me and i was fascinated by
it
and the talk of policemen and so on
and i began making notes about it and
wrote a couple newspaper pieces about it
and i found that a lot of other people
were interested and they began writing
to me and i accumulated material and
finally the thought occurred to me it
would make a book
and i wrote the book
and uh
both my publisher and i believe that it
had a rather limited appeal
we printed it in a limited edition
and the edition was sold out
it was the american language first
edition 19
1918 or 19.
it sold out so fast and once it got out
the amount of material came pouring in
so enormously
that
uh i i was
just forced to write another edition and
then another and then another then it
got so enormous that i had to write
appendixes
um
but i never pretended to be a scholar i
was a sort of
scout
for scholars i accumulated the material
and tried to put it into a readable form
so people could understand it
and to
suck out of it whatever human juices
were there and there were plenty
h l menken on his book the american
language we are coming to you from the
center of union square in baltimore our
next call is rockford illinois good
afternoon
good afternoon i was
watching a book note
a replay yesterday about an interview on
menken's diaries and i wondered either
for mr fitzpatrick or
for miss rogers when she comes back
how
how they feel about the the claims that
he was anti-semitic and racist i
i feel he's kind of being unfairly
judged by
by some hypocritical standards and i
just wondered uh
how miss rogers is handling in her
biography and what mr fitzpatrick's
thoughts are on it uh miss rogers book
was the first book i purchased on bank
and her her volume the impossible making
about 10 years ago and i really expected
to
to see some dowdy old scholar and i was
surprised to see a pretty young lady and
and i wonder what she's what she thinks
about the whole anti-semitic racist
claims
that's all thank you
marion rogers do you want to go through
the chronology of h.l menken's thinking
from the 1920s to the 1930s into the
start of world war ii
uh yes
well the menkins the chronology of
mankind's thinking was uh that he was
always
fighting for the
civil rights of various individuals
african-americans
many many others but the the fact is is
that
when it comes to the diary i think
jonathan yardley said it best we should
uh put
menken
in his time and place menken was not
considered bigoted or anti-semitic
during those years that he lived
now we're all
very very careful and so
some of the things that he said strike
us in the wrong way
but
but
he i think it's very very important and
what i am doing in my own biography is
i'm not being an apologist for mankind
but i am putting him in the context of
his time and place and we'll come back
to that later in the program charlotte
north carolina you're next yes my
question is for uh miss rogers or mr
fitzpatrick i know that william
manchester who is the biographer of
churchill and also the number works on
john kennedy became the assistant to
menkin after his stroke seems like his
viewpoints are completely different than
a lot of menkins i was just wondering if
two of them might be able to shed some
light on the relationship
thank you
vince fitzpatrick
well william manchester wrote a very
fine biography of menkin that came out
in uh 1950.
uh two two biographies came out that
year one by edgar kemmler and one by uh
manchester both sympathetic analyses
which present menken from a different
perspective manchester came to know
menken uh very well during those final
years after the stroke and spent time
with him here at 1524 holland street let
me ask you about one other book that is
listed here the prejudices what was that
what did he write about the prejudices
uh as the title suggests uh present
menkin's views mankind's biases uh the
prejudices gave him the space to frolic
as he pleased to shock and embellish
and the series ran it was a multi-volume
series it ran to six volumes between
1919 and 1927 and there was the selected
prejudices which
continued uh which which appeared that
same year
and we'll continue with your calls good
afternoon
hello you're on c-span's american writer
series go ahead please
hello
carla you with us
portland connecticut go ahead oh yes
that is me
i was a bit distracted i have uh two
questions actually one for ms rogers
which is what attracted
her to menken as a subject uh to begin
with and speaking of mr manchester he
once told me uh that
menken would not be able to find a forum
in a single major newspaper in this
country nowadays and i would like your
thoughts and reflections on that thank
you
marion rodgers how did how would you
respond to that
uh
well i i i'll answer the first part of
the question and that is uh
i came to mencan when i was a student at
goucher college i
the year was 1981 i was a senior
and i was working in a rare book room
writing an article about sarah hart who
was a student at goucher at the time and
i actually tripped over a box of of
letters between menken and sarah inside
there were 750 love letters and taped to
the top of the box was a notice by mink
and it said do not open until 1981
signed h.l menken and
the year was 1981 it was two weeks from
my graduation so it's what some
biographers speak of
that
these acts of serendipity that you don't
find your subject your subject finds you
and that little act of clutziness
actually changed my whole life uh as for
men can find finding a forum today well
it would be a lively column wouldn't it
and i i think that
we need people who to come down strong
on different subject matters sometimes i
do think that columnists are a little
too careful
and
someone like menken would be quite
refreshing
san rafael california you're next
um i have here a letter from h l mankind
in response to questions about his
attitude towards world war ii
the letter is addressed to judge max and
it has no address
but he states here that this is dated
february 4th 1946
and mr menken says
that my belief is that the united states
is already over niagara
and that all talk of saving it is in
vain
we are in fact in for some labor
troubles that will be enormously worse
than any we have ever seen
moreover i'm convinced that there will
be some kind of inflation
i hope i'm wrong but it seems to me that
a country idiotic enough to turn the
russian barbarians into western europe
and to destroy japan's effort to
organize and civilize the far east
deserves any fate that our heavenly
father may dish out to it
that's all he has to say in this letter
and i just thought it would be
interesting uh to answer their comments
about how did he feel about world war ii
thank you caller
i appreciate the call of sharing that
yes it was a situation with menken as i
said before where he did not have the
regular journalistic forum so you had
uh you didn't have the commentary in
print and as i said before he was very
suspicious of fdr's motives
we're joined here by vince fitzpatrick
who heads up the menkin collection he's
also a teacher here in the baltimore
area and he'll be joining us during the
course of the program and marion rogers
who is coming out with a new biography
on h.l makin within the next year we'll
get a call from tucson arizona good
afternoon good afternoon just want to
say i love your show i'm glad you're on
the air and thanks for taking my call
my comments are twofold first one is uh
as a capital l libertarian myself i
would put mankind strongly in the
capital l libertarian camp uh from
everything i've read by mencken uh he
was foursquare against big government
both on economic and social issues
which would make him a libertarian in my
book
second as far as a any contemporary
journalists that might compare favorably
with menken
i would put christopher hitchens in that
category
both of them have been our agnostics
both of them were renaissance men to use
a phrase used earlier
and hitchens in particular was a not
afraid in vanity fair in other places to
take on such icons as princess diana and
mother teresa so um he's the only one i
can think of who might match menken as
far as uh taking on uh his shining
rights in the mass media thank you
thank you caller vince says patrick can
you define his ideology and put a label
either libertarian or conservative or
moderate or liberal to his writings well
as i
had suggested i think that the the
bedrock of menken's uh politics was his
uh jeffersonian liberalism his belief
that the best government is leaves the
individual alone as much as possible
as i've said he would line up on today's
left
in terms of issues such as first
amendment rights he would line up on
today's right in terms of such issues as
the role of the federal government in
terms of economic and political issues
so uh
it depends on how the term is used
we are at union square on holland street
and we're looking at the life and works
of h.l mencken who lived here most of
his life about a mile and a half from
downtown baltimore we'll be joined in
just another 20 minutes or so back with
you vince chris patrick thank you very
much thank you with us thank you p.j
o'rourke is a uh makin affectionato has
studied him and has his own thoughts
about the life and works of mr menken
it's very hard to put a finger on what
menken was politically no i think the
political conservatives such as the old
american spectator crowd who laid claim
to menken
made themselves out to be sort of the
modern heirs to to bank and sensibility
would have been quite wrong
uh he was conservative in one sense that
he disliked change and was suspicious of
change and he was suspicious of a bogus
populism
but you have to remember that he came
out of an era of bogus populism it was
very much the rage from the time that he
was a young man
through
really through the uh through roosevelt
whom we detested uh uh uh uh uh uh
franklin uh i don't think he was a big
he wasn't a big fan of teddy either but
i mean he really detested uh franklin
there was this strain of bogus populism
in
american politics that
everything from a desire to inflate the
money to
trying to fix railroad rates to all the
new deal programs
and even the relatively conservative
republican uh era
after world war one was marked with
maybe the exception of the coolidge
administration and men like coolidge
either make him never like
didn't like politics was suspicious of
politics
conservatives can't
conservatives do like politics uh they
just wish they won more often you know
they
but was menken a libertarian
in a small l sense he certainly was for
letting anybody do whatever they wanted
as long as it didn't harm others i i i
think but but to call him a libertarian
would um
would mean that
menken
had a
strong belief in the sanctity of the
individual the the primacy of the
individual the idea that society and
political uh
organization should be based on the
individual
and i don't think menken's opinion of
the individual was quite that high
amenkan was a believer as many people in
his era were
in the forces of culture
uh he believed he may not have believed
in in in in politics he may not even
have been much of a nationalist
but he did believe in culture
the thoughts of pj o'rourke and we are
coming to you live from union square in
baltimore maryland where h.l menken
lived and worked
and wrote and where he got many of his
ideas we're joined again by marion
rodgers
the writers of this time theodore
dreiser
sinclair lewis ernest hemingway how was
menkin viewed and how did he view those
writers and others
well before we do that i just wanted to
to pop in something else if you don't
mind steve and to say that menken
actually was very much for the
individual man in fact
he was the type of writer who hated the
mob but was for the individual and now
to answer answer your i'm just going
back to something p.j o'rourke said but
to go back to your question
menken
was really the pioneer of literary
critics he he helped all the writers
that we continue to to study today so he
was the first to publish james joyce in
this country he uh
helped the work of f scott fitzgerald
fitzgerald look to menken for an
inspiration and so did sinclair lewis
many of the books that we
study about with sinclair lewis
were taken from ideas and conversations
that he had with menken theodore dreiser
was another
writer that minkin championed
when greizer's work were were being
censored it was menken who was beating
the drum always to promote drizer so
uh people need to remember that
this is one of the great
importances of menken
just very quickly go through his life he
came here at the age of three
he lived here all but five years during
his married life
what did he do when he first began his
career as a reporter
well when he first covered his career as
a reporter he was really covering the
police courts and different aspects of
the city his stories were quite good for
the time i mean he was 18 years old
but menken always said that if he looked
back and and looked at them today he
would shudder uh but he really began his
uh his uh
more his national prominence with an
with a
a stream of columns called the freelance
which was taking place in the early
teens of the 1900s and this is where he
gained his local prominence his national
prominence really happened with the
monday column which he wrote for the
baltimore evening sun
and then we go on with all the other
books that he wrote but it was really
this newspaper column the monday column
that although it wasn't syndicated
really got him into the national
forefront you can follow along on this
series by logging onto our website
americanwriters.org this is a second of
a series of installments as we look at
the life and works of h.l mencken and
continue through the 20th century that's
americanwriters.org or on our website at
cspan.org gilman illinois you're next go
ahead please well my name is carolyn
daly and
back in may 1980 and i had
helped get funding for uh
h l minkin international conference at
chicago's newberry library
and as a result of that i had a
friendship ever since then with a doug
stennerson who has been a professor of a
american literature at chicago's
roosevelt university who's now in his
early 80s and in very poor health but
he was especially interested as you
mentioned a while ago about
minkin's uh friendship with riser and i
know that i've read several books of
volumes of letters of lincoln's
correspondence with ryzer and others and
uh
that he and ryzer i guess they stopped
being really good friends speak when um
when lincoln's mother died and he'd been
very close to her and drizer didn't you
know write the condolence letter or
something that lincoln had expected and
so they didn't have much to do with each
other after that so that is pretty much
a call because i wanted
to sort of get doug stennerson's name
into the record he wrote at least four
scholarly volumes on lincoln i think one
of them which was done as recently as
about 1990.
thank you caller we are in union square
park and directly across the street is
holland street 1524 is where vince
fitzpatrick has now moved to
the relationship between mr macon and mr
dreiser do you want to explain that
yes let me pick up on what the previous
caller said professor douglas stennerson
has done some wonderful writing on
menken and uh he has a book on menkin
and he also was the editor of critical
essays on h.o manc in a fine volume and
he very kindly asked me to contribute to
that and it was a great honor
in terms of the dreiser menken letters
they were superbly edited by professor
thomas riggio of the university of
connecticut
and a number of people myself included
have written on the relationship between
menken and theodore dreiser it was the
most important literary relationship in
each man's career had they not met each
man's career might well have been
different some like the course of
american letters during the 20th century
i believe that the menkin drives a
relationship proves as significant as
say the relationship between emerson and
thoreau and the relationship between
mark twain and william dean hills
our next call is hot springs arkansas go
ahead please
oh thanks for c stand
marion i was uh
just i read his diaries and i've
read some of his books uh edwards
editor's days and some biographies and
it seemed like uh
menkin was
conscious of religion and he was
conscious of grace and mannerisms and
characteristics and
but i don't think it made him a bigot in
any way because if you look at his
actions his
the people that work for him you know
his domestics he paid them well he he
had good relationships a lot the
jewish people could have a lot of
editors he had a lot of friends from
everywhere
and if i'm not mistaken i think that he
even contributed to the
harlem renaissance a little bit by
introducing some authors to kanawha
and i was just kind of wanting your
ideas to know what you thought
yes you're absolutely right and i
appreciate your bringing this up when
menken was the editor of the american
language he was one of the first white
editors to ever publish african authors
african-american authors in his magazine
and he published langston hughes and
w.e.b dubois and george schuyler and
many many others
also menken
really took his took a great risk when
he wrote against a lynching that took
place on baltimore on the eastern shore
of maryland during the
1930s and the nation magazine later
awarded him a prize for courage i mean
there were people who were saying that
if he set foot on the eastern shore he
would be lynched himself his articles
condemning that lynching were so strong
and so original because not many people
were writing against it
that
baltimore goods were boycotted including
the baltimore sun by the entire eastern
shore so menkin was very courageous in
this kind of thing in just a moment
we're going to take you inside the
baltimore row house it was hl makin's
home most of his life but we'll get a
call first from denver go ahead please
well i just wanted to get a call into
you about how funny the man was he seems
kind of lugubrious when you talk about
his iconic classroom and what all but
and i'd like to congratulate you on
getting by the way pj o'rourke on your
program i've had the pleasure of meeting
mr o'rourke a couple of times and he's
right in line of the legacy number one
position of making himself but megan was
a funny writer and he used to laugh out
loud as i understand it when he typed
out his work on his typewriter
using his elbow i think to get the
return carriage to go back and i love
that but i did have a
funny thing that's ingrained
in my memory for just about
forever
and he said the words to the effect that
if the right kind of pressure could be
brought
upon any elected public official he
would come out cheerfully in favor of
bigamy astrology
and cannibalism
yeah lincoln has some funny quotes one
of my favorites is the his i did his uh
his quote on puritanism which he said
it's the haunting fear that someone
somewhere may be happy
and there's another one about bachelors
bachelors know more about women than
married men if not they'd be married to
he has these wonderful one-liners and
the caller is absolutely right reporters
peeping in would find
menken writing in his hotel room during
a convention and actually laughing at
his own prose
was he a drinker
oh yes a man can absolutely adored beer
and in fact and all kinds of drinks he
called himself on amib ambibulus
but uh during prohibition times uh
all of this area of holland street you
could smell the smell of hops in the air
on sundays people were either brewing
bath of gin or bottling beer and
there we have on them on your screen we
have a picture of menken during the
reappeal of prohibition in 1933 the
official repeal prohibition of course
was not until december but in april
roosevelt fulfilled a campaign promise
to bring back beer and mencken who had
written against prohibition he thought
that it was not only against a man's
civil liberties
but it also corrupted the courts and and
produced a lot of harassment to people
by uh the the federal bureaucracy
he took great pride he was invited to
the renard that evening in 1933 he was
going to be given the very first glass
of the
brew as it was poured on 12 midnight
that evening there were hundreds of
people in that room i spoke to a student
from johns hopkins university and he
said he went there just to see history
being made and
when the first frothy glass appeared
at midnight menken lifted it up took one
long
beautiful gulp and everyone leaned
forward they wanted to know what was his
verdict and he said not bad at all fill
it again
it was a marvelous evening for those who
were there in 16 years after prohibition
came to an end this is what h.l menken
said about it
i'm actually i'm baby-less i drink every
known alcohol drink what was that word
ambulance that's a very fine word i
drink every known alcoholic drink and
enjoy them all
and uh
i've always learned early in life how to
handle alcohol i've never had any
trouble with it this rules are as simple
as mud
first
never drink if you've got any work to do
never
if i've got a job of work to do at 10
o'clock at night i wouldn't take a drink
up to that time
uh secondly never drink alone that's the
way to become a drunkard
and thirdly
even if you haven't got any work to do
never drink while the sun is shining
wait until it's dark
by that time
you're near enough to bed
to recover quickly
and back to your calls costa mesa
california you're next on c-span's
american writers series
well thank you i think this is a great
show about a very great american uh i'd
like the guests
to uh
tell the story of menkin's history of
the bathtub by which he tweaked the
noses of editors and readers all over
the united states
and i'd also like to hear some
commentary about nathan's i'm sorry
mankind's partnership with george gene
nathan and thank you very much for
taking my call goodbye
thank you caller marion rodgers yes the
bathtub hoax is very famous in fact it
it still goes on to this day uh and that
was menken wrote the facetious history
of the bathtub and
even wrote about how the first bathtub
was installed in the white house and so
on and he was writing it
during the time of
world war one um
it was really a spoof but people took it
quite literally and he was quite
gratified uh back in the in the 40s that
when president truman a president that
menken did not particularly admire was
giving a tour in the white house and
giving the entire history of the bathtub
which was really menken's own
uh
own prose
as for his friendship with george g
nathan
menken and nathan met
during the 1900s
and they co-co-edited the smart set
together george j nathan is still
considered one of the deans of american
theater critics and did a lot to
influence
the american stage
and they had wonderful years together
perhaps their happiest time together
were during those years of the smart set
then they later went on to edit the
american mercury together they had a
falling out at that time although
neither would ever admit it publicly and
then they were reunited again later in
their lives during the late 1940s
aaron rodgers we're going to go inside
1524 holland street and give our
audience a sense of what it looks like
again just to remind our audience that
he died in 1956 yes what happened
afterwards
well afterwards this row house was in in
the ownership of august mankind that was
menken's younger brother
and then the house
was then later bequeathed to the
university of maryland
then it went on to the city it became
the menken house museum and when the
city life museums went
under here in baltimore the house
remained empty it's empty now which is a
great shame because
unlike many writers homes this house has
almost all of the furniture and books
and stuff of menkins and which is now in
storage but here you can see uh i
believe that's the front parlor which
would would have been considered the
formal social room of the house
this is where he had the piano
this is a typical house of a middle
class family
in the 19th century
there you have menken playing the piano
the other room that is connected to the
front parlor would be the
informal sitting room this is where
menken spent some of his
happiest times it was in these rooms
that menken was
meeting with the lawyers for john's
scopes to to
help the scopes monkey trial it was one
on one of these far walls was a cabinet
full of books and where menken
discovered the adventures of huckleberry
finn
he also had a
cabinet filled with beer steins there
the thing is about this house is that
menken kept saying over and over again
to his brother august
you know i really worry about the fate
of this house i'm afraid that one day
it's going to be empty and abandoned and
it's going to be a wreck
and
right now it's it's not a quite a wreck
but there is a very passionate and
determined band of citizens who don't
want to see it
become that way and
they call themselves the friends of the
menken house and i just want to go back
here we're now in the dining room that
is the wallpaper you see there is a
very close to the original wallpaper
that was there in the window the little
pony frank used to stick his head
through the window and and slurp up
homemade ice cream
but going back to the friends of the
menken house there are many people who
are also supporting the the friends to
see this house going back to being a
living breathing museum that would have
partnerships with school programs and
universities so that this becomes a
a museum that helps the community
and among those who are supporting the
friends include david mccullough william
styron
william manchester russell baker the
actress susan sarandon and many many
others and i believe you have a website
that we can post on the screen and also
an address that you can write to so that
the friends can open up this house and
all of you can come back and visit it
and see
and experience menken's legacy
we're at the corner of holland's in
gilmore in downtown baltimore about a
mile and a half from center city just
off the martin luther king boulevard if
you're familiar with the baltimore area
we're going to take you upstairs and as
we do so we've got a call from medford
massachusetts good afternoon good
afternoon i'd like to ask miss rogers
what do you see as the influence if any
on h.l menken of
an earlier and somewhat similar figure
on the american scene the great infidel
robert ingersoll
who was probably as well known in his
own time for similar reasons of
outspokenness shall we say
as he has forgotten today
thank you
yes well offhand i i can't give you a
direct quote of what he thought of of
ingersoll but
but absolutely
menken was was very very important in uh
in in influencing others and
one of the things he was
he he loved reading the congressional
record
he loved telling reporters to to go and
and read that and you'll get ideas for
stories you'll
you'll actually be able to read the
american language that is spoken by
politicians you'll be able to really
learn what's going on in the world and
this is a
hint that izzy stone later another one
who i guess is a little forgotten today
but is he stone who also read the
congressional record and used it as a
springboard for his prose
his home a four-story row house in the
center of holland street what was on the
second floor
on the second floor was his mother's
sitting room that after her death in
1925 became menken's office and this is
where he he rode some of his uh his
prose and his articles you also had
other bedrooms there and then you go on
and you can see it right here on your
screen uh
this is this is the what was menken's
office probably one of the most
important rooms in the house other than
the garden
the room that meant the most to mankind
here he is upstairs also in one of the
studies that was used before his
mother's death this is the third floor
back study where he wrote the first
edition of the american language in
1919. our next call from san diego good
afternoon
yeah hi a couple of questions uh number
one uh was menken critical of adolf
hitler from the beginning or did his pos
did he evolve on that position number
two the scopes trial
how long was menken in dayton tennessee
and uh did he get along with clarence
daryl and was he part of the defense
strategy
and uh the gene kelly portrayal and
inherit the wind was that an accurate
representation thank you
thank you caller first of all what was
the scopes trial the scopes trial was
one of the first
media events of the 1920s it was called
a trial of the century we've had many
trials of the century since then
but the fact is is in july of 1925
john scopes was a school teacher in
dayton tennessee and he was arrested for
teaching darwin's theory of evolution in
class at the time that was against
tennessee law
and
menken was the one who convinced
clarence darrell who was the famous
lawyer of his day to go down to dayton
and
defend john scopes some of the
preliminary
ideas for the defense were discussed
right here on holland street in his
house with arthur garfield hayes who was
also
a very famous lawyer with the aclu who
was part of the defense team of john's
scopes
so that was a wonderful trial menken
wrote
wonderful articles that were quoted
throughout the country
and during the scopes trial
what was the other question of your
caller you had let me read one part of
what he said describing dayton tennessee
he said i expected to find a squalid
southern village with [ __ ] snoozing
on the horse blocks
what i found was a country town full of
charm
and even beauty
yes
not many of the people in dayton liked
minken because uh he he
wrote about them in in such a in such a
cynical way but actually as for the town
itself menken was quite enraptured with
it he thought it looked like
a town in westminster maryland in fact
and so and he stayed at the home of a
dentist out there in dayton
and uh
and
the two of them corresponded in fact for
many years after the scopes trial had
actually died down and this is what h.l
making had to say about that trial from
july 1925 the audio comes from an
interview that he did in 1948
i remember for instance the scopes trial
wow that was a lot of fun that was a lot
of fun
well it was an overtone of tragedy
don't you think yes it was it was a
dreadful thing to think of presumably
civilized people falling into such a
slough
and it was a dreadful thing to look at a
man like brian a man with his
opportunities in the world
to see what he had come to
intellectually in his old age
it was a tragedy in a way but i should
add it once it wasn't a tragedy to me
i wasn't
suffering anything i was enjoying it
marion rodgers the trial was 1925 five
years later he marries his wife sarah in
1930 and they were married for how long
they were married for five years
the sad thing about their marriage is
although it was a very happy marriage
sarah had always suffered from
tuberculosis and so uh their their
marriage was tinged by illness
menkin took her on various sea voyages
for her health even during those
depression times he was financially uh
comfortable enough to pay for the many
doctors and nurses that were constantly
in the house
and when she died
minkin said quite sadly
the doctors predicted that she had only
three years to live but actually she
lived five so i had two more years of
happiness than i had any right to expect
and vince fitzpatrick who is across the
street on holland street it was 21 years
later when h.l menken passed away in
1946
and he was taken to a funeral home what
three or four homes down from where he
lived yes uh i'm walking up toward that
now lincoln was taken to the whitskey
funeral home on the corner of hollins
and gilmore street
menkin died in the early hours of sunday
january 29 1956
and there was a brief service held here
on tuesday
january 31st 1956. menkin had had not
wished for anything large so it was a
small ceremony the family was here
as well as a small group of friends
alfred a kanov came the novelist james m
kane
some of the sun papers people were here
his close friend dr louis cheslock
and hamilton owens his editor at the
evening sun said a few words and
after which time menken's body was was
taken from the house and cremated and
his ashes were placed in the family plot
in the loudoun park cemetery
it's several miles southwest of here
down the road from the old saint mary's
industrial school that educated babe
ruth another baltimorean who enthralled
america during a better day
menken had chosen his elegy menken had
written his elegy long before it had
appeared in the december 1921 smart set
this was during the tenure of president
warren g harding
much had changed since that time
menken's reputation had risen plummeted
and then ascended once more
but menkin thankfully found no reason to
revise what he had written years before
why did he decide to spend his entire
life in baltimore
well he uh
he found baltimore congenial in a number
of ways it was congenial because he had
family here he had friends here he
enjoyed the ambiance to the city the
place of the city and i guess as
important as anything else the city
was very congenial with his writing
schedule and he found it an easy place
to get work done when he passed away any
regrets about his life no menkin had no
regrets menken had lived fully if there
was only one regret it would have been
that he could have stayed productive up
until the
time of his death the years after the
stroke were very difficult for him
because he he couldn't read and write as
we said but he was a man who had a great
gusto he lived fully every day
and that gusto that vitality is evident
in
in his prose
before we let you go vincent patrick is
there a line or
a graph from all that he has written
that stands out in your mind yes the
thing i'd like to point to is uh is the
epigraph
as i said he written it in december
1921 and
he never saw a reason to change it
and he spoke
in an unusually quiet voice a voice
that's very different from some of the
public writing where mankind was writing
at the top of his lungs
in an unusually quiet voice he asked for
tolerance
if after i deport this fail you ever
remember me and had thought to please my
ghost forgive some sinner and
wink your eyes some homely girl
vince patrick who is the curator of the
menken collection he's also a teacher
here in the baltimore area at loyola
blakefield school and university of
maryland baltimore campus
what else are you working on
thank you very much uh i have a i had
the good fortune to have the opportunity
to write a biography of gerald w johnson
who knew menken very well
it's called uh gerald w johnson from
southern liberal to national conscience
and it will be published this june by
the louisiana state university press my
1989 biography of mankind is currently
being considered for republication in
paperback
and my wife carol and i and our
colleague professor mary beth rashika of
saint john's university in queens new
york are currently working on the fifth
edition of a textbook the complete
sentence workout book to be published by
longmen thank you
vince fitzpatrick who is the curator of
the h.l menken collection joining us
from on holland street just across from
union square thank you thank you and
back to your call san francisco good
afternoon good afternoon i'm enjoying
the program particularly miss rogers
description of hankins views on drinking
because i was the author of a little
book called the ambiguous mr mankin
described as a humorous drinking
biography
of h.l menken
many of the pictures you've used are in
that book
and i'm delighted that the friends of
the h.l menken house are using copies of
the book as premiums to donors to save
the house
really enjoying the program
i'm a big fan of your book and i just
wanted to give viewers that address i
don't know if you have it up there on
your screen but if you're interested in
saving menken's house and want to come
to baltimore and see it please write to
friends of the menken house they're at
733 martin drive
catonsville maryland
21-229-1116 or you can call
410-947-73
or if you are computer literate you can
go to the website
and it's www.menkinhouse.org
i had to give that plugin i just hope
you and you'll join david mccullough and
william styron and so many others to
help save this house
this book merriam-webster's dictionary
of american writers is our companion to
the american writer series you can get
it from our website at
americanwriters.org we also encourage
educators and teachers to log on and
learn more about the lesson plan that's
available from this website next call
from edinburgh texas good afternoon good
afternoon
uh of a wonderful program uh due to
minkin's agnosticism
i'm curious as to what
uh of the his thought of his uh what
would it be his how would he conjecture
dealing with the irony of the middle
east quandary
in religion dealing with between the
jews
christians and muslims
thank you very much i will hang up and
listen to your answer
yes well menken actually visited israel
in 1934
and wrote an article for the baltimore
evening sun called eretz israel which
was later actually put out in book form
and it's quite haunting really to go
back and read what he has to say because
back then
palestine was just beginning to exist
and he said one day these fields are
going to be run over with blood as red
as this earth itself
and if you go back and and look at that
particular article or if you can find
that book which is now a collector's
item uh it's it's it's quite haunting
really
telerosa new mexico you're next
yes howdy uh this is um a comment about
uh the followers as it were of uh h.l
menken
uh it seems that they are
not in newspapers as much as they are in
television or radio such as lenny bruce
or howard stern and especially bill
maher and politically incorrect could
you
discuss that please
thank you
that
let me see if i understand you're right
that his that you're calling these
people they're his followers that are on
tv well i think bill maher i know is a
big fan of
menken and has quoted him from time to
time
and
i think i think there's room for for
all kinds of of people and if they want
to be as outrageous and as controversial
as they like
more power to them
next call alexandria virginia good
afternoon
good afternoon a couple of questions
have been dodged i thought his attitude
toward germany in the two wars
and
his attitude
toward anti-semitism or
racism
that would be considered politically
incorrect today we want the full picture
of
give us it give it to us straight i hope
c-span isn't being affected by political
correctness thank you
yes actually a caller had
had asked this earlier during the scopes
trial question so i'm glad we've come
back to that
during world war ii uh menken actually
was very dismayed about
hitler because
he said that he was a clown and that he
was
ruining any any sort of germany that
german americans like himself or others
had in fact i'd like to read you a
letter
that menken wrote to
to a correspondent
during this this time period and very
briefly he says
i should add that i'm entirely out of
sympathy with the method used by hitler
to handle the jewish question now this
was in 1936 mind you before the any word
of the holocaust but it goes on it seems
to me that the gross brutality to
harmless individuals must needs revolt
every decent man i am well aware that
reports from germany have been
exaggerated again this is 1936 but i'm
also well aware that intolerable
brutalities have been practiced i don't
know a single man of any reputation in
america who's in favor of the nazi
scheme as it stands germany has
completely lost the sympathy it had
during the years following 1920. now
menken did visit germany in 1938
and
he he did take a sense of pride in
seeing how germans had lifted themselves
up from the dreadful reparations that
they were forced to pay during world war
one and that they had taken a new pride
in their country and menken was very
gratifying to see that but to say that
menken was in any way a nazi or that he
was a great fan of hitler would be
totally erroneous
now in the racism question
menken as i mentioned earlier he did
write against lynching he did help
instigate the harlem literary
renaissance he did publish many african
american authors in his magazine behind
the scenes he was helping promote their
works
but in a diary he was using the language
that was common of the time and so this
is what people have latched on to and
this is where some of the focus has been
laid and that's a shame because then one
doesn't get the full picture of menken
but he did come from in this
neighborhood was at the time a german
neighborhood yes it was a
german-american neighborhood although
in his own house
although his family was of german
descent it was an american household
they spoke english there in fact his his
father wrote
the
spoke the slang of the day so uh but
this was a german-american neighborhood
and menken took a great deal of pride in
his roots and his ancestors his
ancestors were from leipzig and were
scholars and had published various books
and menken took a great pride and went
to germany quite often to learn more
about his ancestry and his byline h.l
menken as opposed to henry menken any
reason behind that well menken always
likes to say this that when he was given
a printing press when he was eight years
old that he
ruined the the the
the typeface for for
for some of the letters so that he was
forced to use h.l menken as his byline
and he said that's how it all began
we'll get a call from caldwell idaho
good afternoon
hello there i'm really enjoying your
program about h.l macon and thank you i
just wanted to mention menken was quite
a fan of albert j knock
and he wrote a nice endorsement for the
nokian society in a little
book called cogitations you may know
about it it came from the knock-in
society that was then located at the
foundation for economic education in
irvington new york and i just wanted to
put that into your
into your mixture and i wanted to ask
you a question do either one of you
people
feel like that menken's idea whether he
was agnostic or atheist it seems like
that he hated anything that was
oh he he hated puffery you know whether
it was politicians or preachers and i
wondered if if
if the religious nature of government is
going to be a religion in our country
now you know i wonder if he was here
today if he wouldn't be decrying the
religious nature of government i just
i'll hang up and let you talk about that
thank you very much for your program
yes i think that uh menken would be uh
very much against that after all uh the
the scopes trial was really a
a
a trial about uh not having religion in
the schools and to be able to teach
science and darwin's theory of evolution
and so menken would be uh
disgusted really
and and would want to have the complete
separation of church and state which is
what jefferson wanted and menken as
vince said much earlier in this program
took his ideals from thomas jefferson
in fact he always said if thomas
jefferson came back today he'd be
appalled by what he could see
how much of an influence did he have at
the baltimore sun
menken had a great influence in the
baltimore sun he was very good friends
with paul patterson the publisher
he
behind the scenes he was giving them
ideas for story ideas he was also
was
a board member of the sun in later years
and directing the policy of the paper
and then towards the end which readers
can find out if they read his
autobiographical writing called 35 years
of newspaper work he became rather
disillusioned with the son he became
disillusioned with reporters he said
most of the time they're quitting their
work early in order to play golf
fred rasmussen is with the baltimore sun
and we're going to join him live in just
a moment or two but he has been with
that newspaper since 1973
and talked to us earlier about the
influence of h.l mencken on that
newspaper
menken once said this is a paraphrase
here megan once said when i was a young
man
and my friends were listening to idiot
lectures by pedagogues i was a young
reporter on the street
and he found so much in this city that
was so interesting people and he felt
that this was like the life of kings
being a reporter this is being abroad in
the world doing this kind of work
is just a privilege and he and he never
lost that love for it um
i think when i came here
mankind still was very much a presence
in this building i think
younger reporters menken is kind of an
antique figure
you know they know the name
from j school or they've read some of
the stuff but uh he he doesn't have i
don't think quite the impact
amongst the younger reporters that he
once did uh
when i came here i was so excited oh you
knew how many you were they tell mankind
and of course that's 28 years ago and
there were people here that had started
their 20s who at that point were in
their 50s or 60s or 70s who knew henry
menken and could talk about them and it
was just great for me to listen to those
stories
but um
but he's still here i mean
we have that great quote on that out
there in the lobby which is it says it
all you know
and from our conversation with fred
rasmussen he is now joining us live
outside the menken home on holland
street
more than 40 years after his death is
h.l menken still relevant today
oh i think so it's uh
you know
faces change story stayed the same um
menkin would find uh much to laugh at
marion mentioned a few moments ago about
uh
the kind of religious bend of this
administration
and uh you know
megan menken would find much to a great
buffet to dine from today really
i want to read one this is a series that
takes a look at american history and
what we've tried to do over the course
of the programs
is look at the writings of leading
american writers and get a sense of the
times that they were writing about and
in with history in general he said this
is a quote
it is the misfortune of humanity that
its history is chiefly written by
third-rate men
the first-rate men seldom any impulse to
record or philosophize his impulse is to
act to live to him it's an adventure not
not a syllogism or an autopsy
is that typical minkin
well i you know i i think so that's very
characteristic of menkin um
you know i think the whole world of
journalism i think menken personifies
that certainly uh yeah they often say
reporters are the first people to
witness history gosh knows menken did uh
you hear time and time again about
menkin in the scopes trial menkin on
landon mankind roosevelt uh so that's
all still very relevant and i i think i
would agree with that
i would like to interject something here
too this is from a 1937 letter to paul
patterson publisher of the baltimore sun
papers and i think that any journalist
can take
real inspiration from these words he
said this about journalism i do not
propose that we denounce the
administration incessantly and
unreasonably i only propose that we view
it skeptically and refuse to assent to
its devices and pretensions until we are
sure that they are intelligent and
sincere
every public official with large powers
in his hands should be held in suspicion
until he proves his case and we should
keep him at all times in a glare of
light
these are wise words i think for any
administration and for any journalist
also for any journalist
another 30 minutes as we take a look at
the life and writings and times of h.l
menken as we get a call from appleton
wisconsin you're next on c-span
why did he call his
journal the american mercury
he called his journal the american
mercury
this this was a title that was bandied
about between george j nathan and menken
himself but he wanted to put the put the
words american in the title because this
was specifically an american magazine
that discussed the american scene it was
so influential later when the new yorker
came on the scene they they copied some
of the elements of the american mercury
one of them was americana which was
little snippets of newspaper articles
that were rather funny and which poked
fun and different things and the new
yorker copied this the american mercury
was very influential to magazines all
over the country next call candy oregon
yeah
yes i'm a writer as well as a columnist
and i've also had the great opportunity
of playing henry drummond or clarence
darrow and inherit the win many years
ago
so i fully know the influence of h.l
menken
and i refer and i think he's uh to his
works and i think he was a great
linguist but my and writer but my
question is
it again goes back to the jewish issue i
am jewish
and in one of your quotes
over television this morning
or as this afternoon you say
uh
part of the quote was his handling
referring to hitler of the jewish
question
i know that h.l mankin had a lot of
jewish friends but there's a i i've read
pros and cons of whether he was
anti-semitic or not could you could you
really deal with this right now thank
you so much
i don't i i knew um
menken's nephew admiral powell and i
know marion did also and he was probably
menken's closest family member
uh who cared about henry's work and life
and so forth and
i discussed this issue with him when the
diaries were first published and i was
writing a piece for the sun
admiral labhouse it was very unfortunate
that
he used those words to characterize
people but
not uncommon in those years i think it's
very difficult or
for us we see them we're very shocked by
them
they they they startle us and you wonder
why a man of of this uh brilliance would
be using such language but yet it was
very very common in those days i think
menkin's life as marion vincent earlier
points in the other direction menken was
a liberating force for african americans
he had many many jewish friends he also
uh prevailed upon his friends in the
council of service in the 30s to help
jewish writers he knew get out of
germany so i think his life is really
very reflective of that marian rodgers
why does this issue come up we've heard
a number of calls on this and
you have addressed it in your books
well because i think that this is an
issue that uh it still bothers people
today it was something that
people even talked about in in menken's
day in the in the 30s and then later in
the 40s people were wondering why he
wasn't riding out against
hitler publicly he said these things in
in his in his letters and privately but
he didn't write about it publicly and
part of that has to do with world war
one and the the terrible uh
the terrible censorship really that was
going on in the press the the the uh
horrible uh
fury that was being castigated against
german americans and he
was
sentimentalized germany to such a degree
that he didn't want to be one of those
who spoke out against germany that that
is menken's failing i think as a
journalist that in 1938 when he did
visit that country he did see
certain things that were going on but he
didn't write publicly against them but
even so as as as fred has just mentioned
behind the scenes he was helping
jewish refugees to escape from germany
so he's a very complicated man you can't
really go on one side or the other like
all people he has his failings but he
also has his positive side we welcome
our next caller coming to us from right
here in baltimore
hi um
can you hear me okay
we sure can okay i'm calling literally
right up the street from 1620 holland
street and i'm very obsessed by
the program right now but my i have a
two-part question
the first question
is
what was the overall
feeling of mr menken on the issue of
racism and
the jim crow laws
and the second part of the question is i
don't know if you've announced this or
not but what was the
um
biggest accomplishment
of mr menken during his day or during
his time period
the
the the last piece of mankind wrote
for the sun before his stroke in 1948
was a piece about the
the prevailing conditions of segregation
in druid hill park
uh blacks could not play tennis with
white tennis players and so forth and
they've been a number of incidents where
blacks who did play with whites were
arrested and so forth menken very
strongly came out and said that it was
high times high time such uh ku klux
where he was wiped out of maryland that
uh that african americans paid taxes and
they were entitled to use the parks and
play tennis whatever they whoever they
wanted and
so there again um at the end of his life
uh professional life
you see him coming out very strongly in
that issue
to the second question
menken's greatest achievement i i think
that mankind was a very liberating force
in american journalism
you look to his magazine work as marion
and vince again have said earlier
the bank they they menkin published a
black uh blacks when they couldn't get
into white magazines such as the
atlantic monthly and so forth
participated in the harlem renaissance
mencom's a beacon to a lot of people
both black and white
great influence in american journalism
fred rasmussen who is with the baltimore
sun and marion rogers who has edited a
number of works on h.l menken and will
be coming out within the next year on a
new biography on the author two very
quick questions first of all picking up
on the last point did he shape opinion
at the time oh yes he absolutely shaped
opinion all across the board
people
even when menkin wasn't writing his
articles he was constantly being quoted
and talked about in the newspapers uh he
was he was a celebrity in his day
and have you been able to calculate the
volume of his
writings oh well it's it's millions upon
millions he wrote over 30 books he
contributed to 20 more he wrote hundreds
of over a hundred thousand letters to
correspondence he wrote countless
magazine articles and newspaper columns
uh new new things keep
surfacing to light he he wrote a lot of
autobiographical writings there's a mass
of unpublished material in the enoch
pratt free library in fact mankind took
great pride in saying that he was going
to keep a bunch of nascent phd busy for
years and so he has
including marion rodgers
marietta georgia is next
good afternoon caller
hello
marietta george are you with us
yeah go ahead caller it's marietta
california i apologize
uh two parts um
kind of a fan of minkin not as much as
my grandfather who lived in emporia
kansas i'd like you to compare and
contrast menken's politics with that of
william l and white if you know
and second there's a famous uh quote of
manchester starts off an editorial i
believe about persons guilty of golf and
it goes on and describes
uh the shortcomings of those folks so
could you comment on either of those two
uh well menken always compared golf to
idiocy
they were one in the same word in his
mind uh as for uh comparing him to
william allen white well these they were
friends uh menken knew all of the
foremost journalists of the day they met
each other at camp on the campaign trail
and on convention
at conventions
but william allen white was a great uh a
great supporter of franklin d roosevelt
and as for menken he always said the new
deal has come up with only one novel
idea and that is whatever a earns
actually belongs to b
a is any industrious man or woman b is
any drone or jackass that's the kind of
sentiment that william allen white would
not have subscribed to
baltimore is next good afternoon caller
uh hi this is dr arthur simon baltimore
a couple things i love your c-span i
don't know if you've hit on these in
regards to his attitude toward jews uh
i've read virtually everything he's
written that's available in bound books
except of course the language dictionary
uh and uh i recall him referring to the
jewish boys at city college where
anything he thought about is that they
were so damn smart and fast at the same
time i haven't heard any references to
the saturday night club as soon as i'm
finished here if anybody can refer that
i remember very well i never saw him
there but it was uh a famous watering
hole and a lovely german restaurant on
howard street in baltimore called shell
houses
and
a number of the members of the saturday
night club i i got to know my daughter
was a student at peabody and uh
i think her instructor was a phil uh
cheslock who was there and they drank
beer and had a wonderful time he was
jewish and also our family doctor who
used to make house calls for five
dollars uh a doctor joseph blum uh
uh a man can play the piano and joe
bloom play at viola
uh let me see anything else i'll squeeze
in fast uh i i i love this book on the
prejudices that's when i was first
introduced to it i haven't heard anybody
make references to that uh i've watched
almost his entire show today uh the
heavenly halcyon and a third book of
days that were bound and then the one
who came out about 35 years ago called
the with chris domothy
about 35 years ago and the last point
and thank you for allowing me
when he was married
did he and his wife live on cathedral
street if anybody knows
a lot there to discuss the one book that
you mentioned this is what it looks like
in fred rasmussen if you want to comment
on the other points that the caller
brought up try to move from the end to
the to the beginning uh mankind lived
during his marriage at 704 cathedral
street in a rather lavish apartment with
his wife sarah hard menkin who of course
died
very young
and then he came back here to holland
street caller how far i mean
how far geographically is cathedral
street from where we're located maybe
about two and a half miles it's a mount
vernon near mount vernon place right in
the center of baltimore and uh
and then after he found life there
impossible without sarah it's a rather
large apartment
he came back here with his brother
august to finish out his life
the saturday night club certainly was
the center of mankind's social life
these men were from
newspapermen there were
doctors they were lawyers they were
professional people and they gathered on
saturday night to play classical music
and drink beer
and eat
eat
chopped beef
beef steak tartare and so forth and uh
this was a ritual that went on for well
well over 50 years
there was there's a great mankind story
of a newcomer who was happily dining
away on the beefsteak tar tardy and he
inquired of menkin that
where this wonderful meat come from and
menken said they had very good contacts
in the pathology department at hopkins
hospital and the mankind turned green
but
dr cheslock wrote about the saturday
night club and his wonderful book on
menkin on music and for anyone
interested
in reading that great book
you'll find more about the saturday
night club
marion rogers he
became a reporter when teddy roosevelt
was in the white house and he suffered a
stroke when harry truman was in the
white house how did he view
our presidents during those times
well
menken menken didn't like getting cozy
with presidents he thought it ruined a
person's objectivity so he wasn't one
who would like to go to the press
conference for example of of franklin
roosevelt and succumb as he said to his
christian science smile but but but
menken also
had this to say about presidents and i
have have a quote for you and it really
runs across the gamut of all presidents
he said that
why did men
seek elective office in the first place
and he said
there was a genuine fear of ideas among
americans and
men who had stout convictions and and
strong ideas were really shouldered out
of public life he said eventually they
go in once or twice but then they're
taken over by the intellectual jellyfish
and inner tubes so he said there was
only room for two sorts that become
presidents one was the blank cartridge
who has no convictions at all and is
willing to accept anything to make votes
and secondly the mount bank who is
willing to conceal and disguise what he
actually
actually believes according as the wind
blows hot or cold and he said the
presidency tends year by year to go to
such men as democracy is perfected the
office represents more and more closely
the inner soul of the people we move
toward a lofty ideal on some great and
glorious day the plain folks of the land
will reach their hearts desire at last
and the white house will be adorned by a
downright [ __ ]
h.l menken
and as spring arrives here in this
baltimore neighborhood we'll show you
more scenes around the park you get a
call from westfield new jersey good
afternoon
oh good afternoon uh let me um mute my
tv
okay uh hi my name is dan gutman and i
happen to be holding my copy of
the book you were just showing and
making uh
crestomathy if i'm pronouncing that
right
and
one of my favorite
chapters in that book is one called
quackery
and um
there's a little something that he wrote
in choir chiropractic and um
i'd like to read a few sentences because
i think it's illustrative of
his
barbed wit
is that okay with you
go ahead caller okay
this is called again chiropractic
this preposterous quackery flourishes
lustily in the back reaches of the
republic and begins to conquer the less
civilized folk of the big cities
as the old-time family doctor dies out
in the country towns with no competent
successor willing to take over his
dismal business he is followed by some
hardy blacksmith or ice wagon driver
turned into a chiropractor in six months
often by correspondence
in los angeles the damned there are
probably more chiropractors than actual
physicians and they are far more
generally esteemed
proceeding from the ambassador hotel to
the heart of the town along wilshire
boulevard one passes a long score one
passes scores of their gordy signs there
are even many chiropractic hospitals the
morons who pour in from the prairies and
deserts most of the mailing patronize
these hospitals copiously
and gifted a chiropractic pathology the
same respect that they accord to the
theology of the town sorcerers
that pathology is grounded upon a
doctrine that all human ills are caused
by the pressure of misplaced
vertebrae upon the nerves which come out
of the spinal cord in other words that
every disease is a result of a bench
this plainly enough is buncombe the
chiropractic therapeutics rest upon the
doctrine that the way to get rid of such
pinches is to climb up on a table and
submit to a heroic pummeling by a
retired piano mover
this obviously is bunkum
thank you for that
fred rasmussen
would you call him a curmudgeon
oh absolutely i think he was very proud
of being a curmudgeon remember uh he was
a point of honor with uh with menken
that
he he thought every president from teddy
roosevelt to truman was a fraud i he
loved all that and
as marion said earlier
he felt there was a a
journalistic
junk yard when
the reporter would go to washington and
and lose his objectivity and then
suddenly liked uh donning with the
president and so forth menken issued all
of that
he avoided all of that
no curmudgeon yes absolutely
we by the way want to thank jack sanders
of san diego for allowing us to use a
lot of the audio of h.l menken that you
have been hearing and seeing over the
last uh hour and 50 minutes including
h.l macon's view on being a reporter
you could no more have a 40-hour week
for a good newspaper reporter than you
could have a 40-hour week for an
archbishop
it's just not possible a good reporter
he simply refuses to let a story go and
when he's got his teeth into it
and he wants to wants assignments i i
remember when i went down the office in
the morning
uh
it uh
certainly the
thing that interested me wasn't
whether i'd get a lot of time off and
go home early but whether i'd get some
good assignments
if i got the good assignments i didn't
care how long it worked
i worked many a time all night
when the baltimore fire happened
in february 1904
i was a young city editor
they dug me out of bed about 11 o'clock
in the morning
said a big fire started downtown i went
downtown
i never got my clothes off
or slept
until wednesday morning at four o'clock
and we continue with your calls los
angeles you're next
there the gentleman who just read that
passage from mr menken
the boulevard is pronounced wilshere not
wilshire if you'd like to put us down at
least put us down correctly
going back to the issue of anti-semitism
the fact that it was pervasive at the
time in his works in works of george
orwell believe it or not down enough in
london paris
in works of uptown sinclair in
a newspaper that henry ford published
meetings of america first uh radio
broadcaster father coughlin going on the
fact that it was pervasive does not
excuse it
it really did culminate in the holocaust
and when in 36 or 37 they said oh
there's a hitler and he's a bad guy it
was too late already half a second
do you think h l menken was anti-semitic
well
he was
they were they are today
uh i am a muslim
and since
september
i have seen that happening
more than ever before in this country
and it's like trying to describe a pain
to somebody who has never had it you
don't even recall your last headache how
can i tell you this
and when you sit here in this
remove from history
and try to play with these things it's
dangerous because this is the only thing
that we have to really learn from this
it's not that he drank beer or sat in
this room or was a funny guy
it is that very intelligent very
articulate very expressive people are
often very
wrong people who created this century
henry ford charles lindbergh
these people were aware of the idea that
this group was dangerous and they
destroyed them
they did it they
we'll get a succeeded from fred
rasmussen he can never use his gifts and
talent or
intellectual abilities to to punish
people of different color religions
uh
or ethnic backgrounds that that's not
what henry making was about and if and
if you think that i think you're
misreading mankind's life
we want to thank the menkin society
which has allowed us to incorporate a
lot of the photographs that you have
been seeing over the course of the last
uh two hours
and also the folks in this neighborhood
union square neighborhood and the
baltimore police department which have
cordoned off part of holland street so
that we can provide you with this
program and the folks in the
neighborhood indicative of a baltimore
neighborhood today yes very indicative
very close-knit families and homes are
very important to baltimoreans they
always have been and this is why menken
loved his city karen fretts frank
travato tony and jana prado among those
who have helped us out over the course
of the preparation for this program
we'll get another call from minneapolis
go ahead please
ms rogers a few weeks ago a few months
ago i was in a used bookstore and i
bought a book i had never heard before
or seen before
of
and i'm sure you've read this book it's
1928 by alfred noff it's
published by enough and it's 131 pages
of insults and one-liners about h.l
menken and he obviously accumulated
these and edited them down
and they're absolutely hilarious and
this is the point about agel menken
about why we read him today why we
return to him it's not because he's a
bigot he doesn't tell us anything about
the israeli
muslim situation in in the middle east
today he doesn't tell us about about
race relations he is funny he's
hilarious he had a great sense of humor
and especially he told us about the 20s
thank you
yes that book actually sold quite well
it was one of the biggest sellers of
menken's books but i would like to go
back to that caller because
he says an important point but i would
like to raise this question
degas the great painter was said to be
anti-semitic we don't stop looking at
his ballerinas or horses at the national
gallery t.s eliot of the wasteland was
also said to be anti-semitic and we
don't stop studying the wasteland in our
schools and likewise menken for all for
all of his faults and this man was not a
saint but for all of his faults he
provided a liberating force into this
country he helped us see ourselves as we
had not been seen before he helped many
people with their civil liberties and
that is why we celebrate him today here
in holland street and at union square so
i take your point to that caller and i
realize that he's a he's a funny man
he's a wonderful man but he's also a
very complicated man and maybe that's
what makes him so fascinating our next
call comes to us from scottsdale arizona
good afternoon good afternoon i'd like
to ask miss rogers in reading mankind as
i have over the years
it has always impressed me that his
achievements in writing about the
president and his dialogue seemed to be
more impressive
of our founding fathers who became
presidents
than
those of the 20th century from from
theodore roosevelt all the way through
to
franklin roosevelt that's my first
question and could you come
thank you caller yes uh as i mentioned
earlier in this program and i think
vince has two menken held is his ideal
the founding fathers certainly thomas
jefferson and george washington he found
them gentlemen he thought they were
literary and he thought that they they
held to a man's sense of self-reliance
and individualism and that's why he
celebrated them so very much
one more call indianapolis
you're next yes thank you
i'm just uh have not been quite
satisfied with the biographer's
responses to some of the callers
inquiries about mr minkin's social views
i think that to say that his language
was common for the time
seems a little bit apologetic i think
there are any number of prolific riders
from that time that
that did not take on the reputation of
being anti-semitic or racist and i just
still like to get a clear
answer as to and certainly i would think
that the biographer understands where
those
where that reputation comes from so if
she could address that a little bit more
clearly i'd be
possibly satisfied thank you very much
okay i'll take the challenge and i hope
this response satisfies you one of the
failings that i see of menken is that
as i mentioned earlier when he went to
germany in 1938 he was such a
sentimentalist about the home of his
ancestors that he was blinded to the
fact that many things were occurring
against the jewish people especially at
this time of year the spring of 38 when
uh when when many of them were being
ostracized and and pulled out of their
homes and menken did not write about
this menken
did not he mentioned it a
few times in letters home to united
states but he didn't write about it
dorothy thompson was other journalists
were these were not people who
were
were radicals they were writing about
what they saw menken refused to do that
that to me is his great failing as a
journalist
fred rasmussen would h.l menken
recognize today's baltimore sun
that's a good question
i think he would i think
you look at our
a section or telegraph section
would be
our foreign coverage the editorial page
is still rather bouncy and sprightly
that's a legacy of menkins
if you go back and look at some of those
sun editorials from years back
they were as heavy as a sacred
sacred
concrete no menkins menken's influences
on the paper are still there
you have been with the newspaper for how
long 29 years fred rasmussen who's
joining us outside the menkin home on
holland street thank you thank you and
marion rodgers what is your connection
with the baltimore sun
oh
well my my husband is a columnist for
the baltimore sun his name is jules
whitcover uh but i would say that
menken's great legacy is uh
the liberating force that he provided
into this into this country he was
saying things that no one dared write
about and i think it's a testament to
menken that people have been calling in
today they've been quoting from his
prose they've been laughing over his
humor and they're still riled up about
menken and that's just exactly how
menken would have wanted it how would
you describe his style his writing style
oh well it was absolutely wonderful uh
he said that people used to write to him
and complain that they had to look up
words in the dictionary his uh his use
his words he once said he knew over 25
000 words but his his style is alive one
someone once said that reading mankind
increases your will to live
it's absolutely alive and there's been a
lot of imitators since then who try to
write like menken but there will only be
one h.l menken
and as we conclude our look at uh h.l
menken what was happening during the
times that he was writing and what kind
of influence did he have
during that period well
he personified the 1920s it was a time
of big business but as f scott
fitzgerald once said america was going
on the greatest gaudiest spending spree
in history but it was menken who
reminded us of the bill of rights then
in the 30s mankind of course lost some
of his popularity that more people
believed in the social programs of
franklin d roosevelt than minkin did but
he came gave a comeback back in the
1940s and certainly by the time he
turned 75 during the 1950s uh menken
again was reaching new heights
and in the research that you have been
doing for the book which will come out
within the next year a year or so what
startled you the most what did you learn
that you did not know before going into
that project
well uh that
not many things about men can surprise
me because
i've been living with a man for about 20
years in the course of all the books and
research that i've been doing
but uh it has given me a new
appreciation i guess for baltimore for
the for the love the tremendous love he
had for this city and for his home and
uh and the tremendous love he had for
this country menken may have loved
germany and had many of his roots there
but he loved this country and he was
about a
as american as apple pie marion rodgers
we thank you thank you thanks for having
me and judy cooper we want to thank from
the enoch pratt free library which has
also helped us out in the research for
all of this
more pierce who has produced this
program here in baltimore mark farkas
back in washington eric hanson and a
very very dedicated crew of people who
have been here behind the cameras
running the audio and making sure all of
this goes well technically we want to
thank them all of it's supervised by
gary ellenwood we're going to leave you
with more of the words of h.l menken he
completed his formal education at the
age of 15. this is what he said about
his life as a reporter as we thank you
for joining us from baltimore
and never went to school since thank god
uh
most men at escaped college
have a
a regret for susan
but i must confess i'm much too vain to
have any such regrets i
think that what i was doing when the
boys in my generation were in college
listening to idiot lectures and
cheering football games and doing all
the foolish and silly and useless things
that college boys do
i was a young reporter on the street
and i believe
18.
i believe that a young newspaper
reporter in a big city at that time
led a life it has never been matched on
earth
wow
so
marion elizabeth rogers biography mankin
and american iconoclast is a compilation
of archival interviews love letters and
fbi files that shed light on the public
and private life of the journalist
next she'll talk about h.l menken for
about 40 minutes
new biography titled menken an american
iconoclast in it she profiles the man
considered by many to be one of the most
influential public voices of the 20th
century
some of the uh advanced praise has been
quite astounding kirkus reviews said a
superb study the best biography of
menkin to date publishers weekly said as
rogers shows in this thorough work
menkin was more than a newspaper man and
prolific author this is a meticulous
portrait of one of the most original and
complicated men in american letters
charles a fletcher editor of the diary
of h.l menken and author of menkin a
study of his thought says the most
complete and most living picture of h.l
menken that has ever been attempted
written with vividness and even
poignancy this is a definitive biography
menkin was a newspaper journalist famous
wit and constant figure of controversy
rogers
excuse me rogers takes us through his
professional and personal life from turn
of the century america into the roaring
20s through the depressed 30s and the
home front during world war ii capturing
the irrepressible spirit and irreverent
charm for which menkin was famed sure to
be a must for any consumer of
biographies and american history please
join me in welcoming marion elizabeth
rogers
thank you very much
i appreciate your being here this
evening especially because it's so rainy
and so foul outside but i know what
you're thinking
another biography on menken there isn't
anything new to say about menken ah ye
of little faith
well it's true you could spend a
lifetime researching h.l menken he's
been called the most volcanic newspaper
man ever known
in an age where journalists are pegged
as being from the left or the right
menken defies categorization
some called him horrible henry
some called him worse
but few could remain indifferent
he began his career as a journalist in
1899 when technology had not invaded the
newsroom in fact a telephone when heard
at all was regarded as a toy
his newspaper career ended in 1948
after television had made its debut and
during the years in between menken wrote
literary and social criticism a
newspaper column he edited two magazines
he also wrote a hundred thousand letters
to people ranging from groucho marx to
herbert hoover
but there's other material new material
never revealed that gives us fresh
glimpses of menken gathered from 60
different libraries from all over the
country and germany there's love letters
and fbi files and white house memos
and the unpublished diaries and memoirs
kept by menkin's secretaries and his
lovers and fellow reporters
you know someone once said that peop
that women like writing biographies
because
they enjoy reading other people's mail
well
in that case i'm guilty because you know
i get bored just reading about what
menken has to say about mencken i also
like reading the letters that menken's
contemporaries wrote to each other with
their insights about his influence and
their gossip about his love life and
there's also material that's so new it's
not even in libraries
so many generously searched their
addicts for papers or loaned their
collections to me
now what menken said he looked for in a
biography was a story
a story that provides illuminations into
someone's character so that the subject
becomes vividly alive and some of my
favorite details comes from this new
material
here's the man for example that people
say never suffered from writer's block
but who becomes so depressed after his
mother dies that all he can do is sit at
his typewriter and stare into space
and the man for all his bragging and
self-esteem
who says he always considered himself a
failure
and when you take all this material
together
a rounded picture of menken begins to
form we see the public menkin the
american iconoclast that we celebrate
here tonight the man who predicted on
some great and glorious day the plain
folks of the land will reach their
hearts desire at last and the white
house will be adorned by a downright
[ __ ]
the writer who opposed the telephone
saying no man can hear his telephone
ring without wishing heartily that
alexander graham bell had been run over
by an ice wagon at the age of four
imagine what he would have said of cell
phones
and the man who wrote
heave an egg out of a pullman window and
you'll hit a fundamentalist almost
anywhere in the united states today
and there also emerges from all of this
new material a picture of the private
menkin the man who tried to hide from
his future biographers all the evidence
of his love affairs
menkin's friends called him the german
valentino they used to say how's the
great lover
well women were fascinated by menken and
he was fascinated by them
i don't know if you know this but menken
was the inspiration behind gentlemen
prefer blondes
anita luz wrote it one evening after
menken was paying more attention to a
blonde than to her
he was also known as america's
best-known bachelor the patron saint of
single men the man who famously
maintained that a man may be a fool and
not know it but not if he's married
the man who said bachelors know more
about women than married men if not that
be married to
now there is an entire soap opera about
menkin's love life in this book and then
just when this bachelor ends up finding
real happiness in his marriage his wife
tragically dies five years later of
tuberculosis
now as you can gather from my talk here
tonight
writing the biography of another person
becomes in many ways an effort to re
recreate by selection the texture of a
life
i moved back to baltimore to be in a
city that menken loved to walk the
streets that he walked what the
biographer richard holmes calls a
tracking of someone's path through the
past to bring it alive in the present
and you know i think most biographers
feel this way david mccullough speaks of
a tactile connection the feeling that we
get when we work with documents and from
visiting a historic place
there's the connection that we get with
menken when we handle one of his
original letters and can trace his
spidery signature and in one of them see
the circular print and the blot of foam
left by his beer mug
that has smeared the ink well that
physical connection that we get with
menken
is the same feeling we get when we visit
his house
and that's why it's such a shame that
the menkin house museum in baltimore is
closed bare of the books and the cycles
all the layers of personal history that
a biographer just can't get from
microfilm
and i truly hope that one day this house
can be saved now you're thinking why
should we care
because it's through places that we get
the feeling for the person who live
there
more than anything else they send us
back to the writer's work the same
feeling we get when we visit
samuel johnson's house in london or
ernest hemingway house and key west
it it just brings the person's work
alive
and it's shameful because menken loved
baltimore
now there's a lot about baltimore in
this book but i also tried to capture
how the country felt about menken when
he came upon the american scene as
something exciting and new
during a period when just as now the
press was under scrutiny and the bill of
rights under attack
now 50 years after mankind's death
menkin's america does not seem that much
different from our own
it was a world of evangelical christians
hostile to science
a world where there was a split between
the rural areas and the cities with a
climate of censorship and prejudice and
attacks on dissenters
but it's the timelessness of menkin's
views and the vividness of his language
that are central to a consideration of
his life
now young people could learn a great
deal today about from menken's writing
because his vocabulary numbered over 25
000 words he brought
real adrenaline to the gray and pulpy
style of the day he refused to use
cliches he was called america's george
bernard shaw with a wit like oscar wilde
but he was a force that believed in
liberty above all else
menken's defense of liberty is evident
in a series of reports on the scopes
trial he believed that religion should
not be injected into the study of
science in school classrooms now i
travel to dayton tennessee to do
research and
you won't be surprised to hear
that there are those who still regard
menkin as the stinker
and think that clarence darrow basically
killed william jennings brian with his
inquisition
if so as menken said that was a job of
public sanitation that daryl never
regretted
mankind's belief in free speech is also
seen when menken was arrested in boston
when he sold a copy of his censored
magazine to the head of an outfit which
lived up to menken's definition of a
puritan men can define puritanism as the
haunting fear that someone somewhere may
be happy
menken's fight for free speech is seen
again when he took over the editorial
page of the baltimore evening sun now
menken called the editorial page
journalism's grandest failure how many
read it he asked
you know it reminds me of a complaint of
an editor it's disgusting but it's very
appropriate he said editorial writing is
like wetting your pants in a blue surge
suit it gives you a nice warm feeling
all over and nobody notices
now any journalist who wants to have his
work read should take a look at h.l
menken he not only made his readers
laugh
but
he made them question and he made them
think
i think we're going to see a menkin
revival and the reviews that are coming
in for this book they all be saying
they're all saying the same thing oh
menken where are you now when we need
you
now it's tempting to make parallels with
his day and ours but what i've tried to
do in this book is to put menken in the
context of his times
now people have asked me over and over
again if menken was a bigot
now certainly menken could be unfair he
could arouse feelings of betrayal and
those who would blindly set him up as an
idol
there's no question he was a man of
contradictions and i explored those
contradictions in this book
here was a man who wrote against
prejudice yet who held many of his own
here's a man who wrote against tyrants
who wrote against hitler but only in
private whose sentimental attachment and
loyalty to his german ancestry seems to
have made him insensitive like so many
americans were insensitive to the first
rumors of nazi atrocities during world
war ii and it's disappointing isn't it
one expects better
but then consider this
when roosevelt was doing nothing to open
the gates for jewish refugees when the
prevailing mood of the country was
anti-semitic when walter littman was
writing in the pages of time magazine to
send all the immigrant jews to africa
would a bigot be going against the grain
and writing a column saying open the
gates
and would it bigot be among those who
sponsored jewish families to come to the
united states and when it comes to
african americans and here again is
where menkin again has been criticized
would a bigot in the face of personal
danger be writing against lynching when
no one was doing so and this is 1917 and
the 1930s
and would a bigot be the first white
editor to publish the works of black
authors in his magazine for example the
work of langston hughes and others
and then promote their work to other
americans and
last i'll ask you if would a bigot
be be writing against segregation as
menken did and entertain african
americans in his house
you know these are the paradoxes that we
see and complicated figures in history
menken used to wonder how people would
view him after he was dead it doesn't
matter what people think of me he said
what matters is what i've done
and what he did was considerable because
for all his faults he was a defender of
freedom above all else
and freedom is menken's mantra it's the
running theme throughout this book
when menken develops as a literary
critic we see him battle for freedom
from the victorian anglophile tradition
that stifled american literature
many of the writers that we know today
are the writers that menken promoted
and then menken fought for civil
liberties from for whites and blacks and
finally during the two world wars we see
men can fight for freedom of the press
and i'd like to concentrate on this last
point because i think if you take the
two world wars and the journalism for
that period you'll begin better begin to
understand the free speech issues which
were so important to menken that even
led to his myopia about the war
now we all know that all of us are the
result of various influences but one
cannot underestimate how
much the first world war and the time
leading up to it affected menken because
as a german american world war one
really turned menken's life upside down
pacifists were jailed children who
refused to sing the national anthem in
school were suspended the department of
justice spied on american citizens the
german language disappeared even food
was renamed the hamburger became the
liberty sandwich
and in the patriotic fervor that existed
support for the war could be seen
everywhere in washington right here in
washington
senators in those days wore little
enameled american flags on their coat
lapels and any newspaper editor that
offered any negative discussion of the
war could face 20 years in prison
now in his newspaper columns menken
tried to provide a balance well as you
can imagine mankind's stand provoked a
lot of criticism
and looking back to this period menken
wrote the kinds of courage i really
admire are not whooped up in war but
cried down
no one and such times ever praises the
man who seeks to restore the national
thinking to a reasonable sanity on the
contrary he's regarded as a shabby an
evil fellow
now does it surprise you
when i tell you that once again here at
home menken is being called un-american
yet no one battled harder for the bill
of rights than h.l mencken people from
other countries recognized this
recognized this in europe they called
menken one of the most genuinely
american things that we have now with
all this talk of free speech
it's not surprising that when we come to
world war two
menken takes the same stand as he did in
world war one
now one cannot talk about menkin's
reaction to world war ii
without discussing menken's reaction to
franklin roosevelt
why did menken seem to have such a
hatred towards fdr
well there were roosevelt social
programs for one thing although they did
so much to help the underclass men can
recognize none of it
another reason that menken was against
roosevelt was because of the president's
blemishes regarding civil rights and
this has never been examined very much
but this was really a key point with
menken
there was the internment of japanese
americans and also the way roosevelt did
nothing
nothing to stop the lynchings that were
taking place around the country and it
was menken in fact who joined forces
with the naacp to stop these atrocities
and i've already mentioned menkins
columns about opening the doors to
jewish refugees escaping from nazi
germany
but
one of the main reasons why men can
dislike roosevelt
was how he eroded freedom of the press
and clues to this can be found in
menken's unedited original versions of
his papers
now i'm very much aware
that sometimes menken can embellish a
story at the expense of fact
so every time i came across something
horrid that menken said about roosevelt
or accused him of of doing that same way
over the top
i decided to check it out for myself in
roosevelt's papers at hyde park
and what i found there is not very
savory about a president who has
accomplished so many things for this
country and
don't get me wrong this is not
revisionist history
among the papers at hyde park you'll
find in fdr a skillful politician who
wiretapped newspapermen who he didn't
like
who used the fbi to intimidate
journalists whose own attorney general
wrote privately in his diary that he
couldn't believe the liberties that his
president had taken who used the justice
department and other government agencies
to attain private ends
now
menken was not the only reporter who was
aware of these things during this time
others knew about it but menken was not
writing for his paper by then and no one
else wrote about it because with the
bombing of pearl harbor the unity of the
american public had locked into place
but it's in times like these menkin said
where we confront the greatest challenge
to the press
especially when a president is popular
and especially when the country is at
war as menken said it's the role of the
press not to get cozy with politicians
but as he put it to put to keep a wary
eye on the gentleman who run this great
nation and only too often slip into the
assumption that they own it
now an adroit president can wield a
great deal of power when the press is
mediocre
and menken understood this very well
shortly afterwards menken suffered a
stroke leaving him unable to read or
write
there was a time when mankind used to
rub his hands over his desk he really
enjoyed the feel of the wood and now
that's all the desk was good for
and as the years of menkin's illness
wore on as the 1950s wore on a slow
creeping inertia set out across the
country
as never before americans had become
cautious and silent
statistics show that many americans were
watching tv
five hours a day
you know what tends to be forgotten
about menken was his courage it was the
one virtue that menken most admired it
was
menken's courage that made him speak out
against things that were wrong when no
one else was doing so
which brings me back again to the
question why should there be another
biography on menken
well to answer that i'd like to share
with you something
that william manchester sent to me
shortly before he died it's a small
piece he wrote
he said
50 years ago i spent my mornings
reading to an old man who suffered as i
now suffer from a series of strokes
he was a writer
he was h.l menken i have never known a
kinder man
but when he unsheathed his typewriter
and sharpened its keys
his prose was anything but kind
it was rollicking and it was ferocious
witty intellectual polemicists are a
vanishing breed today
their role has been usurped by
television boobs whose iqs measure just
below their body temperatures
some journalism schools even warn their
students to shun words that may hurt
but sometimes words should hurt that's
why they're in the language when
terrorists slaughter innocents when
corporation executives swindle
shareholders when lewd priests betray
the trust of little children it's time
to mobilize the language and send it
into battle
when menkin died in january 1956 he was
cremated that was a mistake
he should have been rolled in malleable
gold and polished to blind the cosmos
i still miss him
america misses him more
thank you
thank you very much
for following questions please feel free
raise your hands
yes go ahead
i think by now aren't you glad you
stumbled over that box of letters thank
goucher college library
yes uh the story is that some of you may
know that
in 1981 when i was a student at goucher
college i was writing a feature story
for our school newspaper on sarah hart
and sarah hart was an alumna from the
school
and she was the woman whom menken later
married
and klutz that i am i tripped over this
box which said do not open until 1981
signed h.l menken and the year was 1981
and that coincidence
led me on a different path which led to
menken and sarah and then
the impossible h.l menken which was a
selection of his best newspaper stories
and now with this but i think i'm going
to stop with this
any other yes i had the library of
congress interviewed that lincoln did in
the late 40s and i wonder if you know of
any other
filmed or recorded interviews that uh
are expanded yes this uh this library of
congress interview that the gentleman is
referring to
was one that he uh recorded in the
summer of 1948 actually was close to
september so he was suffering from hay
fever you can hear his sniffling
throughout the
interview um and it was just a few
months shortly before he had a stroke
and was unable to give such interviews
and there's a few other recordings
actually at the library of congress uh
radio recordings of not so much
interviews but um
radio shows one was about prohibition
and beer and it's about much younger
menkin it's very interesting to hear the
voice how much younger it sounds
and that would have been in the 1930s
and then
in terms of films
there are some films actually
among alfred knopp's papers at the
university of texas
the harry ransom humanity research
center
and
alfred knopf was a very well-known
photographer for those of you who don't
know that he took wonderful pictures of
all kinds of writers that he published
and he also has this brief little film
strip of menkin and and there's another
one as well that another person from
baltimore had taken and when i first saw
this film strip
it was such a shock because
here i had spent all these years
studying menkin and studying his
photographs getting lost in these
photographs and then to have this man
spring to life and on film it was like
seeing a ghost
and i had
vivid dreams for weeks afterwards
a film yes believe called mankind's
america
made by channel 2 in baltimore
by twin owens who is the son of
hamilton's who worked with the lincoln
at the sun papers yes and that was the
time i knew it
you know very old format
but i hope it's been transferred
yes
this is the film by gwen owens called
menkins america i believe it was made in
the 1950s
and uh and so there's that film as well
you're right
uh yes
i noticed in your book you have a
chapter on the scopes trial and there
were two big trials in mid 1920s america
and the other one was the leopold and
loeb trial
which was also a clarence darrow case
and i'm wondering if menken
made any comment or had anything to say
about that case
yes
he wrote
he mentions it from time to time the um
the famous uh leopold lope case that
clarence daryl
did but it was this case the scopes
trial um scopes monkey trial as it was
called in 1925 that menken is best
remembered for
for some of you who don't know
that was called in those days the trial
of the century i know there's been many
since then
and it was the trial where john scopes
was arrested for teaching the theory of
evolution in school and it was clarence
darrow who elicited menken's help uh to
to help out with his trial and menkin's
columns that became syndicated all over
the country and which
elicited a great deal of fury
uh there was a question back there yes
comment on the accusation that minkin
was a mama's boy oh
yes from time to time especially
recently people have said that menken
was a mama's boy
but quite frankly
i really find that phrase rather
patronizing because
if we put menken back in the context of
his times
in those days
a bachelor
and
who had a mother living at home and
sisters
in menken's case one sister
he wouldn't have left the house he would
have stayed to be the man of the house
but everybody's going around saying that
menken was a mama's boy which is is very
wrong he adored his mother he was very
close to his mother
but to call him that is
is a bit wrong
yes
did meghan believe in democratic
institutions i know he didn't feel that
people were a great repository of wisdom
right well that's coming from about
menken and and democratic institutions
uh one of menken's uh words that he
coined which uh some of you may be
familiar with he talked about the
bouboisi
the great mass of democracy um he always
said that he wrote for the civilized
minority
and
he believed in the democratic
institutions i mean
after all menken was a great proponent
of free speech and the bill of rights
and so um he always considered himself a
lifelong democrat
so yes he believed in those but you
wouldn't think so by uh coming across
his work and in fact uh maybe that's why
a certain congressman to this day are
calling menken un-american
no he wasn't pro-confederate what what
menkin what menken admired was um
virginia and the uh
the certain civility from virginia but
he wasn't pro-confederate he didn't
believe in slavery but what he what he
truly disliked was abraham lincoln he
said that the way abraham lincoln
manipulated the press
um and so that was something he wrote
against
yes
i mentioned that he's hard to
characterize as being on either the left
or the right and i've heard this tossed
about would it would it be accurate to
characterize him as one of the first
real libertarians like albert j knock or
something like that yes was was uh would
i characterize menken as one of the
first real libertarians
yes he was because he always prided
himself in his independence um just now
i was saying that menken considered
himself a lifelong democrat
his views uh especially in the beginning
of this century were considered very
liberal and that's why when menken uh
switched and was against fdr's new deal
programs people began seeing him as very
conservative but actually menken had
never really changed he had always he
had always stuck to uh
the belief of independence and so that's
what makes him libertarian
uh
another question back there can you
comment on how you think menken might
have regarded the current controversy
over the right of rep reporters to
keep the confidentiality of their
sources
yes how i would regard
how menken would view
reporters who try and keep the
confidentiality of their sources
well i had that marvelous quote about
where he said that
reporters should never become too cozy
with politicians that they should keep
keep the president's key politicians
always under the glare of light and in
fact
during the roosevelt era when uh many
reporters in the white house press corps
were getting very very cozy with uh with
the president and his people they were
going to clan bakes and all kinds of
things
menken purposely said uh put himself
back he refused to go because as he said
i'd hate to come under the influence of
fdr's christian science smile
he knew that roosevelt was very charming
and he wanted to keep his objectivity
before you i think there was another
question right here sorry
we look at some of the great american
writers that talked about what was
happening in our country mark twain
ambrose beerus
a hundred years later
what would it take to produce another
writer of the quality of hl
well i think we're living what would it
take to produce another writer of the
quality of h.l menken
i think we're living in those times now
there are a lot of writers that
people equate with meninkin uh pj
o'rourke is one the biting language of
marine dowd is another but what makes
menken so very unique
is the cadence of his language there's a
strain of a mu of the musician in menken
which i talk about in this book but it's
also that he was such a renaissance man
i mean here he was uh changing the
course of american literature with his
magazines
had studied science knew so much about
law and so if we
wanted to produce another menkin it's
not only the times but it's also
someone of that stature and that
intelligence and that talent really
yes
uh early on minkin wrote that you never
accept a ticket to something you're
going to review
never never have it accept a ticket to
something you're going to review
right
right right you're absolutely right
yes
well as far as menken and journalistic
ethics go um he's quite famous for the
bathtub hoax for example but i know in
your book who also mentioned a few other
news items that menken was not fully
honest about especially regarding the
russo-japanese war early on i'm just
wondering whether that's something that
ended pretty much in that period or
whether uh later on he continued to come
up with hoaxes which people may or may
not really have realized were right not
quite honest well menken there's that
there's a bit of the of a pecks bad boy
in menken he has a lot of mischief
and uh the the um hoax or the
the the story that you're referring to
was in 1904 now this is in his
autobiography and he's very proud of it
he's he writes about this in the 1940s
and
it was when his his first paper the
baltimore baltimore morning herald was
losing readers
and
you know in those days we didn't have
the telephone we didn't have cnn
we didn't have all kinds of things and
so no one knew what was happening with
the russia japanese war and all these
papers were scrambling to get the first
lead
and so
menken decided that the way he was going
to bring his paper back to life
was if he studied the battle plans
he could kind of fudge it and so he did
i mean he he wrote about the battle he
um different battleships he used he used
facts but he kind of stretched a little
and in his autobiography he says well
you know all these years later i was
still right but the fact fact was if you
go back to the original papers of that
period you see that a lot of readers of
the herald had noticed that he had lied
and they started questioning him about
it now
again in 1905 the year later um a lot of
journalists were being questioned about
made-up stories here and there in the
press because it wasn't as harsh in
those days as now
and um and so menken came out and said
in an interview that falsifications
would have to die
and that that sort of thing couldn't be
done
and it's only much later in his life
that he um that he stretches the truth a
little but that's when he's writing his
memoirs that three volumes that i would
suggest highly to all of you if you
haven't read them happy days newspaper
days and heathen days and i forgot to
mention you're right there was the
bathtub hoax in 1917
when he uh invented the history of the
bathtub and he uh he talked about you
know the bathtub in the white house and
the different presidents that had used
the bathtub and he went on and on
and
you know and in the 40s harry truman was
giving tours to the white house and he
was mentioning the history of the
bathtub and it just went on
and menken had to finally put a stop to
this bathtub hoax but with menken under
the humor there's always a serious
purpose because
when he was riding this bathtub hoax in
1917
um
there had been a lot of false stories in
the press and he was really making fun
of the gullibility of americans who
believe anything and so i think his best
of hoax was not only a way to have fun
but just to
to test the climate
yes
there uh was an embargo placed on
lincoln's page of papers for a period
after his death i wonder if those are
all available now
yes uh menken imposed three different
embargoes on his paper it was 1961
1971 and 1981
and those those were done in different
stages jonathan yardley says that maybe
he did it that way so that he'd always
be talked about
there's probably a lot of truth to that
and there and when it came to his
memoirs uh 35 years of newspaper work
and my life as author and editor
which was a set of memoirs that he never
finished writing before his stroke
the reason he put that embargo last was
because he didn't want the people that
he was talking about to still be alive
when those papers came out he didn't
want their feelings hurt
yes was he beloved during prohibition by
the
people in baltimore in the social
circles or was it a love hate type of
relationship well everyone loved what
menken was saying about prohibition
because during those 13 awful years that
prohibition was enforced people were
really suffering
i mean
i mean people were brewing
the bathtub gin in their bathtubs and
going blind
a lot of people were brewing beer and
getting sick as a result
and there was a lot of drunkenness going
on there was actually more drunkenness
than the prohibitionists ever wanted um
and so so
people really liked what he was saying
and he drummed the point again home
again
more and more because he thought
prohibition was against our civil rights
in fact i would say that today the fact
that you can go out and have a beer is
really thanks to menken
and
when prohibition finally came to an end
in 1932
uh it was the press that focused on him
and in baltimore at the renard hotel
he is the picture in fact which is the
cover of this book is menken having the
first beer of prohibition and all the
cameras are popping and he says not bad
fill it again
yes marion i know you obviously had to
do a lot of research for this book but
was there any particular part of the
research that you found more satisfying
than others
well the research was a lot of fun
because uh menken is so amusing and you
never know
what you're going to find so so the
menkin room at the enoch pratt free
library is a place that you always hear
people laughing
and but what i can tell you what i found
really the most painful and what i found
the most painful was when i was writing
about menkin's relationship with women
there was one woman named marion bloom
that he courted on and off
and there was another
movie actress named eileen pringle who
was a silent film star in the 1920s she
had everything going for her and she
really made herself become victimized by
menkin's behavior because this was a
celebrity this was a man who could have
anybody
and uh
but what what menken used to do he had a
habit of always telling women that uh
when he would break up with them he
would say okay now um i'm returning all
the letters you wrote to me and now you
read return all the letters that i wrote
to you and i'm going to burn them and
you should do the same thing
and a lot of these women obeyed they
would you know be this exchange of
letters and so when eileen got her
packet of letters that she had written
to menken and she wrote to him every
single day these are heart on your
sleeve kind of letters
she thought twice about it i mean what
is a woman to do
so she kept these letters and she gave
them to yale university and the and
what's very nice about these letters is
it's not lopsided it's actually very
revealing because you you sense what's
going on
with menken and with eileen and she kept
a little sprinkling of his letters as
well
and she said to him
my letters will haunt you beyond the
grave